even christians
um
want to say you know you without sin
cast the first stone but the bible also
talks about
uh
how do you say it um
you know obey the laws of the land and
you know if we get pulled over for a
speeding ticket you can't say well let
me i'm gonna put this up with me and my
god and and uh you know please let me go
thanks for your points up next here on
c-span 2 gavel to gavel coverage now
today's session of the us senate this
will all re-air in its entirety on our
companion network on c-span tonight at 8
o'clock eastern time
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
almighty god
guide the senators today as they move
closer to the completion of this
impeachment trial
and confront some of the most difficult
decisions of their lives
give them physical strength and mental
fortitude for this day
in anticipation of your burden lifting
blessing
we place our trust in you
we renew our prayers for peace in the
middle east
thank you for the life and leadership of
king hussein of jordan
that persistent peacemaker
an emissary of light in the often dim
negotiations for just peace
not this time of his untimely death
we pray for the people of jordan and for
his son
king abdullah
as he assumes the immense challenges of
leadership
in your holy name
amen amen
[Music]
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
the chair recognizes the majority
thank you mr chief justice
this afternoon the senate will resume
consideration of the articles of
impeachment and pursuing to s
res 30
the senate will proceed to final
arguments for not to exceed six hours
equally divided between the house
managers and the white house council
at the conclusion of those arguments
today i would expect the senate to
adjourn over until tomorrow
and we will expect tonight when we go
out of the impeachment trial to uh have
a period for legislative business so
that we can pass a resolution or
consider a resolution with regard to
king hussein
i now ask consent that when the senate
completes his business today it send and
adjournment to reconvene as a court of
impeachment at one pm on tuesday
february nine
without objection and so ordered and
mischief justice i ask unanimous consent
that the february 5th 1999 affidavit of
mr christopher hitchens and the february
7th 1999 affidavit of ms carroll blue be
admitted to the evidence of this
proceeding
is there objection
from the trial i'm compelled to object
objection is heard i believe we're ready
to proceed mr chief justice
the chair recognized mr manager sensing
browner
chief justice
distinguished counsel for the president
and senators
i'm congressman jim sensenbrenner
i represent 580 000 people
entire service in congress i have served
as a member of the committee on the
judiciary of the house of
representatives
we are nearing the end of a long and
difficult process
the senate has considered for the past
several weeks the grave constitutional
responsibility
to determine whether the actions of
president clinton merit his conviction
and removal from office
the senate has been patient attentive
and engaged throughout this unwelcome
task and for this the house managers are
grateful
the managers would also like to thank
the distinguished chief justice for his
patience and impartial demeanor
throughout this trial
at the outset of the manager's closing
arguments it is important to distinguish
what has caused only the second
presidential impeachment in history from
extraneous matters that bear no relation
to the verdict the senate will shortly
reach
when this trial began four long weeks
ago
we said that what was on trial was the
truth and the rule of law
that has not changed despite the lengthy
legal arguments you have heard
the truth is still the truth and a lie
is still a lie
and the rule of law should apply to
everyone no matter what excuses are made
by the president's defenders
the news media characterizes the
managers as 13 angry men
they are right and that we are angry but
they are dead wrong about what we are
angry about
we have not spent long hours pouring
through the evidence
sacrificed time with our families and
subjected ourselves to intense political
criticism to further a political
vendetta
we have done so because of our love for
this country
and respect for the office of the
presidency regardless of who may hold it
we have done so because of our devotion
to the rule of law and our fear that if
the president does not suffer the legal
and constitutional consequences of his
actions the impact of allowing the
president to stand above the law will be
felt for generations to come
the almanac of american politics has
called me a stickler for ethics
to that i plead guilty as charged
because laws not enforced are open
invitations for more serious and more
criminal behavior
this trial was not caused by kenneth
starr who only did his duty under a law
which president clinton himself signed
it was not caused by the house judiciary
committee's review of the independent
council's mountain of evidence
nor was it caused by the house of
representatives approving two articles
of impeachment nor by the senate
conducting a trial mandated by the
constitution
regardless of what some may say
this constitutional crisis was caused by
william jefferson clinton and by no one
else
president clinton's actions and his
actions alone
have caused the national agenda for the
past year to be almost exclusively
concentrated on those actions and what
consequences the president and the
president alone must suffer for them
this trial is not about the president's
affair with monica lewinsky
it is about the perjury and obstruction
of justice he committed during the
course of a civil rights lawsuit filed
against him and the subsequent
independent council investigation
authorized by attorney general janet
reno
the president has repeatedly apologized
for his affair
but he has never
never apologized for the consequences of
the perjury and obstruction of justice
he has committed
perhaps those decisions were based upon
a dick morris public opinion poll which
told the president that the american
people would forgive his adultery but
not his perjury
perhaps it was for another reason
whatever the white house's motivations
were
the fact remains that the president's
apologies and the statements of his
surrogate contritionists have been
carefully crafted for the president to
continue to evade and yes avoid
responsibility for his deceiving the
courts to prevent them from
administering justice
because the president's actions to
obstruct justice are so egregious and
repeated many have ignored his grand
jury perjury charges before you in
article one
i wish to point out four glaring
examples of william jefferson clinton's
perjurious false and misleading
statements to the grand jury
and not at the civil deposition in the
paula jones case
first the president lied under oath to
the grand jury when he falsely testified
about his attorney's use of a false
affidavit at his deposition
second he lied under oath to the grand
jury about his conversations with betty
curry
third he lied under oath to the grand
jury about what he told his aides about
his relationship with miss lewinsky
knowing that those aides would be called
to testify to the grand jury
fourth he lied under oath to the grand
jury when he testified about the nature
of his relationship with miss lewinsky
an ordinary citizen who lies under oath
four times to a grand jury is subject to
substantial time in a federal prison
the decision each senator must make with
respect to article one
is whether the president is to pay a
price for his perjury just like any
citizen must
the president's defenders and spin
doctors would have you believe
that the president told all these lies
under oath to protect himself and his
family from personal embarrassment
and even if he did tell a lie it was not
that bad a lie
senators please remember that the
president's grand jury appearance was
over six months after the news media
broke the story about the president's
affair with miss lewinsky
by august 17th few people doubted that
he had an affair with her there was
little left to hide
and he lied after practically everyone
who was asked including many of you
advised the president to tell the truth
to the grand jury
and still he lied
we have heard a litany of excuses
including the president saying he was
not paying a great deal of attention and
that he was trying to figure out what
the facts were and that he needed to
know whether his recollection was right
and that he had not done anything wrong
and on and on
the president knew what had happened
if monica lewinsky came on to him and
made a sexual demand upon him and that
he rebuffed her as he told sydney
blumenthal
he would have nothing to apologize for
senators don't be fooled by the
president's excuses and spin control
the facts and the evidence clearly show
that he knew what he knew what he was
doing was to deceive everyone including
the grand jury
he and his defenders are still in denial
they will not accept the consequences of
his repeated and criminal attempts to
defeat the judicial process
his lies to the grand jury were not to
protect his family or the dignity of his
office but to protect himself from
criminal liability for his perjury and
obstruction of justice in the jones case
over nine years ago the senate removed
judge walter nixon from office for about
the same offense lying under oath to the
grand jury
the vote in the senate was 89-8 in favor
of judge nixon's removal with 48 current
senators and vice president gore voting
guilty
the boot of federal judge from office
while keeping a president in power after
the president committed the same offense
sets a double standard and lowers the
standard of what the american people
should expect from the leader of their
country
to conclude that the standard of
presidential truthfulness is lower than
that of a federal judge is absurd
to conclude that perjury and obstruction
of justice are acceptable if committed
by a popular president during times of
peace and prosperity sets a dangerous
precedent which sets america on the road
back to an imperial presidency above the
law
to justify the president's criminal
behavior by demonizing those who seek to
hold him accountable
ignores the fact that president
clinton's actions and those actions
alone precipitated the investigations
which have brought us here today
to keep a president in office whose
gross misconduct and criminal actions
are a well-established fact
will weaken the authority of the
presidency
undermine the rule of law and cheapen
those words which have made america
different from most other nations in the
earth equal justice under law
for the sake of our country and for
future generations
please find the president guilty of
perjury and obstruction of justice when
you cast your votes mr cannon
the chair recognizes mr manager cannon
if you'll
just wait a moment mr manager cannon if
there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date
please go ahead
thank you mr chief justice council for
the president
members of the senate
my name is chris cannon i represent over
600 000 people in the third district
of utah
i'd like to begin today with a couple of
thank yous first of all i'd like to
thank you senators for your attention
during this series of presentations i
know that you all have a deep conflicts
over the matter before you
some of you made strong public
statements about it
but you've all paid extraordinary
attention and for that i thank you
i would also like to thank the other
members of the management team it has
been a remarkable experience to have
been associated with them during the
past five months almost as good i might
say as it would have been to have been
home with my wife and children and our
new baby
if i might i'd like to share with you a
recent family experience
i've been home just about a little over
a day out of the last three weeks and it
took my 10 month baby 10 month old baby
about a little while to warm up to me
when i was home last
and
later as i started packing she realized
that i was leaving again and she
insisted that i hold her i think she
felt that if she held on i wouldn't
disappear
unfortunately for her she fell asleep on
the trip to the airport
i know that other managers had similar
disruptions in their families and their
family life for instance charles
kennedy's wife had a baby during the
trial
i would therefore like to thank my wife
and my children and the wives and
children of all the managers for their
forbearance and support during this
process like us they believe in the
obligation we have to assure good
government
and i might say like us they are
grateful
that the manager's role is ending
for the managers this process is almost
done
i hope that history will judge that we
have done our duty well
we have been congratulated and condemned
but we are done
and while our difficult role is ending
yours is just beginning
well i'm certain that sitting here
silently has been difficult the truly
daunting task before you now is to
conclude this trial with one some sense
of legitimacy for america is deeply
divided and the end result of an
impeachment trial was designed by the
founding fathers to solve these
divisions and wounds traditionally after
narrowing the facts and a vote by the
senate either a president is removed
or he has vindicated in this case it
seems neither of those results may be
realized while the facts are clear that
the president committed perjury and
obstruction of justice and here i'd like
to associate myself with the comments of
a man and mr manager since inventor
it is equally clear that this body may
not remove him from office
and from this perception you face the
challenge of legitimizing the end result
your vote will end this matter it is
non-justiciable whatever your decision
is it cannot be undone
the outcome will be right by definition
but how will you do the work of divining
that outcome will affect the way that we
as a nation deal with the divisions
among us
to proceed in a manner that will be
trusted and viewed as legitimate by the
american people you must deal with the
differences between this proceeding and
prior impeachment trials
you must do this with an obvious
commitment to your oath to do justice
impartially according to the
constitution and the law the law
includes the rules and precedence of the
senate senate resolution 16 made this
process different from
all of the preceding 13 senate trials on
impeachment principally by removing from
the managers
the right to present our cases we see
fit
i suspect that the lewd subject matter
and the partisan fight in the house may
have influenced your decision
but there's an integrity to the historic
rules and reasons for them for instance
the senate by nature will be divided
in the impeachment proceeding while the
managers are united it is therefore
easier for the managers to decide on how
to present their case than it is for the
senate
there are other differences in this
proceeding from historic impeachment
practice before the senate may i list
the changes for you with the intent to
help you focus on the goal of a
conclusion that we the people will feel
legitimate
senate resolution 16 called for a
24-hour presentation or trial it was
called in the resolution that mainly
consisted of what the public saw as the
yammering of lawyers time was equally
divided rather than sequenced as it is
in a trial where opening statements are
made and then evidence is put on through
witnesses in a trial each side typically
takes the time necessary to establish
its case or to undermine the witness
through cross-examination
after the moving party has made its case
the responding party makes its case time
is dictated only by what each side feels
it needs each witness is subject to
whatever cross-examination is
appropriate the case develops tested
piece by tested piece and ultimately one
side prevails
here the managers had to cut very
important portions of our limited case
we had a limited number of witnesses
limited to videotaped appearances
limited to fit an arbitrary three-hour
rule that time was lessened because we
had to reserve time for rebuttal
according to judicial traditions
defendants have to challenge each
witness as they appear not wrap the
credibility of an uh of all in one wide
ranging response in these proceedings
the senate has not had the opportunity
to assess the credibility of witnesses
as the case developed the white house
then used his time with long video
portions and small cutting accusations
who knows what the white house might
have done if it had been able or if it
found it necessary to challenge the
witnesses as they testified
another diversion from judicial and
senate trial precedent
was that the only rebuttal for the
managers was that it was what we
reserved after our video presentation
and awkwardly in the questioning period
where important complicated issues were
cut off by artificial time limits while
peripheral issues got more time than
they deserved this questioning period
had the unfortunate side effect of
focusing the public on the partisanship
of the senate the problem of the newness
of the presentation format was
exacerbated by the new media environment
the internet with its immediate and
often unvetted content and cable
television with his perpetual talking
heads gave equal time and equivalency of
weight to the managers in the white
house
with no witness testimony at all to
constrain them the process gave rise to
the perception that the fix was in
leaving some to gloat at having scammed
the situation and others angry at being
unheard
and that is the context with which the
senate must now finds itself and must
pursue a legitimate outcome
given the wide ranging options discussed
it is clear that this is no easy task
will it be adjourned with condemnation
findings of fact about the president's
behavior a bifurcated vote with the
articles of impeachment but not removing
the president a simple up and down vote
on the articles of impeachment or a vote
for acquittal followed by a censure vote
i don't know which if any of these
options really make sense
and i don't know of any other options i
do know that the issue is grave and that
your responsibility is great
so i'm here today to ask you to set
aside some of your natural inclinations
for the good of the country i would
implore you senators both republican and
democrat to set aside partisanship
politics polls and personalities and
exchange them for lofty inclinations
those are procedure policy and precedent
these are the only guidelines this body
should have as the senate deliberates
this case i would ask that a few key
facts never be forgotten
that the president committed perjury
when he lied under oath and he
obstructed justice
the senate has historically impeached
judges for perjury
even recently by some of you assembled
here
any american watching these proceedings
who commits perjury will be punished by
the law
if the senate follows our nation's
precedence of punishing perjurers and if
the senate follows its own precedence of
convicting perjurers then there is only
one clear conclusion in this matter
conviction
[Music]
senators we as americans and legislators
have never supported a legal system
which has one set of laws for the ruler
and another for the rule
after all our very pledge of allegiance
binds us together with the language
liberty and justice for all
if that is the case we intend if we
intend to live up to our oaths and
pledges
we take then our very own president must
be subject to the presidents and the
nation our national judicial system
and this senate body have heretofore set
because i love this country and its
institutions i pray for inspiration for
each of you
as you seek the proper legitimate
outcome may god bless you in this
process thank you
and now from the time over to mr geekes
the chair recognizes mr manager gakus
chief justice
colleagues on each side of the podium
members of the senate if i were to take
some time to thank the chief justice for
his patience in all of this would that
be counted against my time
it would
then i'll send you a note
and we do
we do
offer our thanks to the chief justice
i come from pennsylvania
and the people in my district and the
entire state
and in their 49
brethren states across the nation
the people of our country
recognize that there's really only one
issue with all the fury and the tumult
and the shouting and the invective and
the language and the
the the the
the just plain shouting that has
occurred across the halls of congress
and every place else in the country
it all swoops down in his telescope to
one issue did the president utter
falsehoods under oath
everyone understands that
everyone comes to the conclusion that
that's a serious allegation that has
been made through the impeachment and
one which you must judge in the final
vote that you will be casting
but why is it important
about whether or not the president
uttered falsehoods under oath
it is important not just to con to to
constitute the basis of perjury as is
alleged or and or obstruction of justice
which is alleged
but even if those two were not proved in
all their elements as crimes you would
still have to consider
uh falsehood under oath as constituting
an impeachable offense i say that
advisedly
it starts my contention does with the
assertions of our esteemed colleagues
who represent the president
time after time
and in their briefs and in their
statements on and off the floor they
have stated you need not have a criminal
offense
for it to constitute an impeachable
offense
and they provided examples of that
and they said that all you have to
demonstrate is that an impeachable
offense is one that rocks against the
integrity the system of government
i'm paraphrasing of course
and i submit
and i feel this so strongly that it it
it bothers me that i can't make it clear
that to violate the oath as a witness
in a civil case
or a criminal case
in the jones matter or in the grand jury
smashes against the integrity of the of
our system of government
and our sundry reasons for that
and in this case
if you follow the logic and the the
extreme intellectual presentation made
by
white house counsel that refutes every
item that the
that or attempts to refute not refutes
attempts to refute every
item asserted by the managers
if you believe all of that and are
confused or or in doubt about the jones
case and whether lies
under oath were committed or the grand
jury
you must think about this
this is
this is to me proof positive
that the president uttered falsehoods
under oath in all his public stances
on december the 23rd
the president under oath answered
interrogatories that were sent to him by
the court in the jones case
in which he said
in the in answer to the question have
you ever had sexual relations with
anyone
in a su in a subordinate role
while you were governor of arkansas or
president of the united states now this
is important at that time and the record
will disclose all of this
at that time there was no definition in
front of him
no gaggle of attorneys
trying to dispute what what word meant
what no judge there to interpose the
legal standards that should be employed
but rather the bold-faced naked
phrase of sexual relations that everyone
in the whole world understands to be
what it is and the pre the president
answered under oath
none
now i submit to the members of the
senate if he answered then on december
the 23rd before ever stepping foot in
the deposition of the paula jones case
if he never
appeared there or if whatever he said
there was so cloudy that you can't draw
a conclusion certainly you can
refer back to december 23rd and see a
starting point of a
pattern of conduct on the part of the
president
that proves beyond all doubt that he
committed a pattern and actual
falsehoods under oath time and time
again and if that's not enough on
january the 15th
as the record will disclose
he answered under oath requests for
documents in which the question is asked
under oath in which the president
responded
have you ever received any gifts or
documents from and it mentioned among
others
monica lewinsky and the president under
oath
signed
no or none the record will show for sure
exactly what he said but he denied
that any gifts
were transferred from
or any documents or any items of
personality from lewinsky to the
president i submit to you
that if you're confused about because of
the great presentation made by the
council for the president about the
murkiness and cloudiness of the jones
deposition the uh maddening
consequences of the president's
testimony maddening they said then you
can revert back to
january the 15th before the deposition
and december the 23rd and find proof
positive in the documents already part
of the case that you have to decide
that indeed a pattern of falsehoods
under oath was initiated and conducted
by the president of the united states
that's very important
and
those
allegations by the way have gone
completely uncontradicted by the
president of the united states
i i think they took great delight
these colleagues of mine
on behalf of the president great delight
in saying at one point and they put it
in a marquee in the sky that
in so many different ways when monica
lewinsky said
nobody told me to lie that was the case
for them what a case they made
nobody told me to lie
they won the case right there and there
in their minds
but because that was excelpatory and
that was brandishing this case once and
for all
monica said nobody told me to lie
well i'm going to take some liberties
with the latin that i learned when i was
in school where we all learned in
college and in law school fossum in
oonam
is fossum in toto meaning if you say
something false in one phase of your
testimony more than likely the triers of
fact can find that you were false in all
of them well i'm going to change that i
i think i'm right when i say veritas
in unum is veritas in total so when
monica lewinsky says i
nobody told me to lie and that's the
indomitable indestructible truth that
the white house counsel say that's the
case
then it also must be veritas and totem
because when she says when she said that
she gave gifts to the president
then you must accept that
veritas and unum is veritas in total and
that goes on and on and on
somebody is waving cut this short
very tough for me to do that
but i will i will comply
i have a witness i call a witness
to bolster my
my part of this summation
the witness is the american people
mr
craig in his last appearance on this
podium
was delighted to be able to quote
a poll that showed that 75 percent of
the people of our country felt that
there was no need to present videotapes
to the senate in the trial 75 percent he
said with great gusto
of the american people
and of course
the polls of all types were quoted time
and time again by the supporters of the
president as showing why you should vote
to acquit
the polls the polls the polls i now call
the american people's poll
on whether or not
the president do they believe that the
president committed
falsehoods under oath
eighty percent of the american people i
call them to my side here at the podium
to verify to you that the president
committed falsehoods under oath
[Music]
[Applause]
the chair recognizes mr manager shabbat
yeah i'm steve shabbat and i represent
the first district of ohio which is
cincinnati
this week we will likely finally
conclude this trial
has it been difficult
yes
would we all have preferred that none of
this ever happened of course
but the president has put our nation
through a terrible ordeal and it has
been our duty to pursue this case to its
conclusion
and despite the dire warnings and scare
tactics and heavy-handed threats by
those who would circumvent the solemn
constitutional process that we're all
engaged in
our great country has survived
we have finished this trial in just a
few weeks the economy continues to be
strong and the nation's business is
getting done
but senators before you turn out the
lights and head home you must make one
final decision
it's a decision that should not be
influenced by party affiliation or by
politics or by personal ties
it's a decision that should be guided by
our constitution
by our laws
and by your own moral compass
a few months ago i stood in your shoes
as did all the colleagues here and the
colleagues in the house
and in preparing to make what would
likely be the most
important vote of our careers
throughout the process i did my best to
be fair and to keep an open mind and i
listened carefully to the views of my
constituents the people that sent me to
congress
i reviewed the evidence in excruciating
detail
ultimately
for me the choice was clear i came to
the conclusion that it was my duty to
support impeachment
now it's your turn
to cast what could be the most important
vote of your political careers
the question is
will moral fortitude
or political expediency rule the day
this past weekend
i had the opportunity to spend a couple
hours at my college alma mater william
and mary not too far from here down in
williamsburg virginia
as i walked around the campus i couldn't
help but think back to my college days
and what motivated me to seek public
office in the first place
back in 1972 i was a 19 year old college
student casting my first ballot in a
presidential election
like a majority of americans that year i
voted for a republican richard nixon for
president
four years later however i voted for
democrat jimmy carter
this decision stemmed my
for my profound disappointment over
watergate
and a strong conviction that president
nixon
should not have received immunity
for his actions
now just as in college i find myself
extremely troubled by the actions of a
president
in fact as i started to think about what
i would say today i wasn't sure where to
begin
how exactly do you wrap up in 10 minutes
or less everything we've witnessed in
the last year
we've seen bill clinton's finger waving
denial to the american people
we've seen the president lie before a
federal grand jury we've seen the
president
obstruct justice
we've seen the president hold a public
celebration immediately following the
house impeachment vote
we all know the president's behavior has
been reprehensible
president clinton however refuses to
admit what all of us know is true
to this day he continues to deny and
distort he continues to dispute the
undeniable facts that are before the
senate and before the american people
the president's attorneys have done
their best to disguise the truth as well
at the beginning of this trial i
predicted in my presentation that they
would use legal smoke screens to mask
the law and the facts to their credit
they produce smoke so thick that it
continues to cloud this debate
but if you look through the smoke and
the mirrors employed by these very able
lawyers you will see the truth
the truth is that president clinton lied
to a federal grand jury he lied about
whether or not he had committed perjury
and a civil deposition
about the extent of his relationship
with a subordinate federal employee
about his coaching of his secretary
betty curry and about the countless
other matters
in my opening statement before this body
i outlined the four elements of perjury
and oath intent falsity materiality in
this case all those elements have been
met
president clinton also obstructed
justice and encouraged others to lie in
judicial proceedings
he sought to influence the testimony of
a potentially adverse witness with job
assistance and he attempted to conceal
evidence that was under subpoena
these truths cannot be ignored distorted
or swept under the rug
some of the presidents partisan
defenders want you to do just that but
it would be wrong
it would be wrong for you to send the
message to every american that it's
acceptable to lie under oath and
obstruct justice
it would be wrong for you to tell
america's children that some lies are
all right
it would be wrong to show the rest of
the world that some of our laws don't
really matter
i must agree with phyllis and jack
stanley constituents of mine who live in
my district who wrote me a letter saying
and i quote
we believe that president bill clinton
should definitely be impeached for the
sake of the country if he is not
impeached will not the rule of law in
this country be weakened we do not feel
glee over the prospect of president
clinton's impeachment however
for the sake of coming generations
acknowledging that integrity honor and
decency matter greatly is very important
especially in the highest office of the
land unquote
like most of you i have spent countless
hours at grocery stores shopping malls
at schools and my church
talking to my constituents
i've also read thousands of letters that
have been sent to my office just as we
all have
what i've heard and read doesn't
surprise me
people in cincinnati ohio have a variety
of views on what the ultimate verdict
should be by this body
many want the president removed from
office
others want accenture
still others would just like to see the
process end
but regardless of their views their
honorable people who care about our
country and our future
now i know that throughout the process
some of the president's more partisan
defenders have harshly criticized the
managers the house of representatives
and anyone who would dare believe that
the president committed any crimes
these partisan attacks have been
unfortunate
because i think we all know that these
issues are serious and that they deserve
serious consideration
i know it the american people know it
and i think you all know it too
but despite the partisan and rhetoric
attacks i believe that once this trial
ends we must work together
so i would ask everyone here today to
make a commitment
a commitment to every american that
regardless of the trial's outcome
we will join together to turn the page
on this unfortunate chapter that
president clinton has written into our
nation's history
the question before you now is
how will this chapter end
will the final chapter say that the
united states senate turned its back on
perjury and obstruction of justice by
the president united states
or will it say that the senate took a
principled stand and told the world that
no person not even the president stands
above the law
that all americans no matter how rich
how powerful or how well connected are
accountable for their actions even the
president
as the father of two children and a
former school teacher myself at an inner
city school in cincinnati i believe it
is very important that we teach our
children that honesty
integrity and the rule of law do matter
when i'm in cincinnati i spend a lot of
time visiting schools throughout my
community i taught the seventh and
eighth grade back in cincinnati and when
i go there i go to elementary schools i
go to junior highs i go to high schools
and
i've been doing this for a number of
years and you know what
is inevitably one of the questions that
the kids will ask me
almost every time it's
have you ever met the president of the
united states
now why do the kids ask that question
because our kids understand how
important the office of the presidency
is
the person who occupies that office
owes it to the children of this nation
to treat the office with respect
in the past when those kids ask me that
question they asked me that question out
of pride and respect they looked up to
the office they looked up to everything
the office represents
bill clinton has let our children down
and that's one of the greatest thing
that that bothers me is to the effect
that this will have the children of this
nation
let me conclude with a statement that i
received from a student juliette
asuncion who is a student at mother of
mercy high school who wrote to me
recently and she said i'm writing to
express my feelings on the scandalous
situation that has taken over the white
house for the past couple of months
first i'd like to state the qualities
that should be found in the present
united states since the president is the
official representatives of the united
states he should uphold the values and
ideals held by the people of this
country the president should be honest
and a trustworthy person he should be a
good decision maker have good morals and
have his priorities straight he should
devote his time to the country and set a
good example for the people of this
nation i feel that president clinton
does not measure up to these standards
he's lied to the american people he's
committed perjury for someone in his
position this is an unforgivable act and
he should not be allowed to just walk
away without a punishment he's shown
that he feels he can go above the law
and i strongly believe the president
should be impeached
and i'll conclude by telling you that
when you cast your vote i would ask that
you remember
and you remember that by your vote
you're determining the lesson that
juliet that your children and your
grandchildren will learn
so how will this chapter end
the decision is yours
i now yield to the gentleman from
georgia mr manchabar
the chair recognizes mr manager barr
thank you mister chief justice
distinguished and weather adversary
we're the adversaries council for the
president including my good friend and
former georgetown law professor charles
ruff
gentlemen and ladies of the senate
my name is bob barr i represent the
seventh district of georgia but in a
broader sense i represent the country
because i have been directed as every
one of the other 12 managers of the
house
have been directed by the american
people by majority vote of the house of
representatives to urge you to review
the evidence and issue a verdict of
conviction on two articles of
impeachment passed by the house of
representatives
two days ago all of us celebrated the
birthday of former president ronald
reagan
during his first year in office on may
17 1982
81 this president known for having given
voice
to america's most decent and honorable
incense spoke to the american people
from notre dame university
though spoken nearly 18 years ago and
clearly not in contemplation of an
impeachment the former president's words
provide guidance for you here today
it was on that date that president
reagan spoke of a certain principle and
in so doing he quoted another giant of
the 20th century winston churchill
specifically president reagan then spoke
of those who derided simple
straightforward answers to the problems
confronting our country
those who decried clarity and certainty
of principle in favor of vagueness and
relativism he said
they say the world has become too
complex for simple answers they are
wrong there are no easy answers but
there are simple answers
we must have the courage to do what is
morally right
winston churchill said that the destiny
of man is not measured by material
computation
when great forces are on the move in the
world we must learn we are spirits not
animals
and he said
there is something going on in time and
space
and beyond time and space
which whether we like it or not spells
duty
duty a clear simple concept a
foundational principle
your duty is clearly set forth in your
oath
your oath to do impartial justice
according to the constitution and the
law
in the past month you have heard much
about the constitution and even more
about the law
probably more than you'd prefer
in a dizzying recitation of the us
criminal code
18 usc 1503 1512 1621 1623 tampering
perjury obstruction
now that's a lot to digest but these are
real laws and they are applicable to
these proceedings and to this president
evidence and law you've seen it you've
heard it
they've also seen and heard about straw
men raised up by the white house lawyers
and then stricken down mightily
you've heard them essentially describe
the president alternatively as victim
or saint
you've heard even his staunchest allies
describe his conduct as reprehensible
even some of you on the president's side
of the aisle have concluded there's no
question about his having given false
testimony under oath and he did that
more than once
there has also been much smoke churned
up by the defense
men and women of the senate monica
lewinsky is not on trial
her conduct and her intentions are not
at issue here vernon jordan is not on
trial and his conduct and his intentions
are not at issue here
william jefferson clinton is on trial
here his behavior his intentions his
actions these and only these are the
issues before you
when the white house lawyers raise up as
a straw man that vernon jordan might not
have had an improper motive in seeking a
job for miss lewinsky
or that there was no formal conspiracy
proved between the president and vernon
jordan or that ms lewinsky says she did
not draw a direct link between the
presidents raising the issue of a false
affidavit and the cover stories keep in
mind these are irrelevant issues
when the white house lawyers strike
these theories down even if you were to
conclude that they did they are striking
down nothing more than irrelevant straw
man
what stands today as it has throughout
these proceedings are facts a false
affidavit that benefits the president
the coaching of witnesses by the
president the secreting of subpoena
subpoenaed evidence that would have
harmed the president lies under oath by
the president these reflect president
clinton's behavior president clinton's
intentions president clinton's actions
and president clinton's benefit
not through the eyes of false theories
but by the evidence through the lens of
common sense
you've heard tapes and read volumes of
evidence not pursuant to the precise
process we as house managers would have
preferred but much evidence nonetheless
has been presented
many are saying with a degree of
certainty that usually comes only from
ignorance that there's nothing i or any
of us can say to you today on the eve of
your deliberations to sway your minds i
beg to differ with them
moreover
we have been directed by the people of
this country by majority vote of the
house of representatives to fulfill and
reaffirm a process and to present
evidence to you and to argue this case
to you
there is much in urging a vote for
conviction that can be gained by turning
to and keeping in mind president
reagan's words to america to do duty
duty unclouded by relativism unmarred by
artificiality
duty that lives on after your vote just
as america will live on and prosper
after a vote to convict
duty untainted by polls
polls the country's fascination with
polls warmed its way even into these
proceedings
when just a few days ago we heard one of
the white house lawyers cite polls as a
reason not to release the videotapes
polls played no role in the great and
glorious decisions decisive decisions
that made america a nation and kept it
free and strong quite the opposite was
true
polls likewise played no role in the
great trials of our nation's history
that opened schools equally to all of
america's children or that provided due
process and equal protection to the loss
for all americans regardless of skin
color or economic might or political
power
yet it is now in many respects polls
that threaten to become the currency of
political discourse and even a judicial
process as we near to enter the 21st
century your duty as i know you
recognize is and must be based on polls
and polls not on polls or politics but
on law and the constitution
in other words principle
will you decide in this case the case
now before you will tell america in the
world what it is we have as a foundation
for our nation
not just today but for ages to come
it will tell us in this nation whether
these seats here today will continue to
be occupied by true statesmen
whether these seats in this chamber will
continue to echo with the booming
principles eloquence and sense of duty
of daniel webster john calhoun everett
dirksen robert byrd
i would add to that list statesman my
fellow georgian and your former
colleague sam nunn
whose concern for duty and our national
security caused him recently on cnn
to raise grave concerns over our
nation's security because of the
reckless conduct of this president
will the principles embodied in our
constitution and our laws be reaffirmed
rusted from the pallid hands of
pollsters and pundits and from the swarm
of theorists
surrounding these proceedings
will they be taken up by you and
reaffirmed into the hands of thomas
jefferson
madison washington lincoln and martin
luther king jr and so many other true
statesmen of america's heritage
principles that have stricken down
bigotry tyrants and demagogues
principles that through open and fair
trials have saved the
innocent from the hangman's noose
and likewise has sent the guilty clothed
in due process to the nether regions
it is principle founded and nurtured in
our constitution and law that you are
called upon now to both use and reaffirm
not only america is watching but the
world is too
and for those who say
people from foreign lands and in foreign
lands deride this process and look down
on it i say not so
let me speak briefly of a man not born
in this country but a man who has made
this his country
a man born not in atlanta georgia though
atlanta is now his home
a man born many thousands of miles away
in eritrea a man to who president reagan
surely was in a sense speaking both in
1981 when he spoke of america's duty and
in january 1985 when he spoke of the
american sound that echoes still through
the ages and across the continents
the man whose words i quote is a man who
watches this process through the eyes of
an immigrant
mr seyum tesfaye now i've never met mr
tisify but i've read his words
in the february 5th atlanta journaling
constitution just three days ago
he wrote that this impeachment process
is an example of america at its best a
core constitutional principle that
profoundly distinguishes america from
almost all other nations
he noted without hyperbole that this
process far from being the sorry
spectacle that many of the president's
defenders have tried to make it truly is
a hallmark of representative democracy
reaffirming the principle that no man is
above the law not even the president
these are not the words of the house
managers though they echo ours these are
not the words of a partisan they are the
words of an immigrant a man who came to
america to study and who estate to work
and pay taxes just as countless millions
of us do
every day
[Music]
men and women of the united states
senate you must by reaffirming your duty
to render impartial justice based on the
constitution in the law
reaffirm those same laws and that very
same constitution which drew mr tesfaye
and millions of other immigrants to our
shores over the ages
now this is not a comfortable task for
any of us
but as martin luther king jr correctly
noted in words that hang on my office
wall and perhaps on some of yours
it is not in times of comfort and
convenience that we find the measure of
a man's character but in times of
conflict and controversy
this is such a defining time
obstruction of justice and perjury must
not be allowed to stand
perjury and obstruction cannot stand
alongside the laws and the constitution
by your oath you must
like it or not choose one over the other
up or down
guilt or acquittal
i respectfully submit
on behalf of the house of
representatives and on behalf of my
constituents in the seventh district of
georgia
that the evidence clearly establishes
guilt
and that the constitution and laws of
this land
demand it
i thank the men members of the senate
and yield to mr manager boyer
the chair recognizes mr manager boyer
thank you mr chief justice
[Music]
mr chief justice distinguished counsel
and senators
my name is steve boyer house manager
from monticello indiana i represent 20
counties between south bend and
indianapolis
i will not try to claim the cornerstone
of hoosier common sense mr kendall would
wrestle me for that cornerstone
but as a former criminal defense
attorney i want to take a moment and
compliment
the white house counsel and mr kendall
for doing your best to defend your
client in the face of overwhelming facts
and compelling evidence
your role here is a sort of a side
compliment you think
your role here is much easier though in
a court of impeachment as opposed to a
criminal court of law
as a former federal prosecutor i
complement chairman henry high
and my colleagues uh the house managers
who have embraced and given life meaning
to the rule of law and presented this
case to the senate in a professional
thorough and dignified manner
i assure you that the house managers
would not have prosecuted the articles
of impeachment before the bar of the
senate had we not had the highest degree
of faith
belief and confidence that based on the
evidence the president committed high
crimes and misdemeanors which warrant
his removal from office
as you come to judgment
i would recommend you square yourself
with your duty first
on january 7th i witnessed as the chief
justice administered your oath to do in
court
to do impartial justice according to the
constitution and the laws
you should follow this prescription
follow the truth
strike that follow this prescription
find the truth define the facts
apply the law
give reverence to the senate precedence
while defending the constitution
but i submit
it is the integrity of your oath in
which you must regulate to uphold the
principle of equal justice under the law
during the question and answer phase
with the chief justice on saturday
january 23rd i stood here in the well of
the senate and recommended that you vote
on findings of fact now i want to clear
the record of my intent of the
recommendation since it has been grossly
distorted
it is not to establish the guilt as some
has alleged
a finding of fact is not a finding of
fiction on the contrary it is to prevent
decisions by triers of fact from basing
their judgment on fiction or chants or
politics
the chief justice ruled that you are
triers of fact
and since this constitutional proceeding
of impeachment is more like a civil
proceeding than a criminal trial i bring
your attention to rule 52 of the federal
rules of civil procedure that provides
in pertinent part that when judges sit
alone as a tryer of fact he or she is
required to set down in precise words
the facts as he or she finds them now
this requirement is mandatory and cannot
be waived by the parties in federal
practice
a memorandum of finding the facts is not
a radical concept to american
jurisprudence it is customary and
habitually used in state and federal
courts all across this land
since then since you sit collectively as
a court of impeachment as triers of fact
i recommended the findings of fact to
guarantee that you have carefully
reviewed the evidence and have a
rational basis for your final judgment
to claim that findings of fact is
unconstitutional is false
the supreme court has consistently
permitted the senate to shape the
contours and the due process of an
impeachment trial
the senate owes the american people and
history an accounting of the stubborn
facts
i'd like to comment on some statements
i've heard some senators state publicly
that they are using the standard of
beyond a reasonable doubt
but the senate has held consistently
that the criminal standard of proof is
inappropriate for impeachment trials the
result of conviction in an impeachment
trial is removal from office it is not
meant to punish
you are to be guided by your own
conscience not by the criminal standard
of proof of beyond a reasonable doubt
i have also heard some senators from
both sides of the aisle state publicly
i think these offenses rise to the level
of high crimes and misdemeanors
now to state publicly that you believe
that high crimes and misdemeanors have
occurred
but for some reason you have this desire
not to remove the president
that desire though does not square with
the law
the constitution and the senate's
precedence for removing federal judges
for similar offenses
now so long as william jefferson clinton
is president
the only mechanism
to hold him accountable for his high
crimes and misdemeanors is the power of
impeachment and removal the constitution
is very clear
you cannot vindicate the rule of law by
stating high crimes and misdemeanors
have occurred but leave the president in
office subject to future prosecution
after his term has expired
without respect for the law the
foundation of our constitution is not
secure
without respect for the law our freedom
is at risk
now the president is answerable for his
alleged crimes to the senate here and
now
moreover if criminal prosecution and not
impeachment is the way to vindicate the
rule of law then the senate would never
have removed other civil officers such
as the federal judges
who are not insulated from criminal
prosecution while holding office
thus in providing for criminal
punishment after conviction and removal
from office it was the framers who
ensured that the rule of law would be
vindicated both in cleansing the office
and in punishing the individual for the
criminal act
now i have asked myself many times
how a president
can remain in office while having
committed perjury and obstruction of
justice
is fair
to those across the country or who are
sitting in jail for having committed the
same crimes
i have had the fairness argument thrown
into my face consistently
now fairness is important
fairness is something that's simple in
its nature and it's powerful in the
statement that it makes
a statement which you send carries us
into tomorrow and becomes the future
legacy
if you vote to acquit
think for a moment about what you would
say to those who've been convicted of
the same crimes as the president
what would you say to the 182 americans
who are sentenced in federal court 1997
for committing perjury what would you
say the 144 americans were sentenced in
federal court 1997 for obstruction of
justice and witness tampering
would you attempt to trivialize the
evidence and say this was this case was
only about lying about sex
i want to cite the testimony before the
house judiciary committee of one woman
who experienced the judicial system in
the most personal sense and that was the
testimony of dr barbara battalino i
think i think it's compelling
now she
she held degrees in medicine and law
and manager rogan showed some of the
testimony just the other day you see she
was prosecuted by the clinton justice
justice department and convicted for
obstruction of justice because of her
lie under oath about one act of
consensual oral sex with a patient on va
premises
her untruthful response was made in a
civil suit which was later dismissed
in a legal proceeding dr batolino was
asked under oath quote did anything of a
sexual nature take place in your office
on june 27 1991
end quote her one word reply no
convicted her and forever changed her
life
her punishment she was convicted of a
felony forced to wear an electronic
monitoring device and is presently on
probation she lost her license to
practice law and her ability she lost
her license to practice medicine
and her ability to practice law
now our prisons hold many who are truly
contrite
they're sorry they feel pain for their
criminal offenses and some whose victims
have even forgiven them
others were very popular citizens had
many friends and apologized profusely
but they were still held accountable
under the law
just like the president is a claim to be
doing a good job
many in prison in prison today were
doing a good job in their chosen
professions none of our laws provide for
good job performance contrition
forgiveness or popularity polls as a
remedy for criminal conduct
these were the closing lines of dr
vadalino's opening statement for the
house judiciary committee quote
we all make mistakes in life
but common frailty does not relieve us
from the responsibility to uphold the
rule of law
regardless this nation must never let
any person or people undermine the rule
of law if liberty and justice for all
does not reign we like great
civilizations before us will surely
perish from the face of the earth
what would you say to dr vadalino and
others similarly situated is very
important because fairness is important
alexander hamilton writing not long
after the constitution was adopted well
expressed the harm that would come to
our republic from those who by example
undermine the respect for the law
in a statement that bears repeating
hamilton wrote quote
if it were to be asked what is the most
sacred duty and the greatest source of
security in a republic
the answer would be
an inviolable respect for the
constitution
and the laws
the first growing out of the last
those
therefore who said examples which
undermine or subvert the authority of
the laws lead us from freedom to slavery
they incapacitate us for a government of
laws
president clinton by his persistent and
calculated misconduct and illegal acts
has set a pernicious example of
lawlessness an example which by its very
nature subverts respect for the law his
his perverse example inevitably
undermines the integrity of both the
office of the president and the judicial
process
you see ladies and gentlemen
without choice we were all born free
and we inherited a legacy of liberty a
great sacrifice by many who've come
before us
we cannot collectively as a free people
enjoy the liberties without measured
personal restraint
and that's the purpose of the rule of
law it's the function of the courts to
uphold the dignity of that prescription
and the god-given liberties to all of us
that's how we are able to carry this
nation forward into future generations
so in light of the historic principles
regarding impeachment the overwhelming
evidence the offenses as alleged
the application of the senate precedents
and they believe it makes it very clear
that our president who's shown such
contempt for the law
the dignity dignity and the integrity of
the office of the presidency that was
entrusted to him
must be held
to account
and it can only be his removal from
office
the house managers reserve the balance
of our time
very well the chair recognizes the white
house council
mr chief justice thank you i wonder uh
mr majority leader whether we might
take a brief break because there's going
to need to be some rearrangement of
furniture here
the chair recognized the majority leader
i was hesitant to suggest it too early
today
justice well on request of counsel uh i
i asked that we'd take a ten minute
recess and please return quickly to the
chamber so we can get back to business
and without objection it's so ordered
as the senate takes this 10 minute
recess we are going to invite you to
join us once again with your thoughts on
the conclusions that you've reached here
after the
16th day of the impeachment trial of the
president
the need that they have to do
the chair recognizes mr whitehouse
counsel rough thank you mr chief justice
how's the sound system today
good
mr chief justice
managers to the house
ladies and gentlemen of the senate
i can't resist beginning
following the lead of my colleagues
across the well here
by telling you that my name is charles
ruff
and i'm from the district of columbia
and we don't have a vote in the congress
of the united states
i truly did not intend to begin quite
this way but i
i must
i don't think there is a court in the
land
where a prosecutor would be able to
stand up for
one-third of his allotted time
speak in general terms about
the
what the people are entitled to and what
the rule of law stands for
as important as all of that may be
and sit down and turn to the defendant's
council
and ask that defense counsel go forward
reserving two hours for rebuttal
i recognize that procedural niceties
have not necessarily characterized the
way this trial has gone forward
but i do believe and this is the only
time today i will say this i promise
that kind of prosecutorial gambit
is symptomatic
of what we have seen before in these
last weeks
wanting to win
too much
now that said
let me begin where i want intended to
begin
we are taking
the last steps along a path that
for most of us
has seemed to be unending
indeed some of us may have a sense that
we've gone
well beyond yogi berraland to deja vu
all over again and all over again and
all over again
i thought long and hard as i thought
about what i was going to say today
how i could be of most help to you as
you
make
this momentous decision that will soon
be entrusted to you
i momentarily considered whether
the answer to that question was simply
to yield back my time
but i weighed that against the special
pleasure of stretching out our last
hours with you
or as ernie banks would have said
it's such a nice day let's play too
but cursed as i am with lawyerly
instincts i decided to compromise
i promise you as much brevity as i can
manage
even if not much wit
while making a few final points
that i think you need to carry with you
as you go into your deliberations
now you have heard the manager's vision
or at least
some part of it
their vision of the process we've been
engaged in
and the lessons we've learned
and what it will look like at the end of
our journey
i respect them as elected
representatives of their people
and as worthy adversaries
but i believe their vision to be too
dark
a vision too little attuned to the needs
of the people
too little sensitive
to the needs of our democracy
i believe it to be a vision more focused
on retribution
more designed to achieve partisan ends
more uncaring about the future we face
together
our vision i think is quite different
but it is not naive
we know the pain the president has
caused our society and his family and
his friends
but we know too how much the president
has done for this country
and more importantly we know that our
primary obligation
the duty we all have
is to preserve that which the founders
gave us
and we can best fulfill that duty
by carefully traveling the path
that they laid out for us
now you've heard many speeches over the
past few weeks
about high crimes and misdemeanors
as i look back on the arguments and the
counter-arguments
seems to me that really very little can
be gained
by repeating them
for when all is said and done
what they mean is this
the framers chose
stability
they made impeachment and removal
constitutional recourses of last resort
the question that the managers appear to
have asked
and i am unable to tell you what they
will ask today
is whether perjury or obstruction of
justice in the abstract are impeachable
offenses
that is not the question you must answer
nor must you assume as the managers
appear to
that because judges are removed for
having committed perjury a president
must be removed as well
that is not what the law the rule of law
requires
the rule of law and even-handed justice
is something more than a simple
syllogism you must decide whether on
these facts
arising out of these circumstances
this president
has so endangered the state that we can
no longer countenance his remaining in
office
now i think in their hearts the managers
do not truly disagree
whatever tidbits they've been able to
glean from the historical record or more
modern scholarship
they cannot in the end avoid the
conclusion that removal of the president
is not something that the framers took
lightly
indeed two of their own witnesses in the
judiciary committee professor van
alstein and judge wiggins
tried to make it clear to them that even
if they were to find
that the offenses described in the
independent council's referral had been
committed
another decision had to be made
that decision was whether in the
interest of society
the president should be impeached
as professor van allstein put it in
words that i admit are unflattering to
my client but nonetheless make the point
in my own opinion he said i regard if
the president did that which the special
counsel's report declared are crimes of
such a low order that it would unduly
flatter the president by submitting him
to trial in the senate i would not
bother to do it
now i read that statement to you not
obviously because the professor and i on
the same side of the political divide
have the same view of the president's
conduct but because it is important i
think to understand
as i fear the managers do not that the
framers full well understood
what they were doing when they drafted
the impeachment provisions of the
constitution
they consciously chose
not to make all misconduct by the
president of basis for removal
they chose instead
only that conduct that they viewed as
most serious
as most dangerous to our system of
government
as i said i think in their hearts the
managers recognize the force of this
for they've argued to you that perjury
and obstruction really should be treated
as the equivalent of treason and bribery
in the danger that they pose to our
society
they've offered on this much rhetoric
and a few substantive arguments and i
want to look at just a few of these
arguments as they were advanced in the
manager's opening and not really
addressed since then
first
an historical argument
that blackstone in his commentaries
listed bribery and perjury and
obstruction of justice under the same
heading of offenses against public
justice
second a sort of modern statutory
equivalent of that argument
that under the sentencing guidelines we
actually treat perjury more severely
than we do bribery
and third and this is the theme you've
heard throughout these proceedings
what i'll call the system of justice
argument
that the president's conduct if he is
not removed
will somehow subvert enforcement of our
civil rights laws
but all these arguments are mere
subterfuge offered because the managers
knew
that to make any plausible case for
removal they must bring these articles
within the very small circle of offenses
that the framers believed were truly
dangerous to the state
first blackstone
it's true that the commentaries rate
perjury is among 21 offenses against
public justice
notably however blackstone ranks the 21
in order of seriousness or as he puts it
malignity
now number one on the list the most
malignant offense
is a felony that i have to admit is
unknown to me
that of vacating records
number six
is returning from transportation
also an offense rarely seen
in our modern society
numbers 10 to 12
are baretry
maintenance and temperature especially
dear to me because they involve my
profession
but rarely pursued these days i think
you'll agree
and at number 15
is perjury
now if as madison told us blackstone was
in the hand of every man
what does that tell us about why the
framers
chose treason and bribery and other
high crimes and misdemeanors
as the grounds for impeachment
it tells us that they fully understood
the comparative gravity of offenses
against public justice
and nonetheless chose only those
that truly posed that danger to the
state
treason for obvious reasons and bribery
because to them the risk that the
executive
would sell himself to a foreign country
for example was much more than mere
speculation
and then
other
other
high crimes of similar severity
now as to the lessons to be learned from
the more modern day the sentencing
guidelines mr manager mccollum argued
you to you a few weeks ago
that those to whom you have given the
responsibility to assess
the comparative severity of crimes
have concluded that perjury is at least
as serious a crime as bribery
that decision he told you is evidenced
by the commission's decision to assign
to perjury
an offense level of 12 or approximately
one year in prison and to bribery and
offense level slightly below that
but even to the extent that such an
argument were to be weighed in that
constitutional balance
manager mccollum was simply not being
candid with you
for he failed to explain
that under these same guidelines
a bribe of let's say
75 000
taken by an elected official or a judge
for that matter
automatically carries an offense level
of 24 twice
that of perjury and a prison sentence
four to five times
longer
the drafters of our guidelines
to the extent that manager mccollum
asked you to look at them
full well understand the special gravity
of bribes taken by the country's leaders
and are prepared to distinguish that
offense
from the offenses even at best that are
before you now
and lastly the system of justice
argument
the notion that somehow president
clinton
has undermined our civil rights laws
well whatever i might say could not
match the eloquence of my colleague ms
mills
and therefore i will not tempt fate by
venturing further
into that territory
i really don't want to become further
immersed in the minutiae here
on this i do agree with the managers we
cannot lose sight of the constitutional
forest
for some of the analytical trees
there is only one question before you
albeit a difficult one one that is a
question of fact and law and
constitutional theory
would it put at risk
the liberties of the people
to retain the president in office
putting aside partisan animus
if you can honestly say that it would
not
that those liberties are safe in his
hands
then you must vote to acquit
now each of you has a sense of this in
your mind and your heart better than
anything i could convey or i suspect
anything better than my colleagues could
convey
to you
and i won't
undertake to instruct you further
on this issue
and just as we ultimately leave that
question in your hands
we leave to the conscience of each
member the question
of what standard of proof to apply
despite congressman boyer's
exhortation to the contrary this body
has never decided for any of you
what standard is appropriate what
standard inappropriate
each senator
is left to his or her own best judgment
i suggested to you when i last spoke to
you
that i believe you must apply a standard
sufficiently stringent
to enable you to make this most
important decision with certainty
and in a manner that will ensure that
the american people understand that it
has been made with that certainty
this is not an issue
as to which we as a people and we as a
republic can be in doubt
let me move to the
articles just as you have listened
patiently to our debate about the
meaning of high crimes and misdemeanors
you have as well heard
seemingly endless discourse about the
specific details
of the various matters that the managers
allege constitute grounds for removal
i will strive there not therefore not to
be unduly repetitive
more than is at least absolutely
necessary
my colleagues last saturday and in their
earlier presentations have done my work
for me
but i want to focus for just a little
while
on those aspects of the manager's
presentation
that merit your special attention or
those that have been particularly
elucidated
or for that matter but clouded by the
testimony you heard and watched on
saturday
as we start this discussion let me offer
you
a phrase
that i hope you will remember
as i move through the articles with you
that phrase is
moving targets
and empty pots
moving targets
ever shifting theories
each one advanced to replace the last as
it has fallen
fallen victim to the facts
empty pots
attractive containers
but when you take the lid off
you find nothing to sustain you
now i use the term empty vessels in my
opening presentation
but it sin struck me that that was much
too flattering
and might even suggest
that they had the capacity to float
which they don't
article one
the first moving target
as we've said repeatedly
we've been more than a little puzzled as
to the exact nature of the charges
advanced by the managers under the
rubric of article one and our puzzlement
has only increased i must tell you since
this trial began
we've argued i think with indisputable
force that both articles are so
deficient
that they would not
survive a motion to dismiss in any court
in the land
and we're not insensitive to the claim
that we are advancing some lawyers
argument we're seeking some technical
escape
but i urge you not to treat this issue
so lightly
as you look to article one for example
ask yourselves whether you can
at this late moment in the trial
identify for yourselves with any remote
sense of certainty
the statements that the managers claim
are projects
i suspect you'll hear a lot about that
in the two hours following my
presentation
but i'll try to look ahead just a bit
ask yourselves whether you are
comfortable in this gravest of
proceedings
that when you retire to your
deliberations
you could ever know that the
constitutionally required two-thirds
vote is present on any one charge
now we've been making this argument
excuse me for some time and with some
frequency
and so you would think that at least
once the trial began
the managers would have fixed on some
definable set of charges
but no
indeed it struck me even earlier this
afternoon that when manager and ran
arose to speak to you
he was prepared to give you four
examples
of perjury
we've heard a lot of examples
we haven't heard much certainty
now just to give you an example of
how rapidly the target can move
you'll recall that in describing the
incidence of perjury allegedly committed
by the president
the managers made much of the
preliminary statement he read to the
grand jury
including the use of the words
occasionally
and on certain occasions
to describe the frequency of certain
conduct
and made the general allegation that the
statement was itself part of the scheme
to deceive the grand jury
yet strangely when mr manager roken was
asked about these very charges as late
as january 20th he quite clearly
abandoned them
i direct your attention to the exhibits
before you
and
to the chart
appearing on
television on january 20th
with chris matthews
this is what transpired
mr matthews now defend these elements
one that the president lied when he had
said
these relationships with her on certain
occasions is that the language
representative rogan that is the and
matthews and why is that prejudiced but
jurious
representative rogan in fact i'm not i i
don't think it's necessarily projects
that is that's one little piece of this
answer he gave at the grand jury
matthews well another time he used a
phrase with regard to this ridiculous
thing called phone sex he referred to it
as occasional or on occasion
why do you add them in as part of the
perjury indictment representative rogan
that's not added in as part of the
perjury indictment in article one i
simply raised that issue when i was
addressing the senate
matthews you better get to those
senators because i think they made the
mistake i did of thinking that was one
of the elements in the perjury charge
and similarly over here although i've
reversed the order a bit
go through what you think are the main
elements representative rogan one of the
things they were focusing on is a point
i think i made last week when i was
presenting the case for perjury dealing
with that preliminary statement that the
president read that just really gave the
grand jury a misperception of what the
president's relationship was with monica
lewinsky now i never said that was the
basis for the perjury charge
in fact that's not one even of the four
areas that's alleged but they're trying
to pick these little dots out of the
matrix and try to hang their hat on that
well i have to tell you
as did mr matthews i made the same
mistake
i heard manager rogan say
quote
this prepared statement he read to the
grand jury on august 17th 1998 was the
linchpin in his plan to quote win
unquote
i heard him say it is obvious that the
reference in the president's prepared
statement to the grand jury that this
relationship began in 1996 was
intentionally false
i heard him say
the president's statement was
intentionally misleading when he
described being alone with ms lewinsky
only on certain occasions
and i heard him say
the president's statement was
intentionally misleading when he
described his telephone conversations
with monica lewinsky as occasional
that's what i heard
when manager rogan spoke to you
a few weeks ago
now i know it's unusual to be given a
bill of particulars
on television
but maybe that's part of the modern
litigation age
and so as to articles one's charge now
that this is off the books
that the president perjured himself
concerning his
relationship with ms lewinsky
we are once again left with the claim
that he lied about
touching
about his denial that he engaged in
conduct
that fell within his subjective
understanding of the definition used in
the jones deposition
this in the course of testimony members
of the senate in which the president had
already made the single most devastating
admission that any of us can conceive of
it defies common sense
and as any experienced prosecutor and
five experienced prosecutors said this
to the judiciary committee
will tell you
it defies real world experience
to charge anyone president or not
with perjury on the ground that you
disbelieve his testimony
about his own subjective belief
and a definition of a term used in a
civil deposition
nothing in the evidentiary record has
changed
since the oic
referred this matter to the house six
months ago
indeed it is impossible to conceive what
could change
in the evidentiary record
and the managers have offered this
charge and persist in it
for reasons not entirely clear to me
but some blind faith
that they must go forward
facts or no
now there are three other elements to
article one
first that the allegation rehearsed the
allegation that the president lied when
he claimed that he did not purge himself
in the jones deposition
president of course made no such
representation in the grand jury and the
managers cannot no matter how they try
resurrect the charges
of the article
then article 2 that was so clearly
rejected by the house of representatives
yet if you listen to their presentations
over the past weeks
it becomes evident that whether
intentionally or unintentionally
they themselves have come to the point
where the president's testimony on
january 17th in the jones deposition
and august 17th in the grand jury
are treated as though they were one in
the same
now just just a few minutes ago
you heard manager geekus
talk to you about perjury
and probably 90 percent of what he
talked to you about
was perjury in the jones case
in the jones case
doesn't exist anymore the house of
representatives determined
that that was not an impeachable offense
it appears to make no difference though
that the house rejected this charge
for the managers do continue to dwell on
it
as though somehow they could show the
house mat of the house from which they
came
but they'd made a mistake
only last saturday manager graham could
be heard decrying the president's claim
that he had never been alone with monica
lewinsky
something that comes not out of the
grand jury
but out of the jones deposition
at the same time he was taking him to
task for his disposition on the meaning
of the word is
something that is in the grand jury but
is entirely irrelevant
to these perjury charges
you could even see it in their videotape
presentation last saturday when snippets
from
january 17th and august 17th were played
without any definition and without any
sense that there was any distinction
between the two events
there's literally nothing in the
president's grand jury testimony that
purports to adopt wholesale
his testimony in the jones deposition
if anything it's evident that he's
explaining at length and clarifying and
adding to his deposition testimony
indeed even if article the original
article two had survived
the president's belief
that he had worked quote worked through
the minefield of the jones deposition
without violating the law which is a
quote from his grand jury testimony
could not allow the managers somehow
to establish that that statement was
independently pedurious
and they surely cannot do so now
that the original article two has
disappeared
now as to the second and third remaining
elements of article one
that he president lied about mr
bennett's statement
to judge wright at the time of the jones
deposition and that he lied about his
own statements to his staff
i will deal with them
in my discussion of the obstruction
charges in article 2.
suffice it to say that nothing in the
record as it came to you in january
could support conviction on article 1
and nothing added to the record since
then
has changed that result
let me move to article two
manager hutchinson told you
in his original presentation
that article two rested on in his words
seven pillars of obstruction
i had suggested in my
opening statement of a few weeks ago
that would be more accurate to call them
seven shifting sand castles of
speculation
manager hutchinson has not proved
willing to accept my description
and so i will accept his
let's remove one pillar right at the
start
article 2 charges that the president
engaged in a scheme to obstruct the
jones case the jones case
and alleges as one element of this
scheme
that in the days following january 21st
the president lied to his staff
about his relationship with ms lewinsky
conduct that could not possibly have had
anything to do with the jones litigation
i will get to the merits of that charge
standing alone in a little while but i
bring up the more
forgive me technical argument here
to highlight once more the extent to
which the house simply ignored the most
basic legal principles
in bringing these charges to you
i have yet to hear from the managers a
single plausible explanation
for the inclusion of this charge
as part of a scheme to obstruct the
jones litigation
and i can think of
i'm sure that in
120 minutes remaining to them
some portion of that time
will be explained will be spent
explaining
just this point
and so one pillar gone
a slight list observed
next
ms lewinsky's affidavit
and the first of the empty pots
the managers charge that the president
corruptly encouraged a witness to
execute a sworn affidavit that he knew
to be perjurious false and misleading
and similarly encourage ms lewinsky to
lie if she were ever called as a witness
in my opening statement and mr kendall's
more detailed discussion
we made two points
first that ms lewinsky had repeatedly
denied that she had ever been asked or
encouraged to lie
and second that there was simply no
direct or circumstantial evidence
that the president had ever done such a
thing
now it's not in dispute that the
president called ms lewinsky on the
early morning of december 17th
to tell her about the death of betty
curry's brother
and in the same call that he told her
that she was now listed on the jones
witness list
the managers have from the beginning
relied on one fact
and on one baseless hypothesis
stemming from this call
which in the managers minds
was the beginning and the middle and the
end
of the scheme to encourage the filing of
a false affidavit
there is literally no other event or
statement on which they can rely
now the one fact to which the manager's
point
is ms lewinsky's testimony that the
president said
that if she were actually subpoenaed she
possibly could file an affidavit to
avoid having to testify
and at some point in the call
mentioned one of the so-called cover
stories that they had used when she was
still working at the white house
that is bringing papers to him
and it is on this shaky foundation
a very slim pillar indeed
that the managers build their hypothesis
in the face of the seemingly
insurmountable hurdle
of ms lewinsky's repeated denials
that anyone ever asked or encouraged her
to lie the managers have persisted in
arguing and continue to do so
that the president did somehow encourage
her to lie even if she didn't know it
now you've heard that theme sounded
really for the first time on saturday
and then a little bit today
even if she didn't know it
because both really understood that any
affidavit ms lewinsky would file would
have to be false
if it were to result in her avoiding her
deposition
but neither the fact on which they rely
nor their hypothesis
was of much help to the managers before
ms lewinsky's deposition
and neither surely has any force
after her deposition
after you saw ms lewinsky's testimony
there can be nothing left
of what was at best
only conjecture
even before her deposition
ms lewinsky had testified as had the
president in the grand jury
that given the claims being made in the
jones case
a truthful albeit limited affidavit
might
might establish that ms lewinsky had
nothing relevant to offer in the way of
testimony in the jones case
faced with this record the managers
asked you to authorize ms lewinsky's
deposition
representing that she would and i quote
and this is from the manager's proffer
rebut the following inferences drawn by
white house counsel on key issues
among others
that president clinton did not encourage
ms lewinsky to file a false affidavit
and that president clinton did not have
an understanding with ms lewinsky that
the two would lie under oath
unhappily for the managers and perhaps
their unhappiness was best reflected in
the tone of manager brian's discussion
on this subject
ms lewinsky's testimony as you saw
yourself on saturday did just the
opposite
in an extended colloquy with mr manager
brian
on the subject of the affidavit ms
lewinsky made clear beyond any doubt
first that the president had never
discussed the contents of the affidavit
with her
second
that there was no connection
between the suggestion that she might
file an affidavit and the reference to
any cover story
third that she believed it possible to
file a truthful affidavit
now you saw much of this portion of ms
lewinsky's deposition
on saturday
and i'm not going to impose too much on
your patience but i do want to play
just a very few segments
of that videotape
first two segments dealing with
the content of the affidavit
are you
did he make it strike it did he make any
representation to you about uh
what you could say in that affidavit or
no
what did you understand you would be
saying in that affidavit to avoid
testifying
i believe i've testified to this in the
grand jury
the best of my recollection it was
to my mind it came was a range of things
i mean could either be
something innocuous or
could go as far as having to deny the
relationship
not being a lawyer nor having gone to
law school was
i thought it could be anything
did he uh at that point suggest one
version or the other version
no i didn't even mention that
so that there wasn't a further
discussion there was no discussion of
what would be
in an affidavit
in his uh
answer
to this proceeding in the senate he has
indicated that
he thought he had might have had a way
that he could
have you
get you to follow basically a true
affidavit but yet still skirt these
issues enough
that you wouldn't be called as a witness
did he offer you any of these
suggestions at this time
he didn't discuss the content of my
affidavit with me at all
ever
next
a couple of brief segments
on the issue of the cover stories
may take just a moment here to queue up
well
based on prior
uh
relations with the president the
concocted stories and those things like
that did this come to mind
was there some discussion about that or
did it come to your mind about
not in connection with
not not in connection with the affidavit
did you discuss
anything else that night
in terms of
i would draw your attention to the cover
stories i've alluded to that earlier but
did you did you talk about cover story
that night yes sir
and what was said
um
i believe that
the president said something
you can always say you were coming to
see betty or bringing me papers
i think you've testified that you're
sure he said that that
it that night
um
you are sure he said that that night
yes now what was that in connection with
the affidavit i don't believe so
no now you have testified
in the in the grand jury
i think your closing comments was that
no one ever
asked you to lie
but yet in that very conversation
of december the 17th 1997 when the
president told you that you were on the
witness list he also suggested that you
could sign an affidavit
and use misleading cover story isn't
that correct
um
but i i guess in my mind i separate
necessarily signing affidavit and using
misleading cover stories so
um
well those two those three events
occurred but they don't they weren't
linked for me
and third
a brief segment
on the supposed
falsity of any affidavit that might be
filed
the night of the phone call he's
suggesting you could file an affidavit
did you
appreciate the implications of filing a
false affidavit with the with the court
i don't think i necessarily thought at
that point it would have to be false
so
no probably not i don't i don't remember
having any thoughts like that so
i
imagine i would remember something like
that and i don't but
and last if we might
a brief segment
on the question of whose interests
were being served
but you didn't file the affidavit for
your best interest did you
um
actually i did
to avoid testifying yes
brief
but pointed i think
and i'm sure you remember them from
saturday
and i'm sure you'll take those
excerpts with you
as you move into your deliberations
now there was another issue that
surfaced early on although perhaps it
has dissipated and that is whether
the president ever saw
a draft of ms lewinsky's affidavit
something that the managers alleged
early on
but indeed as we now know from
that testimony
not only did nobody ever see a draft of
the affidavit the president and mrs
linski never even discussed the content
of her affidavit not ever as she put it
either on december 17th or on january
5th or on any other date
according to ms lewinsky the president
told her he didn't need to see a draft
because he'd seen other affidavits
now early on manager mccullum speculated
for you
speculated for you
that when the president told ms lewinsky
that he didn't need to see her affidavit
because he'd seen other affidavits he
really must have meant that he'd seen
previous drafts of hers
and this is what he said
i doubt seriously the president was
talking about 15
other affidavits of somebody else
and didn't like looking at affidavits
anymore
i suspect and i would suggest to you
that he was talking about
15 other drafts of this proposed
affidavit since it had been around the
horn a lot of rounds
that's what manager mccullum told you
well now we know that those drafts
simply didn't exist
they never existed
how do we know
well somewhat belatedly the managers got
around to telling us that
in describing the testimony that they
would expect to receive from ms lewinsky
when they moved here for the right
to take her deposition
they wrote
in their motion
that same day january 5th she called
president clinton to ask if the
president would like to review her
affidavit before it was signed
he declined
saying he had already seen about 15
others
she understood that to mean that he had
seen 15 other affidavits rather than 15
prior drafts of her affidavit
parenthesis which did not exist
close parenthesis
in sum
one
the only reference to an affidavit in
the december 17th call was the
suggestion of the president that filing
one might possibly enable ms lewinsky to
avoid being deposed
itself an entirely legitimate and proper
suggestion
two
the president ms lewinsky never
discussed the content of her affidavit
on or after december 17th
three
the president never saw or read
any draft of the affidavit before it was
signed
four
the president believed that she could
file a true affidavit
five
ms lewinsky believed that she could file
a true
affidavit six
there is not one single document or
piece of testimony
that suggests that the president
encouraged her to file a false affidavit
well if there is no proof that the
president
encouraged ms lewinsky to file a false
affidavit surely there must be some
proof for the other charge that he
encouraged her to give progeria
testimony if she were ever called to
testify
well there isn't
let's begin by noting something that
should help you assess the president's
actions during this period
both the charge that he encouraged the
filing of a false affidavit
and the charge that he encouraged ms
lewinsky to testify falsely
a conversation that the managers allege
gave rise to both offenses
is that call of the early morning of
december 17th
and the managers suggest that the
president in essence
used the subterfuge of a call to inform
ms lewinsky about the death of ms
curry's brother to discuss her status as
a witness in the jones case
subterfuge
come on
a tragedy had befallen a woman
who was ms lewinsky's friend and the
president's secretary
but let's put this in the manager's own
context
on december 6th the president learned
that ms lewinsky was on the jones
witness list
according to the managers that was a
source of grave concern and spurred
intensified efforts to find her a job
efforts that were still further
intensified when on december 11th judge
wright issued her order allowing lawyers
to inquire into
president's relationships with other
women
yet i have not heard any explanation as
to why the president
now theoretically so distraught
that he was urging mr jordan to keep ms
lewinsky happy by finding her a job as
manager hutchinson would have it
waited until december 17th 11 days after
he learned ms lewinsky was on the
witness list and six days after the
supposedly critical events of december
11th
to call and launch his scheme to suborn
perjury
now as to the charge of subernation the
pres the managers do concede
as they must
that the president ms lewinsky did not
even discuss her deposition on the 17th
logically i suppose and she wasn't
actually subpoenaed until two days later
now one might think that this would
dispose of the matter
since they do not identify a single
other moment in time when there was any
discussion of ms lewinsky's potential
testimony
but once again
having lifted the lid and seen that
their pot was empty
they would ask you to find that the same
signal
that we now know did not encourage the
filing of an affidavit
was a signal to ms lewinsky to lie
if she was ever called to testify
but of course we've long known that
there was no such signal
in the grand jury as was so often the
case one of the jurors took it upon him
or herself to ask that which the
independent counsel chose not to
and you have this before
and you've seen it before
a juror
it is possible that you also had these
discussions about denying the
relationship
after you learned that you were a
witness in the paula jones case ms
lewinsky i don't believe so no
a jury can you exclude that possibility
ms lewinsky i pretty much can
i really don't remember it
i mean it would be very surprising for
me to be confronted with something that
would show me different but i it was 2
30 and i mean the conversation i'm
thinking of mainly would have to be
december 17th which was a jury the
telephone call ms lewinsky right
and it was you know 2 2 30 in the
morning i remember the gist of it and i
i really don't think so
a jury
thank you
but all of this
is not enough to dissuade the managers
now that they know that the only two
participants in the relevant
conversation
deny that there was any discussion of
either the affidavit or the testimony
they have created
still
another theory
as manager bryant told you last week
and in essence it was repeated today
quote
i don't care
what was in
ms lewinsky's mind
well that is quite extraordinary
the only witness the supposed victim of
the obstruction the person whose
testimony is being influenced
says that it didn't happen
and the managers nonetheless want you to
conclude i assume
that some subliminal message
was being conveyed that resulted in the
filing of a false affidavit without the
affiant knowing that she was being
controlled by some unseen and unheard
force
i won't comment further
two more pillars
lie in the dust
next
the gifts
on this charge the record is largely but
in critical respects not entirely as the
record has been from the beginning
here is what it shows
on the morning of december 28th
the president gave ms lewinsky christmas
presents and token over impending
departure
for new york
mrs lewinsky testified that she raised
the subject of her subpoena and said
something about getting the gifts out of
her apartment to which as she herself
has now told you
the president
either made
no response
or said something like let me think
about it
betty curry has testified consistently
that ms lewinsky called her
to ask her to pick up a box and hold
them for her
as lewinsky has testified equally
consistently
and testified again in her deposition
that it was her recollection that ms
curry called her
and said that she understood she quote
had something for her or perhaps even
the president said you have something
for me
the president denies that he ever spoke
to betty curry about picking up gifts
from monica lewinsky betty curry denies
that the president ever asked her to
pick up
gifts from monica lewinsky
ms lewinsky has stated on three
occasions before her most recent
deposition
that ms curry picked up the gifts at two
o'clock in the afternoon on the 28th
having been shown
the infamous 332
cell phone call
which had previously been trumpeted by
the managers as absolute proof that it
was ms curry who called ms lewinsky to
initiate the process
ms lewinsky testified on monday that
miss curry came to pick up the gifts
sometime during the afternoon and that
there had been other calls earlier in
the day
but we learned
at least a couple of interesting new
things
from ms lewinsky on this subject
first when she received her subpoena on
december 19th
nine days nine days before she spoke to
the president about them
ms lewinsky was frightened at the
prospect that the jones lawyers would
search her apartment
and she began to think about concealing
the gifts that she cared most about or
that would suggest some special
relationship with the president
and as she told you she herself decided
then
that she would turn over only what she
described as the most innocuous gifts
and it was those gifts that she took
with her to see her lawyer mr carter on
december 22nd
thus when she arrived to pick up her
christmas gifts from the president on
december 28th
she had already decided that she would
not turn over all the gifts called for
by the subpoena
and had already segregated out the one
she intended to withhold
but she didn't tell the president about
that
instead as she testified she broached
the question of what to do with the
gifts and the possibility of giving them
to betty curry
again without describing what had
already occurred
to which the president either made no
reply or said something like i'll think
about it this testimony sheds light on
one of the issues that has troubled
everyone who has tried to make sense out
of what happened on that day
why would the president if he were
really worried about ms lewinsky's
turning over gifts pursuant to the
subpoena
give her more gifts
from our perspective the answer is
already has always been an easy one
he wouldn't have been concerned
he's testified that he's not concerned
about gifts that he gives them all the
time
to all sorts of people and he wasn't
worried about it
now we know that from ms lewinsky's
perspective
as she explained in her deposition
it also made no difference that the
president was giving her additional
gifts
because she had already decided
having had the subpoena in hand for nine
days
that she would not turn them over
now a second ray of light also shines on
two aspects of the manager's case
from ms lewinsky's deposition
you remember may remember that as part
of article one
in their trial brief the managers allege
that the president lied to the grand
jury
this is one of the never-ending list of
possible perjuries
that he recalled saying to ms lewinsky
on december 28th
that she would have to quote turn over
whatever she had
unquote when she raised the gift issue
with her
well the managers sought to obtain from
ms lewinsky testimony that would support
that charge of perjury as well as the
concealment charge
under article 2.
but she turned their world upside down
on both the perjury charge and the
obstruction charge
when asked whether the president had
ever said to her
you will have to give them whatever you
have
or something like that ms lewinsky
testified that fbi agent phelan
of the oic had interviewed her after the
president's grand jury testimony
after they already knew what the
president had said under oath
and asked her whether she recalled the
president's saying anything like that to
her
and i'm sure somewhat to the surprise
of manager bryant
she testified that she told agent fallon
quote that sounds familiar
now aside from the not so minor point
that ms lewinsky's testimony
corroborates the president's
recollection of his response and
undermines the charge for both article
one and article two
a couple of other things are worth
noting
as my colleague ms seligman pointed out
to you
on saturday
this was the first time
after all ms lewinsky's recorded
versions of the events of december 28
that we had ever heard that the
president's version
sounded familiar to him
and second there is not a single piece
of paper at least that we're aware of
and the entire universe turned over by
the independent council to the house and
thence to us
that reflects the fbi's interview with
ms lewinsky
if she hadn't been honest enough to tell
manager brian about it
we and you would never have known
senators what else is there in the
vaults
of the independent council
or in the memory of his agents that we
don't know about
another pillar down
the job search
it may have become tiresome to hear it
but any discussion of the job search
must begin with ms lewinsky's testimony
oft repeated that no one promised her a
job to influence her testimony
remember my two themes
moving targets
empty pots
they come together here
what the managers have presented to you
is a series of different speculative
theories
as each one is shown to be what it is
they move on to the next in the hope
they will find one someday
that actually has a connection to
reality
but they cannot find that elusive theory
for the stubborn facts
will not budge
nor will the stubborn denials by every
participant in their mythical plot
now we know that ms lewinsky's job
search began
in the summer of 97 well in advance of
her being involved
in the jones case in october she
interviewed with you and ambassador
richardson was offered a job
she had her first meeting with mr jordan
early in november
well before she appeared in the jones
case
the next contact was actually before
thanksgiving when she made an effort to
set up another meeting mr jordan was
told to call back after the holiday
she did on december 8th
and set up a meeting
on december 11th again before either she
or mr jordan knew that she was
involved in the jones case
now on that date of december 11th which
we've heard so much about
mr jordan did open doors for ms lewinsky
in new york
but there was no inappropriate pressure
at american express and young and
rubicam
she failed on her own
and at revlon she succeeded on her own
as mr jordan told the grand jury when
asked whether there was any connection
between his assistance to her and the
jones case
his answer was
unequivocally
indubitably
no
in search of some efforts that mr jordan
have some evidence that mr jordan's
efforts were indeed triggered by ms
lewinsky's status as a witness and
therefore possibly inappropriate
the manager's focus on his january 8th
call
mr perlman the ceo of mcandrews and
forbes
admittedly a date by which mizelinski's
status was known
to her to mr jordan and to the president
mr winsky had reported that her original
interview had not gone well although we
know it actually had and that her resume
had already been sent over from the
canters and forbes to revlon where she
was ultimately offered a job
ms jordan was candid in stating that he
went to the top because he wanted to get
action if action could be had
but the record's clear
that the woman involved at revlon who
interviewed ms lewinsky had already made
a decision to hire her
no one put any pressure on her there was
no special urgency there was no fix
in fact if you want to know what happens
when mr jordan calls the ceo of a
company to get action
look at his call to the ceo of young and
rubicam
no job
no job
they made an independent decision
whether or not to hire ms lewinsky
now other than the managers there are
only two people as far as i can tell
who've ever tried to create a link
between
the job search
and the affidavit linda tripp
kenneth stark
no one not ms lewinsky i'm mr jordan not
the president
no one ever said anything to so much as
suggest
the existence of such a linkage
and the managers can find no proof
which is not to say they didn't try
manager hutchinson you'll recall
originally asked you to look at the
events of january 5th
when he said that ms lewinsky had met
with her attorney mr carter
and then according to the manager's
account
mr carter began drafting the affidavit
and ms lewinsky was so concerned that
she called the president and he returned
her call
well the problem with his version as my
colleague
mr kendall showed you
was the affidavit wasn't drafted until
january 6th
mr carter is so testified
now the managers would also have you
believe that mr jordan was involved in
drafting the
affidavit and that he was involved in
the deletion of language from the draft
that suggested that she'd been alone
with the president
ms lewinsky's in mr jordan's testimony
is essentially the same
they talked mr jordan listen you recall
him saying yes she was talking and i was
doodling
he called mr carter
he transmitted to mr carter some of her
concerns but he made it very clear to ms
lewinsky he wasn't her lawyer
and in
words that will
resonate forever at least among the
legal community mr jordan said
i don't do affidavits
and of course mr carter himself
testified that it was his idea
to delete the language about being alone
now the very best that the managers can
do on this issue
is to establish that ms lewinsky talk to
mr jordan
in the same conversation about the job
search and about her affidavit
but as mr jordan told you
ms lewinsky was always talking about the
job search
and he made it very clear to you that
there was no linkage between the two if
we can play just a very brief segment of
mr jordan's
deposition
in your conversation with miss lewinsky
prior to the affidavit being signed did
you in fact talk to her about both the
job and her concerns about parts of the
affidavit
i have never in any conversation with
miss lewinsky
talk to her about the job on one hand
uh
or job being interrelated with the
conversation about the affidavit the
affidavit was over here the job was over
here but the
and of course we've already dispensed
with the notion to the extent that the
managers continue to assert it
that the president ever discussed the
contents of the affidavit with ms
lewinsky or even ever saw a draft
now recognizing that they would never be
able to show
that
the inception of the job search was
linked in any way
to the affidavit the managers developed
the theory which they've advanced to you
that the president committed obstruction
of justice
when the job search assistance became in
their words quote totally incorrect
interconnected intertwined interrelated
unquote with the filing of ms lewinsky's
affidavit
the problem the managers have had
however
is that they've not been able to figure
out
when this occurred
why it occurred
or how it occurred
think back on how many versions
of their theory you have heard just in
the last few weeks
first
it all started on december 11th when
judge wright issued her order permitting
the
jones lawyers to take depositions
to prove
that the president had relations with
other women
that was what galvanized the president
and mr jordan to make real efforts to
find ms lewinsky a job
whoops didn't quite fit the facts
mr jordan met with ms lewinsky and made
calls to prospective employers
before the order was issued
all right let's try this second well it
wasn't really the 11th you see
it was the fifth
when the witness list came out
but they'd already told you in their
trial brief
quite explicitly
and in the majority report of the
committee to the congress
that there was no urgency those are
there was there was no urgency
after december 5th
now i'm a city boy but
that dog went back to sleep
third
as manager hutchinson told you on
saturday
what really happened was that
by december 17th
the president had quote got the job
search moving
and thought quote maybe she's now more
receptive unquote and that's why he
called ms lewinsky on the 17th and told
her she was on the witness list
nice try
no facts
now i don't know whether this chart
which manager hutchinson used
was intended to speak for itself or
to be
elucidated by his own comments
but let's look at it
december 5th
witness list lewinsky exclamation point
true
but this list comes out
monica lewinsky's name is on it
six december sixth
president meets with attorneys on
witness list
true
seven president and jordan meet
well that's also true
but we know
i didn't talk about monica lewinsky
not quite sure why it's there
8th
lewinsky sets up a meeting with jordan
for the 11th
true
at that point she doesn't know she's on
the list mr jordan doesn't know that
she's on the list
the 11th
the lewinsky job meeting with jordan
yes
true and as we know
well before judge wright's order came
out they still don't know the two of
them
that there is
that her name is on the witness list
december 17th the call
true
you're on the list
december 19th
the subpoena is served true
december 28th
president and lewinsky
meet and
gifts are concealed now true but i'm not
sure
what that means
in this context and last
interestingly
breakfast at the park hyatt
more evidence at risk
now
it is
clear
that if you string all these events
together
and you have a theory
that will link them all together
you've made some progress
there's only one problem
other than what we know to be true
on this list
there is nothing other than surmise
that links them together
in any fashion that one could consider
improper
are certainly illegal
but that is in essence
where the managers have brought us in
their theorizing
for their fourth theory is that the
pressure did not really begin to build
until ms lewinsky was actually
subpoenaed and began to prepare an
affidavit
and on this theory the call to mr
perlman was the final step
going right to the top of mcandrews and
forbes to make absolutely sure
that ms lewinsky stayed on the team
but here there are other facts to deal
with
for example look what happened or more
importantly didn't happen on december
19.
on that day monica lewinsky came weeping
to mr jordan's office
carrying with her the dreaded subpoena
and mr jordan called the president
and visited him with that visited with
him that evening and you'll recall that
he talked in very candid terms to ms
lewinsky and to mr jordan
about their relationship
excuse me to the president about their
relationship
wouldn't one think that
if the president was in fact engaged in
some scheme
to use a job in new york to influence ms
lewinsky his testimony that this would
be the critical moment that some
immediate steps would be taken
to be absolutely sure that there was a
job for her
but what do we find
mr jordan takes no further action on the
job front
until january 8th
now there was never so much as a passing
reference
concerning any connection between the
job search and the affidavit among any
of the three participants
any of the three participants there's
not one conversation that anyone could
conclude was designed to implement this
nefarious scheme
that the managers would have you find
and so now we have an entirely new
theory
a one-man conspiracy
a beast unknown
i think
to anglo-american jurisprudence
now the fact that ms lewinsky didn't no
this is under manager's theory the fact
that ms lewinsky didn't know she was on
the witness list until december 17th
and mr jordan didn't know about it until
she was subpoenaed on the 19th and mr
pearlman never knew it
all are proof positive that the
president himself was the mastermind
pulling on unseen strings and
influencing the participants in this
drama without there even knowing that
they were being influenced
under this theory
the latest in the long line
ms lewinsky's denial that she ever
discussed the contents of raffa david
with the president
her denial that there was any connection
between the job and her testimony mr
jordan's denial that there was any
connection between his efforts to find
her a job
and the affidavit and the fact that mr
jordan never discussed any such
connection with the president
are simply evidence of the fact that
there must have been such a connection
that unbeknownst to ms lewinsky she was
being corruptly encouraged to file
a false affidavit
with all due respect
somebody's been watching too many reruns
of the x-files
confronted with this problem the
managers now offer you one last theory
with ever increasing directness they now
accuse mr jordan himself
of obstructing justice by urging ms
lewinsky to destroy her notes
seemingly they ask you to find even in
the face of mr jordan's forceful denials
that one who would forget a breakfast at
the park hyatt
until reminded of it by being shown
their receipt
and who would then admit that his
recollection was refreshed and who would
admit that he remembered a discussion of
the notes
must have obstructed justice himself
and of course
must have been engaged all along
with an effort to influence ms
lewinsky's testimony on behalf of the
president
nonsense
nonsense
and so this pillar returns to the dust
from which it came
next
the charge that the events surrounding
mr bennett's statement to judge wright
during the jones deposition
formed the basis for two chart
they formed the basis for two charges
first that the president obstructed
justice in the jones case
and second that he committed perjury by
telling the grand jury that he really
wasn't paying attention at the critical
moment
both charges depend on the manager's
ability to prove that indeed the
president hadn't had been paying
attention to do that they had always
relied
on the videotape of the deposition in
which it can be seen that the president
was looking in the direction of his
lawyer while mr bennett was talking
but two weeks ago
two weeks ago they came to you and they
produced with a modest flourish a new
bit of evidence an affidavit from mr
barry ward
clerk to judge wright
trumpeted in their words
as quote lending even greater credence
to their claim
now in their memorandum in support of
their request to expand the record by
including mr ward's affidavit the
managers told you the following
and this is the manager's own language
from his seat at the conference table
next to the judge he saw president
clinton listening attentively to mr
bennett's remarks while the exchange
between mr bennett and the judge
occurred
further the managers say mr ward's
declaration would lend even greater
credence to the argument that president
lincoln lied on the president clinton
lied on this point during his grand jury
testimony and obstructed justice by
allowing his attorney to utilize a false
affidavit in order to cut off a
legitimate line of questioning mr ward's
declaration proves that mr ward saw
president clinton listening attentively
while the exchange between mr bennett
and the presiding judge occurred
but
this is what mr ward's affidavit
actually says
the affidavit that was attached to the
very motion
the language from which i just read to
you
and i direct your attention
only to the last sentence because this
is the only one
of any moment from my position at the
conference table i observed president
clinton looking directly at mr bennett
while this statement was being
made
search if you will
for any
evidence
relating to whether the president was
looking attentively or not
there is not one iota of evidence
added to the videotape
you were misled
indeed
mr ward said to the legal times on
february 1st 1999
i have no idea if he was paying
attention he could have been thinking
about policy initiatives for all i know
you were misled
the record before the affidavit is the
record after the affidavit
the managers asked that you remove the
president of the united states
on the basis of a videotape
showing that he was looking in the
direction of his lawyer
well it wasn't much of a pillar to start
with
there's no dispute and we move now to
the conversation of january 18th with
between the president and mrs curry
there's no dispute that president
clinton called ms curry
into the white house on sunday january
18th the day after his deposition
and asked her certain questions and made
certain statements about his
relationship with mr ms lewinsky
the only dispute is whether in doing so
the president intended to tamper with a
witness
managers contend that he was corruptly
attempting to influence ms curry's
testimony
the president denies it
now since we know that ms curry was not
on the jones witness list at the time of
the president's deposition or at the
time of either of his conversations with
miss curry
and we know that discovery was about to
end
the managers have argued that the
president's own references to her in the
jones deposition
constituted an invitation to the jones
lawyers to subpoena
and they argue that proof of that
invitation can be found in a witness
list signed by the jones lawyers on
january 22nd
which listed ms curry and 17 other
potential witnesses
now when i spoke to you on january 19th
i told you that ms curry had never been
placed on a witness list
i was wrong
and manager hutchinson has quite
properly taken me to task for it
but i fear that he's become so caught up
in this new information
that he has lost sight of its true
significance or rather lack thereof
in order to convince you that betty
curry was going to be called by the
jones lawyers
when the president spoke to her on
january 18th the managers
somewhat like diogenes lit their lantern
and sought out the most reliable witness
they could find
a witness whose credibility was beyond
question
who had no ulterior motive no bias
paula jones lawyer
and they brought him to you in a form
that they hoped would allow his motive
and bias to go untested
remember how the managers have told you
that it's important to be able to look
and witness in the eye
test his demeanor
i doubt that you need to do that to
understand
what my color mr holmes's view of the
world
so let's look at what he had to say
you have in the
exhibits before you
an unredacted witness list attached to
mr holm's affidavit i put up on the
easels
the redacted list that was originally
used by the managers
a few weeks ago
because i really see no purpose in
unduly exposing
the names of the people
who are on that witness list
but let me direct you
to these words just as a sidelight
under seal
you'll remember that the president has
been character criticized
for violating the gag order
when he spoke to his own secretary about
his deposition
what then do we say
when the managers produce
a document from a lawyer for one of the
parties
that is still under seal
not yet released by the court
and reveals the name of the names of
individuals who are no part of these
proceedings
surely the managers could have made
their point just as well
without such a revelation
now mr holmes states that the jones
lawyers had two reasons for putting
ms curry's name on the witness list
one because of president clinton's
deposition testimony and two because
they had quote
received what they considered to be
reliable information that ms curry was
instrumental in facilitating monica
lewinsky's meetings
with mr clinton
and that ms curry was central to the
cover story
mr clinton and ms lewinsky had developed
to use in the event their affair was
discovered
now he doesn't tell us where he got this
reliable information but of course we
know it's miss tripp
but let's figure out whether in fact
betty curry really made it on the list
because of the president's testimony
if you look at the number of times that
she's mentioned in the deposition
it's become conventional wisdom that the
president inserted her name
into his testimony so frequently and so
gratuitously
that he did in fact invite the jones
lawyers to call her and thus must have
known that she was going to be a witness
when he spoke to her on january 18th
but if you look at the deposition you'll
find that the first time her name is
mentioned
president is simply responding to a
question about his early meetings with
ms lewinsky and states that betty was
present
the lawyers for the plaintiff then asked
13 questions give or take a few
about ms curry
and we know
there's no secret
from linda tripp and linda tripp surely
told them
about ms lewinsky's relationship with
miss curry
it was only in response to a couple of
their questions about whether letters
had ever been delivered to miss curry
and whether she stated some strongly
late hour that the president said you'll
have to ask her
he didn't invite
he didn't suggest to them that they
called ms curry
they knew
whatever they needed to know about ms
curry to put her on their witness list
now to judge further
whether ms curry made it onto the list
at the president's invitation or because
they already
knew about
witnesses from this trip let me direct
your attention if you look at the
exhibit in front of you rather than the
redacted version here
the person listed on the witness list at
number 165
her name
does not come up at all
in the deposition
but we know
that she was in fact the subject of
conversation surreptitiously recorded
between ms tripp and ms lewinsky
and note 2 the name of vernon jordan
which is on this list
they're the ones the jones lawyers the
ones who first bring him up
and we know of course that they knew
from his trip
that he was already involved in this
scenario
thus neither the january 22nd witness
list nor mr holmes affidavit supports
the manager's theory
president did not know ms curry would be
a witness
when he spoke to her after a deposition
and he could not therefore
have tampered with a witness
well beyond
their statement about how they got this
information mr holmes volunteers that
they didn't get it from the washington
post
well perhaps not
but it's clear that in the days after
the post story broke
we know that some of the names on the
list came from the press reports we know
that jones lawyers began tracking the
newly public activities of the
independent council which was issuing
its own subpoenas
in the hours and days following the
story's release
and for some insight into what at least
the independent council thought was
going on
look at the pleading they filed with
judge wright on wednesday january 28th
to prevent the jones lawyers from
continuing to use their investigation as
an aide
that is the ics investigation as an aide
to civil discovery that pleading said as
recently as this afternoon
plaintiff's council caused process to be
served on betty curry who appeared
before the grand jury in washington
yesterday such deliberate and calculated
shadowing of the grand jury's
investigation will necessarily pierce
the veil of grand jury secrecy
now the managers have criticized us
for ignoring a second conversation
between the president and this curry
suggesting i suppose that it takes on an
even more sinister cast than the first
but there's simply nothing of any
substance to take from this second
conversation that adds to the events of
january 18th
it's clear that the conversation
occurred
on tuesday january 20th
before the star investigation became
public
the managers disingenuously have
suggested in their exhibits
the one they distributed on saturday
that this conversation occurred after
the post story appear
and if you look at the exhibit that was
used on saturday you'll see
january 20th post story is known of
course that's late at night january 21st
posted on the internet president calls
betty for 20 minutes and then sort of
sneaking it in down here
january 20th or 21st
president coaches
curry for the second time
but the record shows this ms curry has
said
that the conversation occurred quote
whenever the president was next in the
white house
that is after the sunday conversation
and that was tuesday
the 20th the day after the martin luther
king holiday
thus the second conversation is of no
like greater legal significance than the
first
since the president knew no more about
ms curry's status as a witness
on tuesday than he did on sunday
in some the managers have tried to
convince you that the president knew
or must have known
that betty
curry would be a witness in the jones
case
if anything we now know that the reason
she was put on the january 22nd list
along with many others
had more to do
with linda tripp
than anything else
but putting this aside for the moment
that is putting aside the question
whether the president could have had any
reason to believe
that miss curry would be a witness
look at whether miss curry herself
believed
that she was being corruptly influenced
on january 18th
in response to continuing efforts by the
prosecutors to get her to admit that she
felt some untoward pressure from the
president
she testified and you've seen this
before as well
did you feel pressured when he told you
those statements
none whatsoever
and what did you think of what was going
through your mind about what he was
doing
at the time i felt that he was i want to
use the word shocked or surprised that
this was an issue and he was just
talking
question that was your impression that
he wanted you to say because he would
end each of the statements with right
with a question
answer
i do not remember that he wanted me to
say right he would say right and i could
have said
wrong
and at the end
did you feel any pressure to agree with
your boss
none and so on a human level a human
level we have the president who has just
seen
his worst nightmare come true
and who knows that he's about to face a
press title wave that will wash over him
and his family and a country and we have
his secretary who knows of indeed has
been a part of
his relationship with monica lewinsky
but knows nothing about the long since
ended improper aspects of that
relationship
we have a conversation that was the
product of the emotions
that were churning through the
president's very soul on that day
what we do not have
is an attempt corruptly to influence the
testimony of a witness
only one pillar left
the managers asked the senate to find
that the president's conversations with
mr blumenthal
and other aides was an effort to
influence their testimony before the
grand jury
their theory much as was true of some of
their other theories
founders on shoals that they don't
account for
as they would have it
in the days immediately following the
lewinsky story
the president spoke with a few members
of his senior staff
as they would allege knowing that they
would probably be grand jury witnesses
and misled them about his relationship
with ms lewinsky
so they would convey that misinformation
to the grand jury when they were called
now just so that you can see for
yourself
what the president testified to in the
grand jury on this subject i want to
play
about three or four minutes of that
testimony for you
either you denied a sexual relations or
relationship with monica lewinsky or if
they've told us that you denied that do
you have any reason to doubt in the days
after the story broke do you have any
reason to doubt no the
let me say this
it's no secret to anybody
that i hope that this relationship would
never become public
it's it's a matter of fact that it had
been many many months since there had
been anything improper
about it
in terms of improper contact
did
let me finish
so
what i did not want to mislead my
friends but i wanted to find language
where i could say that
i also frankly did not want to turn any
of them into witnesses
uh because i
and sure enough they all became
witnesses
well you knew that so and so i said to
them things that were true about this
relationship
that i used in the in the language i
used i said there's nothing going on
between us that was true
i said uh i have not had sex with her as
i define it that was true
and did i hope
that i would never have to be here on
this day giving this testimony of course
but i also didn't want to do anything to
complicate
this matter further so i said things
that were true
they may have been misleading and if
they were i have to take responsibility
for it and i'm sorry they may have been
misleading sir and you knew though after
january 21st when the post article broke
and said that judge starr was looking
into this he knew that they might be
witnesses
he knew that they might be called into a
grand jury didn't you so i think i was
quite careful what i said after that i
may have said something to all these
people of that effect but i i also
whenever anybody asked me any details i
said look i don't want you to be a
witness or i turn you into witness or
give you information that could get you
in trouble i just wouldn't talk i by and
large didn't talk to people about it if
all of these people
let's leave out mrs curry for a minute
vernon jordan said blumenthal john
podesta harold ickes erskine bowles
harry thompson after the story broke
after judge starr's involvement was
known on january 21st have said that you
denied a sexual relationship with them
are you denying that no
and i'm just telling you what i meant
but i told you what i meant by when they
started this deposition you told us now
that you were being careful but then it
might have been misleading is that
correct it might have been
since uh
we have seen
this this four-year 40 million dollar
investigation come down to parsing the
definition of sex
i think it might have been i i don't
think at the time that i thought that's
what this was going to be about
in fact if you remember the headlines at
the time
even you mentioned that post story all
the headlines were
in all the talking
with people who talked about this
including a lot who have been quite
sympathetic to your operation
said well this is not really a story
about sex this is a story about
subernation of perjury and these talking
points and all this other stuff
so i what i was trying to do was to to
give them something they could that
would be true even if
misleading in the context of this
deposition
and keep them out of trouble and let's
deal and deal with the what i thought
was the almost ludicrous suggestion that
i had urged someone to lie or tried to
suborn perjury in other ways
now it's clear from that excerpt i think
that in the hours and days immediately
following the release of the post story
the president was struggling with two
competing concerns
how to give some explanation to the men
and women
we worked with every day
and worked with most closely without
putting them in the position
of being grand jury witnesses
but he was not in any sense seeking
to tamper with them or to obstruct the
grand jury's investigation
putting aside for the moment our
strenuous disagreement both with the
factual underpinning of and the legal
conclusions
that flow from the manager's analysis of
these events
i find it difficult
to figure out
how it is that they believe
the president
intended that his statement to mr
blumenthal or his statement to mr
podesta
would
involve their conveying
false information to the grand jury
or that he sought in some fashion
to send that message to the grand jury
when at the very moment that those aids
were first subpoenaed
he asserted executive privilege
to prevent them from testifying before
the grand jury
for someone who wanted mr blumenthal
to serve as the manners would have it
as his messenger of lies
that's strange behavior
indeed
now there's an issue here that i don't
really
want to get into at length and i not
having heard the last two hours of
the manager's presentation don't know
whether they're going to get into
and that is
manager graham's favorite issue
question of whether
there was some scheme to smear monica
lewinsky early middle or late
other than to say that no such plan ever
existed i just want to ask the managers
this
although i must admit that for the first
time in my life i have heard marlene
dietrich's name used as a pejorative
what was manager brian saying
about ms
lewinsky that she was lying
that she'd misled the managers
that because her testimony helped the
president they were not going to attack
her character and her integrity
i don't know how many of you seen
witness for the prosecution
either before or after
mr bryant used that example
but ask yourselves
what was he saying
what was he doing
ladies and gentlemen the senate i don't
know whether there's a market for used
pillars
but they're all lying in the dust
it's difficult for me as a lawyer as an
advocate for my client
to speak to this body about lofty
constitutional principles
without seeming merely to engage in
empty rhetoric
but i'd like to think i guess that if
there were ever a forum
in which i could venture
into that realm be excused for doing so
could be heard without the intervening
filter of skepticism that i fear too
often lies between
lawyer and listener this is the time and
this is the moment
only once before in our nation's history
has any lawyer
had the opportunity
to make a closing argument on behalf of
the president of the united states and
only once before has the senate
ever had to sit in judgment on the head
of the executive branch
we all must cast an eye to the past
looking over our shoulders to be sure
that we've learned the right lessons
from those who've sat in this chamber
before us
we also must look at the future
to be sure that we leave the right
lessons to those who come after us
we hope that no one will ever have need
of them
but if they should
we owe them
not only the proper judgment for today
but the proper judgment for all time
now you've heard the managers tell you
very early on in these meetings
that we've advanced a quote so what
defense
that we're saying that the president's
conduct is really nothing to be
concerned about
that we should all simply go home and
ignore what he has done
not of course to
choose a word that would have been
familiar to the framers themselves
is balderdash
if you want to see so what in action
look elsewhere
so what if the framers reserved
impeachment and removal
for only those offenses that threaten
the state
so what if the house judiciary committee
didn't quite do their constitutional job
if they took
the independent council's referral and
added a few frills and then washed the
hands of it
so what if the house approved articles
that wouldn't pass muster
in any court in the land
so what
if the managers have been creating their
own theories of impeachment as they go
along
and so what and so what
and so what
by contrast what we offer is not
so what
but this
ask what the framers handed down to us
is the standard for moving the president
ask what impeachment
and removal would mean to our system of
government
in years to come
ask what you always ask in this chamber
what is best for the country
no the president wouldn't allow any of
us
to say so what
to so much as suggest that he what he
has done can simply be forgotten
he's asked for forgiveness from his
family and from the american people
and he's asked for the opportunity to
earn back
their trust
in his opening remarks
manager hyde
questioned whether this president
can represent the interests of our
country in the world
go to ireland and ask that question go
to israel in gaza and ask that question
or if you doubt whether he should
hear at home
continue in office
ask the parent whose child walks safer
streets by the men and women
who go off to work in the morning at
good jobs
we are
we are together i think
weavers of a constitutional fabric in
which
all of us now are clothed
and generations will be clothed for
millennia to come
we cannot leave even the smallest flaw
in that fabric
for if we do
one day
someone will come along
and pull a thread
and the floor will grow and it will eat
away at the fabric around it
and soon
the entire cloth will begin to unwrap
we must be as close to perfect
in what we do here today
as women and men are capable of being
if there is doubt about our course
surely we must take special care
as we hold the fabric of democracy
in our hands
to leave it as we found it
tightly woven
and strong
now before today i wrote down
the following
the rules say that the managers will
have the last word
well the rules today say the manners
will have the last paragraphs
but that truly isn't so because even
when they are finished
theirs will not be the last voices you
hear yes one or more of them will now
rise and come to the podium and tell you
that they have the right of it and we
the wrong that our sense of what the
constitution demands
is not theirs and should not be used
that is their privilege
but as each of them does come before you
for the final time and as you listen to
them
i know that you will hear not their
eloquence as grand as it may be
not the pointed jibes of manager
hutchinson or the centaurian tones of
manager rogan nor the homespun homilies
of manager graham
nor the grave exhortations of manager
hyde
but voices of greater eloquence than any
of us can muster
the voices of madison and hamilton
and the others who met in philadelphia
212 years ago
and the voices of the generations since
and the voices of the american people
now
and the voices of generations to come
these
not the voices of mere advocates
must be your god
it's been an honor for all of us
to appear before you
in these last weeks
on behalf of the president
and now our last words to you
which are the words i began began with
william jefferson clinton is not guilty
of the charges that have been brought
against him
he did not commit perjury
he did not commit obstruction of justice
he must not be removed from office thank
you very much
the chair recognized the majority
justice i asked consent that we take a
15-minute recess without objection it's
so ordered
as the senate takes this 15-minute
recess we are going to open our phone
lines streetsboro ohio good afternoon
good afternoon i'm for acquittal i think
the president is a wonderful man a good
president and i think the republicans
should leave him alone it should stop
right now
thank you
the senate will be in order
the chair recognized the majority leader
justice i believe now we're ready to
meet with
the managers from the house i understand
that they do have a two-hour
presentation um and i will look for
guidance from the chief justice about
whether or not we should take a break
for the last 45 minutes
that would be after mr manager
rogan if at all
very well
the chair recognizes mr manager mccollum
uh mr chief justice and members of the
senate
at the outset of my closing remarks i
would like to
lay the record straight on a couple of
matters with all due deference to white
house counsel
the suggestion that mr ruff made at the
beginning of his closing that we were
somehow being unfair to him on the
timing today of the rebuttal it seems to
me to be a little strained
he thinks thou does protest too much was
a remark i used earlier a quote from
shakespeare and i think it's appropriate
here too because if you recall we had no
rebuttal at all as you normally would
have at the big end of our case to begin
with and secondly we thought we ought to
have live witnesses here but we haven't
had those and the list could go on and i
really don't think that we are being
unfair
secondly uh i would like to make one
correction and make a clear point i i'm
sure it was not intended but in your
remarks i believe mr ruff you indicated
there was no history with regard to
beyond a reasonable doubt uh standard
maybe i misunderstood that but i want
the record to be clear that in the
claiborne case there was in fact a vote
that took place here in case of judge
claiborne some 75 to 17 saying that that
standard did not apply to impeachment
cases
now having said that
i would like to move on to my own
thoughts
notwithstanding the clever and
resourceful arguments that white house
counsel have made to you today and in
the past few weeks
i suspect that
that most of you probably more than
two-thirds believe that the president
did indeed commit most of if not all of
the crimes he's charged with under these
articles of impeachment
and i suspect that a great many of you
share my view that these are high crimes
and misdemeanors
but nonetheless it is my understanding
that some of you who share these views
are not prepared to vote to convict the
president and remove him from office
that instead you are of the mind at the
moment subject to persuading you
otherwise in your own debate to acquit
him
ultimately the choice is yours not ours
but a few moments i'd like to spend with
you reviewing just a few of the facts
not many
and suggesting to you what i believe and
we managers would believe would be some
very significant negative consequences
of failing to remove this president
having heard all the evidence over the
past few days and weeks there should be
little doubt
that beginning in december 1977
william jefferson clinton set out a
course of conduct designed to keep from
the jones court the true nature of his
relationship with monica lewinsky
once he knew he'd have to testify
he knew he was going to align his
deposition and he knew that he was going
to have to
lie and not only himself but get monica
lewinsky to live he was going to be
successful and he was going to have to
get his personal secretary to lie about
that relationship and he was going to
have to have his aides and others help
him cover this up
if he was going to be successful in
lying in the jones court deposition
he did all these things
and then he chose
to lie to the grand jury again
because if he had not
he would have not been able to protect
protect himself from the crimes he'd
already committed
no amount of arguing by white house
counsel can erase one simple fact
if you believe monica lewinsky you
cannot believe the president
if you believe monica lewinsky
the president committed most of the
crimes with which he's charged in these
articles today for example
while the president did not directly
tell her to lie and never advised her
what to put in her affidavit
she knew from the december 17 telephone
conversation
with the president that he meant for her
to lie about the relationship and file a
false affidavit and that he lie as well
and i want to refresh your recollection
these charts we put up some time before
more complete form you have them in
front of you but this is a direct quote
from her we showed this on television
saturday where she was reading from her
grand jury deposition and confirming
this is indeed what she said and what
she her interpretation of that affidavit
phone conversation in essence meant
despite everything else that you've
heard
she said for me the best way to explain
how i feel
uh what happened was you know no one
asked me or encouraged me to lie but no
one discouraged me either
it wasn't as if the president called me
and said you know monica you're on the
witness list this is going to be really
hard for us we're going to have to tell
the truth and be humiliated in front of
the entire world about what we've done
which i would have fought him on
probably that was different
and by him not calling me and saying
that you know i knew what that meant
i knew what that meant
she lied in that affidavit
the president clearly
intended to influence her by suggesting
the affidavit and all of the other
things that went on in that conversation
and all of the circumstances that were
there monaco whitnessy was equally clear
in her testimony to you saturday
that betty curry called her about the
gifts
not the other way around
and surely nobody believes that betty
curry would have called monica lewinsky
about the gifts on december 28th unless
the president had asked her to do so
and then the day after the president's
deposition in the jones case the
president clearly committed the crimes
of witness tampering and obstruction of
justice when in logical anticipation of
betty curry being called as a witness he
said to betty curry you were always
there when she was there right
we were never really alone
you could see and hear everything
monica came on to me and i never touched
her right she wanted to have sex with me
and i can't do that
now i'm not going to rehash
all of the evidence in this case again
but it is my understanding that some of
you may be prepared to vote to convict
the president on obstruction of justice
and not on
perjury i don't know how you can do that
i honestly do not know how anybody could
do that
if you believe sidney blumenthal's
testimony that the president told him
that monica lewinsky came at him and
made a sexual demand and that he
rebuffed her and that she threatened him
and said she would tell people they had
had an affair and that she was known as
a stalker among her peers surely you
must conclude
that the president committed perjury
when he told the grand jury
that he told his aides including
blumenthal
nothing but the truth even if it was
misleading the exact quotes from the
president's grand jury testimony people
are worried about what are the exact
quotes what are the words i want to give
you the words
and so i said to them things that were
true about this relationship so i said
things that were true they may have been
misleading so what i was trying to do
was to give them something they could
that that would be true even if
misleading that was even played on
television in the white house
presentation a few minutes ago
that was perjury
what he told sidney blumenthal
was not
true
it wasn't just misleading it was not
true and he knew it was not true and it
was perjury in front of the grand jury
if you believe the president committed
the crimes of witness tampering and
obstruction of justice when he called
betty curry into his office the day
after his deposition and told her you
were always there when when she was
right the ones i just read to you and
the other statements to coach her surely
you must also conclude that the
president committed perjury before the
grand jury when he told the grand jurors
his purpose in making these statements
he said and this is what he said these
are his exact words to the grand jurors
i was trying to figure out what the
facts were i was trying to remember i
was trying to remember every time i'd
seen ms lewinsky
that is not true he knew that was not
true that is not what he was doing no
one rationally can reason that that is
what he was trying to do when he made
the coaching statements to ms curry that
was perjury in front of the grand jury
and then we've heard a lot of talk about
the civil deposition nobody's trying to
prove up that deposition or is lying in
here today nobody's trying to use that
as a duplication or anything else of the
sort but the president said before the
grand jurors
quote my goal he's talking now about the
jones case deposition my goal in this
deposition was to be truthful
that's the lie that's the perjury
that is as simple as the second count of
the perjury article is does anybody
believe after hearing all of this that
the goal of the president and the jones
deposition was to be truthful he lied to
the grand jury and he committed perjury
and last but not least if you believe
monica lewinsky about the acts of a
sexual nature that they engaged in how
can you conclude the president
committed perjury when he specifically
denied how can you not conclude that he
committed perjury when he denied those
acts those were very explicit mr ruff
appears suggested this was a subjective
question maybe about the interpretation
of the definition you might call it
subjective but he used and we're not
going to go over all that again with you
today but i want to remind you he used
specific words that he confirmed were in
that definition and said i did not do
those things i did not touch those parts
monica lewinsky if you believe her
testified that he did do those things
many times
he committed perjury when he said he
didn't do those things if you believe
monica lewinsky
if you're going to vote to convict the
president on the articles of impeachment
regarding obstruction of justice i urge
you in the strongest way
to also vote to convict him
on the perjury article as well
i think you're doing a disservice not to
do that and sending a terrible message
about perjury and the seriousness of it
for history and to the american people
if you don't
as you've seen this federal sentencing
guidelines mr ruff talked about those up
here a while ago perjury and obstruction
of justice do have
under the baseline guidelines a higher
amount of sentencing than simple plain
vanilla bribery does that's where they
start
and yes he's right you can get
enhancements for aggravating
circumstances for bribery in certain
cases and you get a greater sentence but
so can you get a greater sentence for
perjury
if there was any significant effort to
wrongfully influence the administration
of justice as one for example then you
can get a significantly enhanced
sentence for perjury if you committed
perjury and so on we didn't choose to
bring up a litany of those lists and
show all the enhancements that you could
get but of course you could do that but
for the pure base there is no question
about it and the other significant thing
if you recall i brought up and some of
us did a couple of weeks ago now
witness bribery bribing a witness is
treated more severely under the
sentencing guidelines for base
sentencing than ordinary bribery is
all three are high crimes and
misdemeanors
now what are the consequences of failing
to remove this president from office if
you believe he's committed the crimes of
perjury and obstruction of justice
what are the consequences of failing to
do that what's the downside
first at the very least
you will leave a precedent of doubt
as to whether perjury and obstruction of
justice are high crimes and misdemeanors
when impeaching the president
in fact your vote to acquit under these
circumstances may well mean that no
president of the future will ever be
impeached or removed for perjury
obstruction of justice
is that the record that you want
second you will be establishing the
precedent that the standard for
impeachment and removal of a president
is different
of that for impeaching or removing a
judge or any other official
while arguably although it's never
happened a federal judge could be
removed for
a lesser standard under the good
behavior clause of the constitution such
removal would have to be by a separate
tribunal have to be by procedure set by
statute because
under the impeachment provisions of the
constitution
which all judges have been removed under
previously
the same single standard exists for
removing the president as for removing a
judge
that standard is that you have to have
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors so while the constitution
on its face
does not make a distinction for removing
a president or removing a judge
if you vote to acquit
believing that the president committed
perjury and obstruction of justice for
all time you're going to set a precedent
that there is such a distinction
third if you believe the president
committed the crimes of perjury and
obstruction of justice and that they're
high crimes and misdemeanors but you do
not believe a president should be
removed when economic times are good and
it's strongly against the popular will
to do so by voting to acquit you'll be
setting a precedent
for future impeachment trials
can you imagine how damaging that could
be to our constitutional form of
government to set the precedent that no
president will be removed from office
for high crimes and misdemeanors unless
the polls show that the public wants
that to happen
would our founding fathers have ever
envisioned that of course not
our constitution was structured
to avoid this very situation fourth
then there is what happens to the rule
of law
if you vote to equip
what damage is done for future
generations by a vote to acquit will
more witnesses be inclined to commit
perjury and trials will more jurors
decide that perjury and obstruction of
justice
should not be crimes for which they
convict
no military officer
no cabinet official no judge no ceo of a
major corporation no president of
university
no
principal of a public school in this
nation
would remain in office no matter how
popular they were if they'd committed
the crimes of perjury and obstructive
justices charged here
to vote to equip puts the president on a
pedestal that says as long as he's
popular
we're going to treat him differently
with regard to keeping his job than any
other person in any other position of
public trust in the united states of
america the president is the
commander-in-chief
he is the chief law enforcement officer
he is the man who appoints the cabinet
he appoints the judges are you going to
put on the record books the precedent
that all who serve under the president
and whom he's appointed will be held to
a higher standard than the president
what legacy to history is this
by voting to acquit the president what
mischief have you wrought to our
constitution to our system of government
to the values and principles to be
cherished by future generations of
americans all william jefferson clinton
all because i guess is the argument that
william jefferson clinton was elected
and is popular with the people all this
when it is clear that a vote to convict
would amount to nothing more than the
peaceful orderly and immediate
transition of government of the
presidency to the vice president
william jefferson clinton is not a king
he is our president
you have the power
and the duty to remove him for office
for high crimes and misdemeanors
i implore you
to muster the courage
of your convictions
to muster the courage the founding
fathers believed that the senate would
always have in times like these
william jefferson clinton has committed
high crimes and misdemeanors
convict him
and remove him
i yield
to mr kennedy
the chair recognizes mr manager kennedy
thank you mr chief justice
members of the senate
during the next few minutes i would like
to address the constitutional issue you
are called on to decide
in this case
are the crimes charged against the
president offenses for which he may be
removed from office
are these crimes high crimes and
misdemeanors are these crimes which
proceed as alexander hamilton said from
the abuse or violation of some public
trust
the president's lawyers have argued
vigorously that even if all the charges
against the president are true the
constitution forbids the removal of this
president
they contend that this isn't even a
close case that the crimes charged
against the president are far removed
from the constitutional category of high
crimes and misdemeanors a category of
offenses they have sought to restrict
narrowly
to misconduct causing ruinous harm to
the system of government
while the president's lawyers have been
consistent in urging a narrow and
restricted understanding of the
impeachment and removal power they have
not been and i repeat they have not been
consistent in describing the standard
used to determine if high crimes and
misdemeanors have been committed
in their submission to the house of
representatives they stated
unequivocally
the constitution requires proof of
official misconduct for impeachment
those are their words and i quote them
again the constitution requires proof of
official misconduct for impeachment
indeed that statement was the primary
heading for their whole argument on
constitutional standards and likewise in
their trial memorandum submitted to the
senate they argue that impeachment
should not be used to punish private
misconduct
subsequently they have apparently
abandoned this position
recognizing that it would lead to the
absurd result of maintaining an office
presidents who were undoubtedly unfit to
serve
they now begrudgingly concede that a
president is not necessarily immune from
impeachment and removal simply because
his crimes do not involve
the abuse of the powers of his office
they have been driven to concede that
there are at least some circumstances in
which a president may be removed for
crimes not involving what they call
official misconduct but of course they
contend that the circumstances in this
case don't even justify consideration of
removal
in the proceedings in the house and in
their trial memorandum submitted to the
senate the president's lawyers made much
of the argument that tax fraud
by a president of the united states
would not be sufficiently serious to
justify impeachment and removal i have
mentioned this before
in these proceedings and i mention it
again now because it vividly
demonstrates
the low standard of integrity
the pathetically
low standard of integrity
that would be established for the
presidency if the arguments of the
president's lawyers are accepted by the
senate
now perhaps i missed something but i
don't recall any mention of the tax
fraud issue by the president's lawyers
in the course of their various
presentations to the senate
could it be that the president's lawyers
have come to understand that the
argument that tax fraud is not an
impeachable offense does not strengthen
their case
but on the contrary highlights the
weakness
of their case
tax fraud by a president like lying
under oath and obstruction of justice by
a president
in this case would of course be wrong
it would be shameful indefensible
unforgivable
but
this is the big but
it would not be impeachable they say
not even a close case
bad yes
but clearly not impeachable and why is
that
why would it not be impeachable
why is it clearly unquestionably
unimpeachable
this is the answer
this is the heart and soul of the
president's defense
tax fraud and a host
of undefined other crimes like the lying
under oath and obstruction of justice in
this case are just not serious enough
for impeachment and removal
that's the answer that's the defense
it's just not serious enough
all the grand legal arguments all the
fine legal distinctions come down to
this simple this marvelously simple
proposition
it's just not serious enough
let me refer you once again to a
statement
from the 1974 report on the
constitutional grounds for presidential
impeachment prepared by the staff of the
nixon impeachment inquiry i want to cite
a portion of that report
that i have previously cited to you
the president's lawyers have also cited
this very same statement in both their
trial memorandum and their argument
during these proceedings now this is
what the report says
because impeachment of a president is a
grave step for the nation
it is to be predicated only upon conduct
seriously incompatible with
either the constitutional form and
principles of our government or
the proper performance of constitutional
duties of the presidential office
for our purposes now impeachment is to
be predicated only upon conduct
seriously incompatible with the proper
performance of constitutional duties of
the presidential office
that's the standard the managers accept
that's the standard the president's
lawyers apparently also accept and
that's a standard i would hope all 100
members of the united states senate
could accept
i believe we can reach agreement on this
standard the problem comes of course in
applying the standard there's the rub
a wide gulf separates us on how this
standard should be applied
the president's lawyers say that under
this standard the case against the
president isn't even worth considering
the managers argue on the contrary that
a conscientious application of the
standard leads to the firm conclusion
that the president should be
convicted and removed now our
fundamental difference goes to the issue
of seriousness it all goes back to the
claim of the president's lawyers that
his offenses just are not serious enough
to justify removal
i think we have agreement that
obstruction of justice and lying under
oath are incompatible with the proper
performance of constitutional duties of
the presidential office
a president who has lied under oath and
obstructed justice has by definition
reached his constitutional duty to take
care that the laws be faithfully
executed
such conduct is directly and
unambiguously
at odds with the duties of his office
now so far so good but here's the real
question
is that conduct seriously incompatible
with the president's constitutional duty
that's the question you all must answer
if you say yes
it is seriously incompatible you must
vote to convict and remove the president
if you say no
you must vote
to acquit
the president's defenders have not
offered a clear guide to determining
what is serious enough
to justify removal instead they have
simply sought to minimize the
significance of the particular offenses
charged against the president
today we heard an attempt to minimize
the significance of perjury i was
somewhat amazed to hear that
there was no mention made of what the
first chief justice of the united states
justice j had to say about perjury being
of all crimes the most pernicious to
society that was omitted from the
president's
analysis
but let me say this
i believe
that we should focus on any mitigating
circumstances
we should also focus on the aggravating
circumstances that relate to the
particular facts of a given case
now i'd like to briefly review the
factors advanced as mitigating the
seriousness of the president's crimes
we all know what the leading mitigating
factor is we've all heard this a
thousand times it goes like this
the offenses are not sufficiently
serious because it's all about sex
now this is directly linked to the claim
that the president was simply trying to
avoid personal embarrassment in
committing these crimes
the problem with this argument is that
it proves too much
it's very common for people who lie
under oath and obstruct justice to do so
at least in part to avoid personal
embarrassment
people engage in such conduct in their
efforts to extricate themselves from
difficult and embarrassing situations
to a large extent the offenses of
president nixon could be attributed to
his desire to avoid embarrassing
revelations
did that reduce his culpability did that
lessen the seriousness of his misconduct
the answer is obvious it did not
the desire to avoid embarrassment is not
a mitigating factor likewise the nature
of the precipitating misconduct a sexual
affair
does not mitigate the seriousness of the
president's crimes if you accept the
argument that it's just about sex
you will render the law of sexual
harassment virtually meaningless
any defendant guilty of sexual
harassment would obviously have an
incentive to lie about any sexual
misconduct that may have occurred
but no one no one has a license to lie
under oath about sex in a sexual
harassment case or in a divorce case or
in any other case
i would suggest to you that in an
objective review of all the
circumstances of this case and you need
to look at all of the circumstances
all of the facts and context
if you do that
you will be pointed not to mitigating
factors but to aggravating factors
the conduct of the president was
calculated and sustained
he said
his settled and determined purpose
was corrupt
it was corrupt from start to finish
he knew exactly what he was doing he
knew that it was in violation of the
criminal law he knew that people could
go to prison for doing such things
he knew that it was contrary to his oath
of office he knew that it was
incompatible with his constitutional
duty as president and he most certainly
knew that it was a very serious matter
i'm sure he believed he could get away
with it
but i'm equally sure that he knew just
how serious it would be if the truth
were known and understood
he knew all these things in the midst of
it all he showed not the slightest
concern for the honor the dignity and
the integrity of his high office
when he called miss lewinsky at 2 30 in
the morning he was up to no good just as
my colleague mr graham noted he knew
exactly what he was doing when he called
miss curry in his office twice and told
her lies about his relationship with
miss lewinsky he knew exactly what he
was doing when he sent miss curry to
retrieve the gifts from ms lewinsky and
that's the only way it happened
he knew exactly what he was doing he was
tampering with witnesses and obstructing
justice he was doing everything he could
to make sure that paul jones did not get
the evidence that a federal district
judge had determined and ordered that
she was entitled to receive
he was doing everything he could to
avoid adverse legal consequences in the
jones case
that's what he planned to do and that's
what he did
and to cap it all off
he went before the federal grand jury
and lied
whatever you may think about the
president's testimony to the grand jury
one thing is clear he didn't lie to the
grand jury to avoid personal
embarrassment
the dna on the dress had ensured his
personal embarrassment there was no
avoiding that
there was no way to explain away the dna
the stakes were higher before the
federal grand jury
this wasn't about avoiding personal
embarrassment this wasn't about avoiding
liability in a sexual harassment case
this was a federal criminal
investigation concerning crimes against
the system of justice
this was about lying under oath and
obstructing justice in the jones case
and what did he do when he testified to
the grand jury
he said anything he thought he needed to
say to avoid responsibility for his
prior crimes
the prosecutors went down to the white
house and william jefferson clinton sat
there as president of the united states
in the white house and he lied
to a federal grand jury
he sat there in the white house and he
put on his most sincere face he swore to
god
to tell the truth
and then he lied
he planned to lie and he executed his
plan because he believed it was in his
personal and political interest to lie
never mind the oath of office never mind
the constitutional duty never mind that
he solemnly swore to god to tell the
truth
now ask yourself this simple question
was this course of conduct seriously
incompatible
with the president's duty
as president
if this doesn't fall within the meaning
of the offenses alexander hamilton
described as proceeding from the abuse
or violation of some public trust tell
me what would
i would respectfully suggest to you that
this is exactly the sort of conduct that
the framers had in mind when they
provided a remedy
for the removal of a chief executive who
is guilty of misconduct
i believe that they would have rejected
the argument
that this deliberate willful stubbornly
corrupt course of criminal conduct just
isn't serious enough
for the constitutional remedies the
framers established a remedy that they
designed to protect the health and
integrity of our institutions
those who establish our constitution
would have understood the seriousness of
the misconduct of william jefferson
clinton they would have understood that
it was the president who has shown
contempt for the constitution not
the managers from the house of
representatives they would have
understood the seriousness of the
example of lawlessness he has set
they would have understood the
seriousness of the contempt for the law
the president's conduct has caused they
would have understood the seriousness of
the damage the president has done to the
integrity of his high office
those wise statesmen who established our
form of government would have understood
the seriousness of the harm president
clinton has done to the cause of justice
and constitutional government
they would have understood that a
president who does such things
should not remain in office with his
crimes ladies and gentlemen of the
senate for the sake of justice and for
the sake of the constitution this
president should be convicted and
removed
the chair recognizes mr manager bryant
thank you mr chief justice members of
the senate
distinguished
colleagues i want to
distinguish colleagues at the bar
representing the
president i want to commend
them for an outstanding effort that they
have made throughout these proceedings
and
tell them that i just read a poll and
it's
from a couple of days ago that
something over 80 percent of the
american people believe
that the president is guilty of
something here
so i think that moves our entire debate
i don't think there's any need to even
talk about the facts any longer because
of the poll
i use that
tongue-in-cheek because that seems to
beg the question that we're also going
to talk about today and that is whether
the president ought to be removed for
this conduct and one of the arguments
i've heard put forward and since we've
been here was the fact that the polls
support this president and
that the stability issue would be
being played and that's that's simply
not the case because we all clearly
understand that it's this body's
function to determine not only the facts
of this case but also apply to it the
law as well as the constitutional law as
to the removal
and conviction process
i still remain concerned
with
opposing council's continued reference
that the house managers want to win too
much i i know i'm not that eloquent but
i did try to make that point the other
day
and i will make it again if i have to
take an oath to tell the truth the whole
truth enough but the truth i'll do that
and tell you that we're not trying to
win at all cost
this has been a process i think has been
healthy for this country and regardless
of the outcome regardless it's going to
be in your hands very shortly regardless
of the outcome this country i think will
benefit not only in the short term but
in the long term for this debate
and there are many many other issues at
stake here and i tried to tell you a few
the other day without
this concept that all we want to do is
win as if it's a simple game
we have been over the last four weeks as
men and women
involved as ordinary men and women i
might say involved in an extraordinary
process
it's uniquely thorough
and and we have tried to blend
the facts of this case with the
the law of the charges
together with the the uh the politics
and the polls and the the media
and we tried we've had to make some
tough decisions we've had to make some
difficult decisions i know on our side
we have as to what witnesses to call
how to treat these witnesses in
depositions i know on on this side
they've had to make difficult calls i'm
sure there's been some talk about having
the president come down and not coming
down
and what has in large part made this
process distinct from past impeachments
and i'm talking about the one last
century
of the president and the subsequent
judicial impeachments has been
just the
it seems the the media and the daily
grind on all of us
the critiques it's almost like we're
performing we're in a play and every day
we get a review we've been good or bad
or indifferent
and what concerns me most about that is
that i as as you move to the very
serious issue of deciding whether or not
this president should be convicted based
on the facts and whether that president
should be removed i'm concerned that
that people
are stressing the trees
and if that's what you see on tv and
what you read in the paper you're going
to see the trees and not the forest here
and miss the big picture because that's
so important it's not about the
personalities of these people or the
personalities here or the politics
involved or the polls
but it's about the facts and and ladies
and gentlemen the senate there are
conclusive facts here
that support a conviction
the president
and his attorneys as i said the other
day have made a good defense and have
tried to to
put a paint a picture to the facts i
think that
that simply do not match with logic
or common sense
take for instance the affidavit now we
continue to see ms lewinsky testifying
on video that she never talked with the
president that night and never made the
about
linking
the
false story the concocted story with the
affidavit
and mr ruff i think challenged people to
say what do you think the president
meant to do that night when he called
her at 2 30 in the morning
well what do you think he intended to
call doing that call at 2 30 in the
morning do you think he called her to
tell her he had a christmas present for
her
or do you think his intent was to tell
her which he did
that
you've been listed on the witness list
and you could be subpoenaed
and you know you might give an affidavit
to avoid testifying
he suggested the
affidavit and then he said in that same
conversation
well you know you can always use that
cover story why would he suggest using
the cover story that night
were they even seen each other then
it it it belittles all
reasonable judgment to accept this type
of defense of this conduct that it was
an innocent phone conversation the
president really meant nothing by it and
the fact that miss lewinsky said well i
didn't connect the
but look at what she did she went to her
lawyer and used that concocted story in
a affidavit that she filed in the case
now
it was in the draft affidavit they took
that out later for other reasons but she
did tell her lawyer that and they
attempted to use it but again it's the
president's state of mind that matters
and was it what his intent was on the
false affidavit
and then that same false affidavit was
later used in the court
and the president knew it was false he
knew it was false it was used in the
deposition
and
we've seen the deposition testimony with
the president sitting there listening to
his lawyer talk about that affidavit
when he submitted it
and he obstructed justice by not
objecting at that point not instructing
his own lawyer don't put that false
evidence into this testimony
and and people stand up to laugh and say
well you know he was he was not paying
any attention and they got this silly
affidavit from this guy that was there
and said he looked he was looking at his
lawyer but he couldn't tell what he was
thinking of course he couldn't tell what
he was thinking
nobody's mind readers but this was a
critical affidavit at that time which
was going to cut off critical testimony
in that case and you can this just about
guarantee i'd say 100 percent that the
president was indeed listening very
carefully knew that his lawyer was
submitting a false affidavit and did
nothing to stop it that's another count
of obstruction of justice
tampering with betty curry two occasions
and they say well nothing happened
between the first time and the second
time i'm not so sure legally that
matters it was two or three days that
happened
on the day following his deposition and
two or three days after that
and initially remember his defense was i
was simply trying to recall what
happened and then we brought up the fact
well why did you go a second time did
you have a short memory didn't you get
it right the first time and now we hear
the defense today that well
gee nothing really changed and so it's
all kind of one one issue there one one
big one big tampering rather than two
attempts to tamper
still obstruction of justice
the job situation mr hutchinson will
talk about later mr blumenthal
same thing i'm sure mr rogan will
testify or talk about in a minute
but if you'll look carefully you'll see
that the president is the only thread
that goes from each one of these from
the very beginning from the point when
he met monica lewinsky from that point
when he looked at that pink pass and
said you know that's going to be a
problem and you know why that was going
to be a problem because that limited her
access to this president and what he was
going to do
but from that point till they terminated
the relationship
this president is involved in each one
of these issues of the obstruction of
justice it's always him by himself
testifying falsely sitting there letting
his lawyer submit a false affidavit or
it's him and one other person he and
monica lewinsky talking about filing a
false affidavit he and monica lewinsky
talked about a concocted story to
testify he and betty curry on two
occasions about well betty you remember
the testimony was like this
he and john podesta cindy blumenthal the
the many aides talking to them
individually giving them a false story
and as mr hutchison so well pointed out
in his argument the other day it's
always
a private issue in terms of no one else
knows what's going on vernon jordan
didn't know what was happening with the
affidavit necessarily betty curry didn't
understand what was happening with the
affidavit or the job search to the point
that they knew what was going on look at
look at and analyze each one of these
and you'll see that there's a car
compartmentalization going on with this
president
and he's at the center of it each time
now
what do we do with it what do you do
with it
it's it's going to be in your hands very
shortly and and i want to address just a
couple of points on the constitutional
issue of the conviction and the removal
because white house counsel very
very well argued the issue of
proportionality
and again proportionality simply means
that
the legacy of this senate and this
congress will be that we have destroyed
sexual harassment laws
because what we're going to say when you
argue that proportionality think about
what it is we've heard this issue about
well back in my hometown 80 of the
people that get divorces lie about this
issue well certainly that does not want
to be the legacy of this congress that
we legitimize lying in divorce cases nor
would it we want to have the legacy of
this congress being that we
did not support the sexual harassment
laws because you know and i know that
that this is an important part going on
back and getting accurate truthful
testimony is absolutely essential in
these types of cases and if we send the
message out on the proportionality
theory that it's just about sex and you
can lie about it it will be the wrong
thing to do
the law like the facts
are a very stubborn thing
and the fact that the economy is good
and and and people are doing well
if the law has been broken
if perjury has been committed if
obstruction of justice has been
committed by this president
it is my belief that the fact that the
economy is good should not prevent this
senate from acting and removing the
president just as
if the economy were bad
you wouldn't want to be able to go in
there and impeach the president because
it's bad you don't want to not impeach
him because simply simply because the
economy is good
it is a difficult task we've had a
difficult task bringing this case over
to you and i thank you you have been
here
the four weeks in attendance you've paid
attention
when it was your turn to ask questions
you asked very good questions you've
been
uh ready to listen
and and and i thank you for that uh
you've got a difficult task ahead of you
i know when i voted on this i thought
you know if this were a republican
president what would i do
it's a tough choice and i said but you
know i really think i would have voted
the same way i voted even if it were a
republican president i know like mr
shabbat i voted for mr carter in 1976.
voted for mr reagan in 1980 you might
add but uh voted for mr carter 1976
after the 1974
incident
it is it is tough and and what has made
it awfully hard is y'all have also taken
an oath to do impartial justice
and i simply ask you as you consider
these and do impartial justice
that you set a standard
that if you believe the president indeed
did
commit either perjury or obstruction of
justice or both of those that you set
that standard high
for the president for the next president
for the next generations you set that
standard high for our courts
that have to deal with perjury and
obstruction every day with people who
are less than the president but yet who
are watching who are watching very
closely what we do up here
but set that standard high for the
president don't lower our
expectation and what we expect out of
the president
and i think if if you do that if you
look high if you set the standard high
that the right thing will be done i i
have confidence and have trust and have
just been so pleased with
with the way
we've been received here i know you will
do the right thing
i apologize to you as i will be talking
to you probably for my last time if if
i've come across as being up here
preaching to you it's not my intent to
lecture you
you do not need any lectures from me or
anyone else to preach to you i hope i've
had that opportunity to rebut
some of the uh the area the proof in the
area that i'm in charge of
but i i would just simply sit down by
telling you that there is conclusive
proof here particularly in the in terms
of the obstruction of justice charges of
the hiding of the evidence of the filing
of the false affidavit i might i think i
did skip over the hiding of the evidence
let me just quickly say
and
i'm not sure a lot in you can be added
from what we said in the past but
it it
if
if the monica is telling the truth as as
her lawyers are as the president's
lawyers seem to tell you that's that's a
that's a no no-brainer there because she
says i know for a fact that
that uh miss curry called me that she
initiated the call and as i told you the
other day from that point forward it
seems to me a moot issue because the
initiate initiation of the phone call by
betty curry began a process
to
hide that evidence and the only way that
betty curry would have known to make
that call to begin that process of
hiding evidence
would be to have a telephone call a
conversation with the president to be
instructed that way
the president whose intent was to
conceal the relationship but it would
have been totally inconsistent for her
for him to have suggested that she
turned the evidence over it would have
been totally consistent for him
to ask betty curry to go out and hide
the evidence get it from miss uh
lewinsky and hide the evidence
and as i close let me just tell you too
on the heels of mr kennedy
that there there are law professors who
testified
in our hearing
who have the contrary view to what
the view that was expressed by other law
professors that mr ruff referred to
that you you can it is constitutional to
impeach a president
for
conduct that's not clearly official
that's
that's uh might be described as as
personal
and particularly conduct of perjury or
impeachment or obstruction of justice
professor turley says in my view serious
crimes in office such as lying under
oath before a federal grand jury have
always been milemon say conduct for
which a president
for a president and a sufficient grounds
for impeachment
uh professor john mcginnis of
benjamin cardoza law school says that uh
obstruction of justice is clearly within
the ambit of
high crimes and misdemeanors so if
there's any question on this private
conduct versus personal conduct that
view is out there that given the right
type of personal conduct or misconduct i
should say it's clearly an impeachable
offense and with that i would call mr
manager hutchinson
to follow
the chair recognizes mr manager
hutchinson
thank you mr chief justice
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen of the senate
when i was appointed as a manager i hope
to present the case before the senate
with my colleagues in a manner that was
consistent with the dignity of this
great body and also respectful of the
constitutional independence of the
senate i hope that you agree and believe
that we have done that as we have come
over here
during the months of this trial process
i have grown to appreciate the
institution of the senate to a greater
degree than ever before but i think of
even more importance to me
i've grown to respect the individuals
that comprise this body more than ever
and let me say it has been a privilege
to appear
before you
as we come to the closing of this case
let's go to the key questions
that should be on your mind first of all
has the obstruction of justice and
perjury cases been proven
have the allegations been proven
my colleagues have touched upon the
perjury let me talk about article 2 on
the obstruction of justice
the white house defense team
composed of extraordinarily
distinguished and talented attorneys has
tried to diminish the significance of
the overwhelming facts on obstruction by
using certain phrases such as
it's all circumstantial
or
the managers ignore those stubborn facts
or they want to win too badly
or it's a shell game with no shell
and today the latest catchphrase
moving targets
empty pots well those are certainly
quotable phrases
designed to diminish the factual
presentation with dripping sarcasm
but i believe that they ignore
the underlying facts testimony and
evidence that has been presented
and let me just address a couple of
arguments that mr ruff has presented
during his presentation
the first argument that he presented as
he described it was a technical argument
that the
article 2 obstruction of justice charge
the article's impeachment on the line to
the aids
was not really in reference to the
federal civil rights case
and that is a true statement but if you
read
article two paragraph seven it refers to
this and says the false and misleading
statements made by william jefferson
clinton were repeated by the witnesses
to the grand jury
causing the grand jury to receive false
and misleading information the article
is appropriately drafted is well stated
and gives them total notice as to what
that charge is about
some of the other arguments have been
handled by my colleagues but mr ruff
also said why have the managers never
never explained if this was such an
urgent matter for the president
why did he wait until december 17th to
tell miss lewinsky that she was on the
list i'm afraid mr ruff failed to listen
to my opening presentation when i went
through that time frame
and in that time frame the witness list
came out on december 5th
it continued to accelerate december 11th
with it was judge wright's order
and then
it was december 17th that the call was
made at 2 a.m in the morning to let miss
lewinsky know she was on the list why
was it december 17th this is in the
president's mind no one knows why he
picked that particular date but perhaps
it was that the job search was well
underway then
he felt like she could handle this
distressing information and in fact on
the day after that call she already had
two
interviews lined up on that same day
december 18th set up by mr jordan and so
perhaps it was an appropriate time to
let her know she was on the witness list
they raised the question about the
christmas gifts that you have the
testimony of betty curry you have the
testimony of miss lewinsky and the issue
is simply do you believe monica lewinsky
if you accept her reluctant
testimony yet forceful and clear
testimony that the call came from betty
curry then you have no choice but to
conclude
that the
retention of the gifts the retrieval of
the gifts was initiated by the president
of the united states
when you go to the job search
and they point to the testimony they
played the video of mr jordan
who said that there was never a
conversation in which both the
job and the false affidavit were
discussed together
and they cut it off at that point and
you remember i had a butt in there
well if you would have heard further
beyond that you have heard me
cross-examining mr jordan as i did and
reminding him of his previous testimony
in which he acknowledged that in every
conversation with miss lewinsky
they talked about the job and so he
acknowledged that they talked about the
job and the affidavit all in the same
conversation together
mr ruff makes the point
that the managers
that the managers got close enough to
accuse mr jordan of telling miss
lewinsky to destroy the notes
implying that we're making up this
but is this evidence that is coming from
the managers it's my recollection that
is testimony that is coming from miss
monica lewinsky
we're not concocting this it is
testimony from witnesses that have been
brought before this body whose sworn
testimony you've received whose sworn
testimony they defend and rely upon but
when it comes to this they say no it's
the managers
well
then they come to another pillar of
obstruction the one that they avoided
every opportunity but finally addressed
today and that's the coaching of betty
curry and i was interested that they
finally talked about this the first
coaching incident and then the second
one and mr ruff tried to go into that
it's clear that it occurred on january
20th rather than 21st in fact that is
her testimony that occurred in one of
those days but they missed the point the
legal significance of the second
coaching
episode is that it totally goes against
the defense of the president that it was
there he was doing this to acquire
information to get facts to help in
media inquiries well if that is the case
there's absolutely no reason for it to
be done on the second occasion and
clearly she was known to be a witness at
that time and that is the legal
significance it goes to his intent his
motive what he is trying to do to a
subordinate employee
the fact of this matter is that this is
not a case that is based upon
circumstantial evidence on each element
of obstruction there is direct testimony
linking the president to a consistent
pattern of conduct designed to withhold
information conceal evidence and tamper
with witnesses to avoid obedience and
directives of a federal court
let's look at the direct proof not
circumstantial evidence but direct
testimony what did vernon jordan testify
as to the president's involvement the
job search
question to mr jordan you're acting
behalf of the president when you're
trying to get miss lewinsky a job and
you were in control of the job search
his answer
yes
acting at the direction of the president
and he was in control
what did vernon jordan testify he told
the president when a job was secured for
a key witness and the false affidavit
was signed mr president
she signed the affidavit she signed the
affidavit
and then the next day the job is secured
and the report to medicare the report to
the president mission accomplished is
this circumstantial evidence this is
direct testimony by a friend and
confident of the president vernon jordan
who is the one person who clearly knew
all of the ingredients to make the job
search and obstruction of justice it was
the president that knew he had a
dangerous relationship with miss
lewinsky he knew his friend was securing
a job at his direction and he knew a
false affidavit was being procured at
his suggestion he was the one person
that knew all the facts
fourthly miss lewinsky is this
circumstantial evidence or direct
testimony when she talked about what the
president told her on december 17th she
was a witness and immediately following
the fact that she was a witness the
suggestion that she could
use the cover stories the suggestion
that she could use an affidavit
direct testimony was there direct proof
about presidents tampering with the
testimony of betty curry it was betty
curry herself who acknowledged this and
testified to it no this is not
circumstantial evidence it is direct
testimony the same with sydney
blumenthal direct testimony after direct
testimony painting a picture
setting up the pillars of obstruction
now they want you to believe monica
lewinsky sometimes
but they don't want you to believe her
other times and you have to weigh her
testimony i could go on on the facts but
the truth is that our case on
obstruction of justice has been
established now some of you might
conclude that i will i accept five or
six or of those pillars of obstruction
but there's one i have a reservation
about well if you look at the article if
there's one element of obstruction that
you accept and believe and you agree
upon then that is sufficient for
conviction and surely it's sufficient to
convict the president if there was even
one element of obstruction
i would remind you that a typical jury
instruction on conspiracy for
obstruction would be that it only takes
one overt act to satisfy the
requirements for a conviction the
government does not have to prove all
the overt acts just one that was carried
out
another question some of you might be
thinking about is this serious enough to
warrant
conviction and removal
one of the foundations of our judicial
system is that any citizen regardless of
position or power has access to the
court can you imagine the shock and
outrage of this body if a corporation in
an effort to protect itself from
liability concealed evidence and
provided benefits to those witnesses who
are cooperative
outrage
injustice
and those are the allegations against
the tobacco companies those the
allegations last night on cbs 60 minutes
about a major corporation and there
should be outraged by this body but we
would rightfully be outraged about that
and we should also be outraged if it
happened by the president
it should be no less when it is
conducted by the president the next
argument is well yes the president
should be held accountable but he can
always be prosecuted later
in fact i understand a censure
resolution is being circulated
emphasizing that the president can be
held criminally responsible for his
actions when he leaves office
this is not too subtle of a suggestion
that the independent council go ahead
and file criminal charges against the
president i appreciate judge starr but i
do not believe that is what the country
has in mind when they say they want to
get this matter over
i do not believe your vote on the
articles of impeachment should be a
signal to the independent council to
initiate criminal proceedings it appears
to me that that is the implication of
the central resolution being discussed
i would emphasize that it is this body
that the founding fathers entrusted with
the responsibility to determine
whether a president's conduct has
breached the public trust and your
decision
in this body should conclude this matter
it should not be the initiation of
another national drama that will be
carried out over the next three years
and finally there are some who consider
the politics of this matter
we have proven our case
and i entered this body thinking that
this was a legal judicial proceeding and
not political and i have been reminded
that there are political aspects under
the constitution to a senate trial and
so i can see the point
we're all familiar with profiles and
courage written by john f kennedy
he reminds us of the courageous act of
senator edmund g ross
in voting for the acquittal of president
andrew johnson in his impeachment trial
senator ross was a profiling courage
because he knew the case against
president johnson was not legally
sufficient
even though the politically expedient
vote was to vote for conviction
senator ross followed the facts and he
followed the law and he voted his
conscience it was to his political
detriment but it reflected his political
courage today we have a different
circumstance the question is will the
senators of this body have the political
courage to follow the facts and the law
as did senator ross despite enormous
political pressure to ignore the facts
and the law and the constitution
you will make that decision
i've appeared i appear before this body
as an advocate i am not paid for this
special responsibility but i am here
because i believe the constitution
requires me to make this case the facts
prove overwhelmingly that the president
committed obstruction of justice and
perjury despite this belief
whatever conclusion you reach
will not be criticized by me
and i will respect this institution
regardless of the outcome
as the late federal judge orrin harris
of arkansas
always said from the bench to the jury
when i was trying cases
and i hated his instruction
because i was the prosecutor
but he would tell the jury
remember the government never wins or
loses a case the government always wins
when justice is done
well this is the congress and this is
the senate and it is your responsibility
to determine the facts and to let
justice roll down
like mighty waters
the chair recognized mr manager rogan
mr chief justice
distinguished counsel for the president
members of the united states senate
me the most poignant part of this entire
proceeding
was the day a few weeks ago when we were
addressed
by the distinguished former senator from
arkansas dale bumpers
and probably the thing that touched me
most about his presentation is when he
talked about the human element
of what this impeachment proceeding has
meant and how difficult
that has been
it touched me because it made me
remember that that difficulty is not
limited solely for democrats in this
chamber
i am one of the house managers i am a
republican today
but that was not always the case
i used to be a democrat
and being a house manager and the
impeachment of president clinton has
been especially difficult for me
and i'd like to tell you why
20 years ago in december 1978
i was finishing my last semester of
college and had just applied to law
school
i was waiting for my application to be
accepted someplace
and in december of 1978 i was a delegate
in memphis tennessee
to the democratic midterm convention
now on that time at that time president
carter was halfway through his term of
office he was not particularly popular
among the party faithful
there was a great deal of sentiment
that a member of this body today should
challenge him for the nomination that
decision had not yet been made but among
the delegates to that convention there
was an overwhelming desire to see
senator ted kennedy appear
the carter white house froze senator
kennedy out of the proceedings he was
not invited to address the convention
his name appeared nowhere in the program
so the delegates did something on their
own there were workshops being held
during the day and a workshop on health
care
was called and senator kennedy was
invited to fly out that day and address
that workshop
and he did that in the afternoon and he
left after he addressed it i had gone to
a workshop that morning where president
carter personally appeared and my
recollection is about two or three
hundred people came to that
senator kennedy's workshop had to be
transferred to a large auditorium
because about 2 000 people appeared to
hear him
the senator came he spoke and he left
i stayed even though most people left
with him because i was fascinated by the
young fellow
who was
moderating the program that day
he was bright
he was in control he was articulate he
didn't look that much older than me
and i was stunned that this young man
was not only the attorney general of his
state but he was the governor elect of
his state
sometime after that workshop i walked up
to him and introduced myself i told him
who i was and he spent about 15 minutes
encouraging me to go to law school to
stay active in politics his name was
bill clinton
i've never forgotten that day 20 years
ago
when then attorney general clinton took
the time for a young fellow who had an
interest in the law and politics
and i've never forgotten in recent days
the graciousness he has shown to me to
my wife and to my children when we have
encountered him
this has been a very difficult
proceeding for me and for my colleagues
the house managers
but our presence here isn't out of
personal animosity toward our president
it is because we believed that after
reviewing all the evidence the president
of the united states had committed
obstruction of justice and perjury he
had violated his oath of office and in
so doing he had sacrificed the principle
that no person is above the law
and friendship and personal affection
could not control
under those circumstances
up until now the idea that no person is
above the law has been unquestioned
and yet this standard is not our
inheritance automatically
each generation of americans
ultimately has to make that choice for
themselves
once again
it is a time for choosing
how will we respond
by impeaching the president
the united states house of
representatives made that choice
it went on record as saying that our
body would not tolerate the most
powerful man in the world
trampling the constitutional rights of a
lone woman no matter how obscure or
humble she might be
we refuse to ignore presidential
misconduct despite its minimization by
spin doctors pundits
and yes even the polls
the personal popularity of any president
pales when weighed against the
fundamental concept that forever
distinguishes us from every nation on
the planet no person is above the law
the house of representatives jettisoned
the spin and the propaganda
we sought
and we have now presented the
unvarnished truth
now it is your unhappy task to make the
final determination
face the truth and polish the
constitution or allow this presidency
in the words of chairman henry hyde
to take one more chip out of the marble
the constitution solemnly required
president clinton as a condition of his
becoming president to swear an oath to
preserve protect and defend the
constitution
and to take care that the laws be
faithfully executed
that oath of obligation required the
president to defend our laws that
protect women in the workplace just as
it also required him to protect the
legal system from perjury abuse of power
and obstruction of justice
fidelity to the presidential oath is not
dependent on any president's personal
threshold of comfort or embarrassment
neither must it be a slave to the latest
polling data
how important was this oath to our
founders
did they intend the oath to have primacy
over the shifting winds of political
opinion
or did they bequeath to us
ambiguous constitution
that was meant to roll with the punches
of the latest polling data and focus
groups the constitution gives us that
answer
in article 2 section 1 it says that
before he enters
on the execution of his office
he shall take an oath
and the oath is then prescribed
the mere fact that a person is elected
president does not give him the right to
become president no matter how
overwhelming his vote margin
votes alone do not make a person
president of the united states
there is a requirement that precedes
obtaining the power and authority of the
presidency
it is the oath of office it is swearing
to preserve protect and defend the
constitution it is accepting the
obligation that the laws are to be
faithfully executed
no oath
no presidency
it is the oath of office and not public
opinion polls that give life and
legitimacy to a presidency
this is true no matter how popular an
elected president may be
or how broad his margin of victory
the founders did not intend the oath to
be an afterthought or a technicality
they viewed it as an absolute
requirement before the highest office in
the land was entrusted to any person
the evidence shows the president
repeatedly violated his oath of office
now the focus shifts
to your oath of office
the president hopes that in this chamber
the polls will govern
on behalf of the house of
representatives we entreat you
to require that the constitution reign
supreme
for if polls matter more than the oath
to uphold the law
then yet another chip out of the marble
has been struck
the cry has also been raised that to
remove the president is to create a
constitutional crisis by undoing an
election
there is no constitutional crisis
when the simple process of the
constitution comes into play
listen to the words of dr larry yarn
from the claremont institute
he said elections have no higher
standing under our constitution than the
impeachment process
both stem from provisions of the
constitution
the people elect a president to do a
constitutional job
they act under the constitution when
they do it
at the same time they elect a congress
to do a different constitutional job
the president swears an oath to the
constitution
both in the elections and in the
impeachment process
if a president is guilty
of acts justifying impeachment then he
not the congress will have overturned
the election
he will have acted in ways that betray
the purpose of his election
he will have acted not as a
constitutional representative but as a
monarch
subversive of
or above the law
if the great powers given the president
are abused then to impeach him defends
not only the results of the election
but that higher thing which elections
are in service namely the preeminence of
the constitution
the evidence clearly shows
that the president engaged in repeated
and lengthy patterns of felonious
conduct
conduct for which ordinary citizens can
be and have
been jailed and lost their liberty
this simply cannot be wished or censured
away
with his conduct aggravated by a
motivation of personal and monetary
leverage in the paula jones lawsuit
the solemnity of our sacred oath
obliges us to do what the president
regrettably failed to do
defend the rule of law
defend the concept that no person
is above the law
on the day the house impeached president
clinton
i said that when they are old enough to
appreciate the solemnity
of that action
i wanted my little girls to know that
when the role was called
their father served with colleagues who
counted it a privilege to risk political
fortunes
in defense of the constitution
today i am more resolute in that opinion
from the time i was a little boy
it was my dream
to one day serve in the congress of the
united states
my dream was fulfilled two years ago
today i am a republican
in a district that is heavily democratic
the pundits keep telling me that my
stand on this issue puts my political
fortunes in jeopardy
so be it
that revelation produces from me
no flinching
there is a simple reason why
i know that in life dreams come
and dreams go
but conscience is forever
i can live with the concept
of not serving in congress i cannot live
with the idea of remaining in congress
at the expense of doing what i believe
to be right
i was about 12 years old when a
distinguished member of this body
the late senator ralph yarborough of
texas
gave me this sage advice about elective
office
he said always put principle above
politics
put honor
above incumbency
i now return that sentiment
to the body from which it came
hold fast to it senators
and in doing so
you will be faithful both to our
founders
and to our heirs
the chair recognizes mr manager graham
uh mr t how much time
the managers have 45 minutes remaining
shall i continue okay
i promise not to take the whole 45
minutes
i've been told that my voice fades and
i'll try to
try not to let that happen here
as we
bring the trial to conclusion i think it
needs to be said from our side of the
aisle
that our staff has been terrific
you don't know
how many hours of sleep has been lost by
the young men and women working to put
this case together under the procedures
that the senate developed they have done
an absolutely benefic magnificent
job
and if there's anybody to blame for
our side not being told
blame blame us
because our staff has done a terrific
job and that just needs to be said
now let's talk about mr rogan's district
truly
if there's anybody on our side that all
that's had a risk it's been jim
and i made some lifelong friends in this
situation really on both sides of the
aisle and this has been tough tough for
our country
but sometimes some good comes from tough
situations and i think some good will
come from this before it's all said and
done
ladies and gentlemen in the senate i
know it doesn't look to be so now but it
will be so later on
i come from a district where i'm the
first republican in 120 years
they tell me they hung the other guy so
i know i'm doing better
so i'm four years into this thing this
is my third term
and you can take
you can take the national polls and turn
them upside down in my district
but i have on occasion
said if the president would reconcile
himself with the law
i would be willing to consider something
less than impeachment
i can assure you that did not go over
well with some people in my district
but i thought that would have been good
for the country
because elections come and go and we can
get through just about anything and
everything in this country
but it does take leadership and
character does still count
having said that i am a center like the
rest of you and the part of the problem
with this case is that we have to
confront our own sins because who are we
to judge others
when the things get to be private and
personal
i'm not asking you
to use that standard
i'm standing before you as a sinner
and i would never want my president or
your president removed because of
private sins
only when it gets to be constitutionally
out of bounds
only when it gets to be so egregious
that you can't look your children in the
eye and explain
what happened here in terms of the law
we can all explain human failings
but we've got a real mixed message going
on and it needs to be straightened out
quickly if you could bring the founding
fathers back
as everybody suggested the first debate
would could we call them as a witness
they would be some people objecting to
that live or dead it's been hard to get
a witness
and i guarantee you
you know what i think they would tell us
what's a poll
they would be instructed but we can't
summon them back but you know what i
really think they would tell us
we started this thing it's up to y'all
to carry it on
and it is and they would be right
it's not their job to tell us what to do
it's our job to take the spirit of what
they did and build on it
and if you've kept an open mind you have
fulfilled your job
if you've listened to the facts and vote
your conscience you have fulfilled your
job
i will not trample on your conscience
i've said that before
i have
started this process with great concern
and i leave with a lot of contentment
because i believe the facts have stood
the test of every type scrutiny
demagoguery you can throw at them
and they stand they stand firm and you
know what they're going to stand they're
going to stand the test of history
people suggest that history may judge
you badly if you have to vote to convict
this president i suggest that will not
that will be the least of your problems
our past
and this present moment
becomes our nation's future
and what are we going to leave to the
future generations
what do we do when the next federal
judge is brought before this body
having been impeached by the house
for cheating on our taxes
[Applause]
are we going to self-righteously throw
that federal judge out
after having listened to this massive
case of obstruction of justice and
perjury before a grand jury
we may throw that federal judge
out but we'll have to walk out the door
backwards
we will not walk out boldly
what happens when
the next federal judge is acquitted
by a jury of his peers
and you know the result
would be just to remove that judge
you did the right thing by not being
bound by the acquittal in the case of
judge hastings he did the right thing to
get to the truth
and act accordingly
because people who said in judgment of
others
there needs to be no reasonable doubt
about who they are and what they're able
to do in that role
the president of the united states
sets the top of the legal pyramid
if there's reasonable doubt about his
ability to faithfully execute the laws
of the land
our future will be better off if that
individual is removed
and let me tell you where it all comes
down to me
if you can go back and explain to your
children and your constituents how you
can be truthful and misleading at the
same time good luck
that's the legacy that bill clinton has
left all of us if we keep in office
the idea that i was truthful but
misleading
that scenario focuses around
whether or not one type sex occurred
versus the other type of sex
he's wanting you to buy into this
definition that was
allowed to exist because the wording
wasn't quite right
that's the essence of it i was truthful
but i was misleading
mr podesta asked a little more questions
than the other people did
and the president denied any type sexual
relationship to him
was he truthful there
was he truthful in his grand jury
testimony how can you be both it's just
absolutely impossible
i would like to play two clips for you
now
now you stated i think very honestly and
i appreciate that you were lied to by
the president
is it a fair statement giving your
previous testimony concerning your
30-minute conversation
that the president was trying to portray
himself
as a victim
of a relationship with monica lewinsky
i think that's the import of his whole
story
thank you before you put the other tape
in
every member of this body
should need to answer this question
is that a truthful statement
if you believe that the president of the
united states is a victim of miss
lewinsky we all owe him apology
he is not
he is not
you ask me why i want this president
removed
not only are there high crimes
not only they do not only the rise the
level of constitutional out of bounds
behavior not only are they worse than
what you remove judges for they show a
tremendous willingness as a national
leader
to put yourself
above anything
decent and good
i hope that still matters in america
next clip
would it be fair to say that you were
sitting there during this conversation
and that you had previously been told by
the president
that he was in essence a victim of miss
lewinsky's sexual demands
and you said nothing to anyone
is the question you said nothing is the
question you said nothing to anyone
about what the president told you right
um
i never told
any
of
my colleagues
about what the president told me
and this is after the president recants
his story recounts the story to you
where he's visually visibly upset
feels like he's a victim
that he associates himself with a
character who's being lied about and you
at no time
suggested to your colleagues
that there's something going on here
with the president and miss lewinsky you
need to know about
is that your testimony
i never
mentioned my conversation i regarded
that conversation as a
private conversation and confidence and
i didn't mention it to my colleagues i
didn't mention to to my friends i didn't
mention it to
my family besides my wife
did you mention it to any white house
lawyers
i mentioned it many months later to
lanny brewer in preparation for one of
my grand jury appearances
when i knew i would be questioned about
it
and i certainly
never
mentioned it to any reporter
ladies and gentlemen of the senate i've
asked you several times to vote your
conscience and i will not step on it if
you disagree with me but i've always
said let us tell the story about what
happened here i am saying it again
ladies and gentlemen we need to get to
the truth nothing but the truth the
whole truth and let the chips fall where
they may
let me just say this idea about being
truthful and misleading
can you sit back as the president of the
united states after you told a lie to a
key aid where you portray yourself as a
victim and watch the press stories fold
out or roll out along the lines that she
wears her test to dress is too tight
she comes from a broken home she's a
stalker she's sex obsessed can you sit
back and watch all that happen and still
be truthful but misleading
we have laws against that is that in
this country we have laws in this
country that even high government
officials cannot tell a lie to somebody
knowing that lie would be repeated to a
grand jury that's exactly what happened
here
he betrayed himself as a victim which is
not a misleading statement it's a lie
because if you knew the truth you
wouldn't consider him a victim
and that line went to a federal grand
jury and those citizens were trying very
hard very hard to get it right and he
was trying very hard to mislead him at
every turn
when they tried to get to the truth he
ran the other way
and he took the aura of the white house
with him
if you believe he's a victim then you
ought to acquit him
if you believe he's lying then you ought
not be our president
there's two things in this case
that are crimes
two aspects of it
before the paula jones deposition after
the paula jones deposition
and i'm gonna revisit that with you for
the very last time
the affidavit
was an attempt to have a cover story
where both of them could lie and go on
about their lives
the job search
was to take somebody who was being
friendly
and get them a job so they could go on
about their lives and someplace else and
get this matter behind them and conceal
from a court the truth
those things are crimes
the gifts or being under the bed of
betty curry the president's secretary is
no accident
they didn't walk over there by
themselves
they got conveyed by his secretary
after she picked him up from his
consensual lover
people have figured that part out
there's no accident that happened that's
a crime when you're subpoenaed to give
those gifts
but it's still about getting her a job
and having a cover story so she could go
on with her life
but when the article came out on january
the 21st
the whole flavor of this case changed
and i don't know how you gonna explain
this to yourself or others but i'm gonna
lay out to you what i think happened
based on the evidence
that january the 21st when the cover
story when the story broke that she may
have been telling what went on and the
president was faced with the idea that
the knowledge of the relationship was
out in the public forum
what did he do then
there was no more nice jobs
using a good friend
there was no more let's see if we can
hide the gifts and play hide the ball
you know what happened then
he turned on her
it's not my favorite part of the case
it's the most disgusting part of the
case
it's part of the case
that history will judge
the crimes change
they become more ominous because the
character traits become more ominous
the young lady
that was the stalker
that was sex obsessed
that wore skirts too tight
that young lady
was being talked about openly in public
that young lady was being lied about the
federal grand jury
and the truth is that young lady fell in
love with him
and probably to this day
24 5 year old young girl
doesn't believe it or want to believe
what was going to come our way
but y'all are adults y'all are the
leaders of this nation
for you to look at these facts and
conclude anything else
would be an injustice
because without that dress ladies and
gentlemen the stories will grow in
number
and we would have no admissions
of misleading and truthful
[Music]
the white house is the bully pulpit but
it should never be occupied by a bully
the white house will always be occupied
by sinners
including our founding fathers and
future occupants
what we do today
will put a burden on the white house and
the burden on our future
one way or the other
is it too much of a burden to say to
future presidents
don't fabricate stories in front of a
grand jury don't harsh words
don't mislead don't lie when you beg not
to is it too much to say to a president
if you ever sue play it straight
don't hide the gifts under the bed
don't get people to fall file false
testimony for you
don't try to trash out people who are
witnesses against you
if that's too much of a burden to put on
the white house
this nation is in hopeless decline
it is not too much of a burden ladies
and gentlemen
it is only common decency being applied
to the occupant of the white house
to acquit
under these facts
we'll place a burden
on the constitutional process of
impeachment and how we deal with others
who are federal judges and other high
public officials
that i suggest to you will be almost
irreconcilable
i want my country to go boldly into the
next century
i don't want us to limp into the next
century
i don't want us to crawl in the next
century regarding the rule of law
no matter what you do we will make it
the difference between how you vote here
i think determines whether we go boldly
with the rule of law intact
or we have explaining to do for
generations to come
i'll leave with you
an example
that i think says much
general macarthur was moved removed
by president truman
a very popular fella at the time
the reaction to the macarthur dismissal
was even more violent than truman had
expected
and for an entire year majority public
opinion ranked itself ferociously
against him
he said characteristically of the
hostile polls
i wonder how far moses would have gone
if it had taken a poll in egypt
what would jesus christ have preached if
you've taken a poll in the land of
israel
it isn't polls that count
it's right and wrong
and leadership
men with fortitude
honesty
and a belief in the right
that make epics in the history of the
world
ladies and gentlemen of the senate thank
you for listening
if you got any doubts about whether this
president has committed high crimes
we need to make sure the senate itself
was told the truth
don't leave any doubts lingering because
the evidence is overwhelming
that these offenses occurred the crime
of perjury and obstruction of justice
have traditionally been high crimes
under our constitutions for god's sakes
let them remain so
and let it be said that no president
can take the presidency and the bully
pulpit of the presidency
and hurt average citizens from it
thank you very much
the chair recommend recognizes mr
manager hyde
mr chief justice
learned council and the
senate
we are blessedly coming to the end of
this melancholy procedure
but before we gather up our papers and
return to the obscurity from once we
came
permit please a few final remarks
first of all i want to thank the chief
justice not only for his patience and
his perseverance
but for the aura of dignity that he has
lent to these proceedings and
it has been a great thrill really to
be here in his company as well as in the
company of you distinguished senators
secondly i want to complement the
president's council
they have conducted themselves in the
most professional way
they have made the most
of a
poor case in my opinion
excuse me there's an old italian saying
and it has nothing to do with the
lawyers but to your case
says you may dress the shepherd in silk
he will still smell of the goat
but all of you are great lawyers and
it's been
an adventure being with you
you know the legal profession like
politics is ridiculed
pretty much and every lawyer
feels that and understands the
importance of the rule of law
to establish justice to maintain the
rights of mankind to defend the helpless
and the oppressed
to protect innocence to punish guilt
these are duties which challenge the
best powers of man's intellect and the
noblest qualities of the human heart
we are here to defend that bulwark of
our liberty
the rule of law
as for the house managers i want to tell
you
and our extraordinary staff how proud i
am of your service
for myself i cannot find the words to
adequately express how i feel
i must use
the inaudible language of the heart
i've gone through it all by your side
the
media condemnations
the patronizing editorials the hate mail
the insults hurled in public the
attempts at intimidation the death
threats and even the disapproval of our
colleagues
which cuts
the worst
you know all a congressman ever gets to
take with him when he leaves this
building
is the esteem of his
colleagues and his constituents
we've risked that
for a principle and for our duty as
we've seen it
in speaking to my managers of whom i am
terminally proud i can borrow the words
shakespeare's henry v
as he addressed his little army of
longbowmen at the
battle of ajinkor
and he said we few
we happy few
we band of brothers
for he
who sheds his blood with me shall be my
brother
and gentlemen in england a bed
will curse
the fact that they are not here and hold
their manhood cheap
when any speaks who fought with us on
saint crispin's day
as for the juror judges
you distinguish senators it's always a
victory for democracy when its elected
representatives do their duty no matter
how difficult
and unpleasant and we thank you for it
please don't misconstrue our fervor
for our cause to any lack of respect or
appreciation
for your high office
but our most formidable opponent has not
been opposing council
or any political party
it's been a cynicism
the widespread conviction that all
politics and all politicians are by
definition corrupt and venal
that cynicism is an acid eating away at
the vital organs of american public life
it is a clear and present danger because
it blinds us to the nobility and the
fragility
of being a self-governing people
one of the several questions that needs
answer
is whether your vote on conviction
lessens or enlarges that cynicism
nothing begets cynicism like the double
standard one rule for the popular and
the powerful
and another for the rest of us
one of the most interesting things in
this trial was the testimony
of the president's good friend the
former senator from arkansas
he did his persuasive best to maintain
the confusion
that this is all about sex
of course it's useful for the defense to
misdirect our focus toward everyone
concedes our private acts and none of
our business
but if you care to read the articles of
impeachment you won't find any
complaints about private sexual
misconduct you will find charges of
perjury and obstruction of justice which
are public acts and federal crimes
especially when committed by one the one
person
duty bound to faithfully execute the
laws
infidelity is private and non-criminal
perjury and obstruction are public and
criminal
the deliberate focus on what is not an
issue here
is a defense lawyer's tactic and nothing
more
this entire saga has been a theater of
distraction and misdirection
time-honored defense tactics when the
law and the facts get in the way
one phrase you have not heard the
defense pronounce is the sanctity of the
oath
but this case deeply involves the
efficacy the meaning and the
enforceability of the oath
the president's defenders stay away from
the word lie
preferring mislead or deceived
but they shrink from the phrase sanctity
of the oath
fearing it as one might a rattlesnake
there is a visibility factor in the
president's public acts
and those which betray a trust or reveal
contempt for the law
are hard to sweep under the rug
or under the bed for that matter
they reverberate they ricochet all over
the land
and provide the worst possible example
for our young people
as that third grader from chicago wrote
to me if you can't believe the president
who can you believe
speaking of young people
in
1946 a british playwright
terence radigan wrote a play based on a
true
experience that happened in england in
1910
the play was called the winslow boy
and the story as i say a true story
involved a young 13 year old lad
who was
kicked out of the royal naval college
for
having forged somebody else's signature
on a postal money order of course he
claimed he was innocent
but he was summarily dismissed and his
family of very modest means couldn't
afford legal counsel and it was a very
desperate situation
sir edward carson the best lawyer of his
time barrister i suppose
got interested in the case and took it
on
pro bono and lost all the way through
the court
finally he had no other place to go but
he dug up an ancient remedy in england
called petition of right
you asked the king for relief and so
carson wrote out five pages of reasons
why
a petition of right should be granted
and lo and behold it got past the
attorney general got to the king
the king read it
agreed with it
and wrote across the front of the
petition
let right be done
edward the seventh
and i have always been moved by that
phrase i saw the movie i saw the play
and i have the book
and i am still moved by that phrase let
right
be done i hope when you finally vote
that will move you too there are some
interesting parallels
to our cause here today this senate
chamber is our version of the house of
lords
and while we managers cannot claim to
represent that 13-year-old winslow boy
we speak for a lot of young people who
look to us
to set an example ms seligman last
saturday
said we want to win too badly
this surprised me because none of the
managers has committed perjury
nor obstructed justice nor claimed false
privileges none has hidden evidence
under anyone's bed or encouraged false
testimony before the grand jury that's
what you do if you want to win too badly
i believe it was saul bello who once
said a great deal of intelligence can be
invested in ignorance
when the need for illusion is great
and those words characterize the defense
in this case the need for illusion
is great
i doubt there are many people on the
planet
who doubt the president has repeatedly
lied under oath and has obstructed
justice
the defense spent a lot of time picking
lint there's a saying in equity i
believe that
equity will not stoop to pick up pins
but that was their case
so the real issue doesn't concern the
facts the stubborn facts
as the defense is fond of saying but
what to do about them
i am still dumbfounded about the drafts
of the censures
that are that are circulating
we aren't half as tough
on the president in our impeachment
articles as this draft is that was
printed in the
new york times
an inappropriate relationship with a
subordinate employee in the white house
which was shameless reckless and
indefensible
i have a problem with that it seems
they're talking about private acts of
consensual
sexual misconduct which are really none
of our business but that's the lead-off
then they say the president deliberately
misled and deceived the american people
and officials in all branches of the
united states government this is not a
republican document this is coming from
here
the president gave false or or
misleading testimony and impeded
discovery of evidence in judicial
proceedings
isn't that another way of saying
obstruction of justice and perjury
the president's conduct demeans the
office of the president as well as the
president himself and creates disrespect
for the laws of the land
future generations of americans must
know that such behavior is not only
unacceptable but bears grave
consequences including loss of integrity
trust and respect but not loss of job
whereas william jefferson clinton's
conduct has brought shame and dishonor
to himself into the office of the
president
whereas he has violated the trust of the
american people
see hamilton
federalist number 65
and he should be condemned in the
strongest terms well the next to the
strongest terms the strongest terms
would remove him from office
well do you really cleanse the
office as provided in the constitution
or do you use the
airwick of a censure resolution
because
any sensor resolution to be meaningful
has to punish the president if only his
reputation
and how do you deal with the laws of
bill of attainder how do you deal with
the separation of powers what kind of a
precedent are you setting we all claim
to revere the constitution
but accenture is something
that is a device
a way of avoiding the harsh
constitutional option and it's the only
one you have or up or down on
impeachment
that of course is your
judgment and i am offering
my views
for what they're worth
once in a while i do worry about the
future i wonder
if after this culture war is over that
we're engaged in
if an america will survive that's worth
fighting to defend people won't risk
their lives for the u.n
or over the dow jones averages
but i wonder in future generations
whether there be
enough vitality left in duty honor and
country to excite our children and
grandchildren to defend america
there's no denying the fact that what
you decide it will have a profound
effect
on our culture as well as on our
politics a failure to convict will make
a statement that lying under oath while
unpleasant
and to be avoided is not all that
serious
perhaps we can explain this to those
currently in prison
for perjury we have reduced lying under
oath to a breach of etiquette
but only if you are the president
wherever
and whenever you avert your eyes from
wrong
from an injustice you become a part of
the problem
on the subject of civil rights
it's my belief this issue doesn't belong
to anyone
it belongs to everyone
it certainly belongs to those who have
suffered invidious discrimination and
one would have to be catatonic
not to know that the struggle to keep
alive equal protection of the law never
ends
the mortal enemy of equal justice is the
double standard and if we permit a
double standard even for the president
we do no favor to the cause of human
rights
it's been said that america has nothing
to fear from this president
on the subject of civil rights
i doubt paula jones would subscribe to
that endorsement
if you agree the perjury and obstruction
of justice have been committed
and yet you vote down the conviction
you're expending and expanding the
boundaries of permissible presidential
conduct you're saying a perjurer and an
obstructor of justice can be president
in the face of no less than three
precedents for conviction
of federal judges for perjury you shred
those precedents
and you raise the most serious questions
of whether the president is in fact
subject to the law
or whether we are beginning a
restoration
of the divine right of kings
the issues we're concerned with have
consequences far into the future
because the real damage is not to the
individuals involved but to the american
system of justice
and especially the principle that no one
is above the law
edward gibbon
wrote his magisterial decline and fall
of the roman empire in the late 18th
century
in fact the first volume was issued in
1776
in his work he discusses an emperor
named septimius severus who died in 211
a.d after ruling 18 years and here's
what gibbon wrote about the emperor
severus promised only to betray
he flattered only to ruin and however he
might occasionally bind himself by oaths
and treaties his conscience obsequious
to his interest
always released him from the
inconvenient obligation
i guess those who believe history
repeats itself are really onto something
horus man said you should be ashamed to
die
unless you have achieved some victory
for humanity
to the house managers i say your
devotion to duty in the constitution
has set an example that is a victory for
humanity
charles de gaulle once said france would
not be true to herself
she wasn't engaged in some great
enterprise
that's true of us all we spend our short
lives as consumers
space occupiers clock watchers
as spectators
or
in the service of some great enterprise
i believe being a senator
being a congressman
and struggling with all our might for
equal justice
for all
is a great enterprise
it's our great enterprise
and to my house managers your great
enterprise
was not to speak truth to power
but to shout it
and now let us all take our place in
history
on the side of honor and oh yes
let right be done i yield back my time
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice i believe that
concludes the closing arguments
therefore the senate will reconvene as
the court of impeachment at 1 pm on
tuesday to resume consideration of the
articles of impeachment i would ask the
court of impeachment standing
adjournment until 1pm tomorrow and i ask
further consent that the senate now
resume consideration of the legislative
session i remind all senators to stand
as the chief justice department chamber
without objection it's so ordered
the senate will please come to order
okay
please take your conversations to the
hallway or the cloakroom
senate will please come to order for a
short period of business
the senate will please come to order
the majority leader deserves to be heard
mr majority leader
mr president there's a bill at the desk
due for its second reading
clerk will read
h.r 99 and act to amend title 49 united
states code to extend federal aviation
administration programs through
september 30th 1999 and for other
purposes
i would object to further proceedings mr
president on this matter at this time
objection is heard it will be placed on
the calendar i now ask unanimous consent
that the senate proceed to the
consideration of the senate concurrent
resolution which is at the desk
the clerk will read the resolution
senate concurrent resolution seven
honoring the life and legacy of king
hussein
[Music]
all hashem
uh mr president i ask unanimous consent
that the resolution be agreed to the
preamble be agreed to and the motion
reconsiderably laid upon the table and
any statements relating to the
resolution appear at this point in the
record without objection i want to note
uh mr president that uh i i'm offering
this uh on my behalf and the
distinguished minority leader senator
daschle uh this is a resolution of
course uh
uh commending the significant and
lasting contributions to peace and
security of his majesty king hussein of
jordan and i'd ask unanimous consent
that my entire statement be made a part
of the record at this point without
objection president ordered i would ask
unanimous consent that a statement that
i would like to insert at the record in
the record be considered as read and
follow immediately the statement made by
the majority leader without objection so
ordered and mr president now ask
unanimous sense of sentence stand in the
german under the previous order until 1
pm tomorrow
the senate is adjourned until 1 pm
tomorrow
all those other people that have been in
the military like the first pilot
who was got given a dishonorable
discharge because she had an affair is
he not our commander-in-chief they
should all be reinstated to their jobs
thanks westminster the senate about to
be in session you will see live gavel to
gavel coverage here on c-span 2. this
all will re-air on our companion network
c-span tonight at 8 o'clock eastern time
if you weren't able to get through
during this session where our phone
lines were open we invite you to join us
if the hearing is in fact if the
deliberations are in fact closed as soon
as the senate goes into closed session
we'll be opening our phone lines again
for your thoughts if the hearings the
deliberations are open when the senate
takes breaks we'll be back with your
phone calls
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
almighty god
we renew our trust in you when we
realize
how much you have entrusted to us
we are stunned by the psalmist reminder
that you have crowned us with glory and
honor
and given us responsibility over the
work of your hands
we renew our dependence on you
as we assume this breathtaking call
to courageous leadership
help the senators to claim your promised
glory and honor
imbue them with your own attributes
and strengthen their desire to do what
is right and just
as they humbly cast before you
any crowns of position or pride
crown them with your presence and power
in your holy name
amen amen
the sergeant-at-arms will make
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date
the chair recognizes the majority
thank you mr chief justice
this afternoon the senate will begin
final deliberations on the articles of
impeachment
a higher pursuant to s-rest 30 a senator
may at this time offer a motion to
suspend the rules to allow the final
deliberations to remain open
that motion is not amendable and no
motions to that motion may be offered
therefore i would expect at least one
vote to occur occur shortly
following that vote if the motion is
defeated i will move to close
deliberations if that motion should be
adopted the senate will begin full
deliberations with each senator
allocated 15 minutes to speak and i
should note that that would be true
whether it is
in open or closed session although
senator daschle and i may have some
further comments to make about that
later on
i would note that if each senator uses
his or her entire debate time the
proceedings would take
25 hours not including breaks and
recesses
and therefore i remind all senators that
lincoln gave his gettysburg address in
less than three minutes
and kennedy's first inaugural was
slightly over seven minutes
but
certainly every senator will have his or
her opportunity to speak
for up to 15 minutes if that is their
desire and of course we would also need
to
communicate with the chief justice about
the time of the proceedings i would
expect that we would try to go until
about 6 or 6 30 this afternoon
i want to confer with senator daschle
but i think maybe we will try to begin
earlier tomorrow
and go throughout the day into the early
evening but again we do have to take
consideration the fact that
[Music]
about seven or eight hours would be the
absolute maximum you could probably do
in a single day but we will we'll talk
further about that and make an
announcement before
we uh
conclude today and now you're on the
floor to the senator from pennsylvania
senator specter for the purpose of
propounding a unanimous consent
agreement the chair recognizes senator
spector
chief justice on the
behalf of the leader and in my capacity
as
a co-presider
for the senate at the deposition of mr
sidney blumenthal i ask unanimous
consent that the parties be allowed to
take
additional testimony
additional discovery including testimony
on oral deposition
of mr christopher hitchens
miss carol blue mr r scott armstrong
and mr cindy blumenthal
with regard to possible fraud on the
senate by
alleged perjury and the deposition
testimony
of mr cindy blumenthal with respect to
allegations
that he mr sidney blumenthal
was involved with dissemination beyond
the white house of information
detrimental to the credibility of miss
monica lewinsky
and that pursuant to the authority of
title ii senate resolution 30 the chief
justice of the
united states to the secretary of the
senate
shall issue subpoenas for the taking of
such testimony
at a time and place to be determined by
the majority leader after
consultation with the democratic leader
and further
that these depositions be conducted
pursuant to the procedures
sent forth in title ii of senate
resolution 30.
except that the last four sentences of
section 204
shall not apply to these depositions
provided further however
that the final sentence of
section 204 shall apply to the
deposition of mr sidney blumenthal is
there objection justice i object
objection is heard
i recognize the majority leader on
behalf of myself and senator daschle i
moved to suspend the rules on behalf of
senators hutchinson
harkin
and others in order to conduct open
deliberations
a senator from minnesota
there'd be a 40-minute debate equally
divided between the leaders of their
designees in open session on the motion
to suspend the rules
is there objection
objection is heard
the question is on the motion to suspend
the rules
uh the eyes and knees
the yeas and these are automatic the
clerk will call the role
abraham
mr abraham
i
mr akaka
mr akaka no
mr allard
mr allard i
mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft no
mr baucus
mr baucus
i
mr bai
mr bai
i
mr
bennett mr bennett no
mr biden
mr bingaman
mr bingaman
aye
mr bond
mr bond
no
mrs boxer
mrs boxer
i
mr bro
mr bro i
mr brownback
mr brownback no mr brian
mr brian
aye
mr bunning
mr bunning no mr burns
mr burns no
mr bird
mr bird i
mr campbell
mr campbell
no
mr chafee
cleland
mr cleland i
mr cochrane
mr cochrane no
ms collins
ms collins i mr conrad
mr conrad i mr coverdale
mr coverdale no
mr craig
mr craig no
mr crapo
mr crapo no
mr daschle
mr daschle i
mr dewine
mr dewine i mr dodd
mr dodd i mr domenici
mr domenici
no mr dorgan
mr dorgan i mr durbin
mr durbin i mr edwards
mr edwards aye mr enzi
mr nz
no mr feingold
mr feingold i
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein i
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald no
mr frist
mr frist no mr gorton
mr gorton i mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida i
mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas no mr grahams of
minnesota
mr grassley
mr grassley no
mr greg
mr greg
no mr hegel
mr hegel
i mr harkin
mr harkin i
mr hatch mr hatch no mr helms
mr hollins
mr hollings i
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas no mrs
hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas i
mr inhofe
mr inhofe no mr in no way
mr no way i mr jeffords
mr jeffords aye
mr johnson
mr johnson
aye mr kennedy
mr kennedy i
mr kerry of nebraska
mr kerry of nebraska aye mr kerry of
massachusetts
mr kerry of massachusetts aye mr cole
mr cole
i mr kyle
mr kyle
i
ms landrieu
ms landrieu
i
mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg i
mr leahy
mr leahy
i mr levin
mr levin i mr lieberman
mr lieberman i
mrs lincoln
mrs lincoln
i
mr lock
mr lot
no
mr luger
mr luger
hi
mr mack
mr mack
no mr mccain
mr mccain
i mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell no
ms mikulski
ms mikulski
i
mr moynihan
mr moynihan aye mr murkowski
mr murkowski
no
mrs murray
mrs murray
i
mr nichols
mr nichols no
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island i mr reed of
nevada
mr reed of nevada i mr rob
mr rob i mr roberts
mr roberts no
mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller
i
mr roth
mr roth
no
mr santorum
mr santorum no
mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes
i
mr schumer
mr schumer
i mr sessions
mr sessions no mr shelby
mr shelby no
mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire no
mr smith of oregon
mr smith of oregon
aye
ms snow
miss snow
i
mr specter
mr specter
i mr stevens
mr stevens
aye mr thomas
mr thomas
no
mr thompson
mr thompson
no mr thurman
no mr thurman no mr torricelli
mr vornovich
mr vornovich no
mr warner
mr warner no
mr wellstone
mr wellstone
i mr wyden
mr wyden
i mr allard
this is chief justice
mr allard no
the chair recognizes the senator from
hawaii
mr akaka
i
mr helms
mr helms no
mr chafee
mr chafee no
mr grahams of minnesota
mr graham's of minnesota no
mr torricelli
mr torcelli i
mr biden
[Applause]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
on this boat the a's are 59 the nays are
41
two-thirds of those senators voting a
quorum being present not having voted in
the affirmative the motion is not agreed
to
mr justice uh
i observe the absence of reform
clerk will call the role mr abraham
mr akaka
mr allard
strashcroft
mr barcas
mr bye
mr bennett
okay
so
mr biden
mr bingaman
during legislative sessions the senators
used the quorum calls to meet sometimes
on the senate floor or just off to
discuss issues that they are debating
it's during legislation apparently the
same thing going on now senate majority
leader trent lott suggested the absence
of a quorum as you can see just before
they went to this graphic he was
talking with democratic leader senator
tom daschle discussing where the
impeachment trial of the president goes
next a few minutes ago as you saw on a
vote of 59 to 41 the senate voted not to
open final deliberations to televised
coverage a two-thirds vote was needed or
67 votes was needed to change the senate
rules to open to coverage mr brownback
the a votes were 59
about seven about eight votes short of
the necessary two-thirds while this
quorum call continues we'll take the
opportunity to try to get as many of
your calls in as we can
and then once the senate goes into this
closed session we'll again be taking
your phone calls so if you don't get in
in this portion stay with us because
we'll be back shortly to your calls 202
is the area code if you've decided
you're for acquittal 624 11 11 is the
number but 624 1115 is the line to use
if you are for conviction fayetteville
north carolina you're up first
yes i'm for acquittal because i just
think the way the republicans went about
this is all wrong they wanted to bring
down this man's administration but they
couldn't do it with their political
ideas so they did it with his personal
problems and that's not the right way
and another thing i don't feel like he
betrayed the public trust i never asked
him who he was sleeping with and so i
don't feel like he was lying to me
that's not what i'm concerned with when
i see my president what i'm concerned
with is how is he going to keep this
economy going how is it going to keep
the job employment rate up that's what
i'm more concerned with and the
republicans have tried i don't
understand why anybody is not outraged
that after four years and 40 million
dollars they did not have a case until
monica lewinsky came along how in the
world can we be at this point when we
should have been at this point at
whitewater nothing there foul gate
nothing there travelgate nothing there
campaign finance nothing there but yet
monica lewinsky his personal affair
something that we shouldn't even be
concerned about as a nation is what
we're having this impeachment about
newberry springs california
uh yes sir first of all uh thanks for
the wonderful coverage uh by c-span
you're welcome i have uh just a couple
observations to make here uh i was
wondering i i hear
the term quite often throughout the
senate about
voting your conscience voting your
conscience
this is fine now my question
to them would be
what are they going to do with their
conscience
of the young woman who
had attained the
aircraft commandership the only woman to
do this
in history and none after her uh as a
b-52 pilot
uh they took her so-called sexual
interest indiscretion and uh because
they couldn't convict her on that turn
around and convicted around
insubordination
secondly there's a captain and a
lieutenant
right now facing the same kind of a
dilemma
as clinton had put himself in but
they're thinking of court martial and
hanging him
and i recognize the majority leader
mr chief justice uh
i asked consent the quorum call be
dispensed with in the absence of
objection it's so ordered
and mischief justice uh i do want to
encourage
a reminder that uh only those people
that are properly authorized to be on
the floor of the senate should be here
and the sergeant-at-arms will
act accordingly
now mr chief justice there is a desire
by a number of senators that
it'd be possible for their statements
even in closed session uh be made a part
of the record senator daschle and i have
talked a great deal about this we think
this is appropriate way to proceed
and therefore i would send this motion
to the desk that the record of the
proceedings held in closed session
for any senator to insert their final
liberations on the articles of
impeachment shall be published in the
congressional record at the conclusion
of the trial
what
the clerk read the clerk will read the
motion
the senator from mississippi mr lot
moves that the record of the proceedings
held in closed session
for final deliberations on the articles
of impeachment
oh
mr chief of justice i used adam's
consent that the uh reading be dispensed
with
and in the absence of
no order
now
chief justice so that everybody would
understand if i could be recognized as
the chair recognize the majority desire
one and all
to have
the opportunity for this record to be
made
after the trial is concluded uh senators
can have their statements in the closed
section put in the congressional record
in the record of the trial
uh there may be senators that choose for
whatever reason not to do it in that way
at that time
and uh senator dash and i've talked a
great deal about this and we think that
this is the fair way to make that record
and we would urge
that it be adopted point of point of
clarification the chairman recognizes
the senator from california ms feinstein
thank you mr chief justice mr leader
could i ask a point of clarification
does this mean that repartee between
members will not be recorded but just
the statement
as the member submits it
mr chief justice if i could respond to
that as best i can
i think that would be up to the senators
um that has been one of my points i hope
that we won't just have speeches
and in fact we will have deliberations
as we have found ourselves in previous
closed sessions uh almost uncontrollably
we wound up
discussing and talking with each other
i would hope that if we come to that
that the senators involved and the the
exchange would make that a part of the
record and a part of history and i
believe that they would have that right
under this uh proposal senator daschle i
yield uh percentage
purposes of clarification i think i may
have misunderstood what the majority
leader
described here but but our intent would
be to allow statements to be inserted in
the congressional record not into the
hearing record
so correct and i misstated that right so
people understand this would actually
allow you the opportunity to insert your
statement into the congressional record
succeeding the votes on the two articles
the chair recognizes the senator from
minnesota i thank the chief justice a
question for the majority leader i i may
not have just might not have heard this
the right way
this would uh allow any senator
who who so wishes to have
his or her statements made in all of our
not just final deliberations but through
this would cover all of our
sessions that have been closed sessions
is that correct or not
mr chief justice i believe this would be
applicable only to the final
deliberation well mr chief justice if i
could ask the majority leader whether he
might be willing seems to me if this is
the principle
i wonder whether he would amend his
request so that any senator who wanted
to
it would be entirely up to the senator
this is far different than having our
final deliberations a matter of public
records which is what i think we should
do but what you're saying is that any
senator who so wishes can do so might
that not apply to all of the closed
sessions we've had it would seem to me
the same principle would apply to all of
it
that's not what is in this proposal and
i
i'd like to think about that and discuss
it with the senator of minnesota and
others uh
i remember making a passion speech but i
had no prepared notes
uh and so i couldn't put it in the
record if i wanted to uh when we were in
one of those closed sessions but it's a
it's a a thought i honestly had not
considered this was aimed at the closing
deliberations i think we need to give
some thought to reaching back
now to those other closed sessions uh
before we move in that direction the
chair recognizes center from idaho
senator craig would the majority leader
yield for a question
uh glad to hear mr judge
is it my understanding that your motion
would keep this session of deliberations
closed
except for those senators
who would choose to have their
statements
become a part
of the congressional record
and that it would be the choice of the
individual senators and that the
deliberations of the closed session
would remain closed
unless otherwise specified by each
individual senator specific to their
statements
is that a fair understanding mr chief
justice uh that is uh accurate
understanding and that is with the
presumption that we will uh go into
closed session uh and such a motion will
be made in short order and i also want
to clarify that this is uh made on
behalf of senator daschle and myself
and we've consulted a great deal on this
and we both have been thinking about
doing something like this but we just
never had actually put it on paper until
just a moment ago but you're you're
stupid
as a senator from georgia senator
coverdale
an inquiry to the leader
in response to the question by the
senator from california who alluded to
actual deliberations and not a statement
among senators
i would assume
that in your concurrence that that could
go into the congressional record it
would require all the participants of
the colloquy
the parliamentarian tells me this is all
out of order
mr chief justice uh
um
if i may uh
i will in a moment i will make a motion
to close the doors for deliberations
however i believe we have to dispose of
this pending motion no
the question is on the motion
ask the majority leader one further
follow-up question on his motion
without objection uh mischief justice
i want to make sure i fully understand
from the distinguished majority leader
our vote on what we do on the record
does not
include a vote on closing the session
itself it simply assumes that vote
carries
right
the chair recognizes the senator from
iowa
again i'd ask consent that i'd be able
to ask the majority leader a question
regarding the ethics without objection
i just have a question regarding the
ethics rules under this
proposed motion
could a senator
give his or her statement in public
and then give the same statement in
closed session and still not violate the
ethics rules i'm concerned about
how we might run afoul of that i'd
yield to the head of the ethics
committee for clarification
justin are from new hampshire if the
motion carries
as has been outlined by the majority
leader you have
every right to release your statement
that would not violate rule 29.5 i could
give it an open out and open or whatever
i could do
your statement yes yours not anybody
else's
i understand
the chair recognizes the senator from
washington
says i ask unanimous consent to ask the
majority leader a point of clarification
uh
without objection
i would just ask if we reference another
senator's remarks in our statements
would we have to get that other
senator's
consent in order to submit our statement
then for the record
i'm not chairman of the ethics committee
but i'm assured by those that are on the
committee that you would have to do so
are we ready to move forward now mr
chief justice uh the
senator from from massachusetts senator
kerry i ask unanimous consent that i'd
be permitted to ask a point of
clarification without objection
uh mischief justice i'd ask the majority
leader he mentioned that he hoped during
the deliberations there would be
more than just speeches and there'd be a
process of policy
i was wondering if he was then
contemplating
how that would work because i think
under the rules were limited to one
intervention of a specific time period
does the majority leader contemplate
approaching that differently mr chief
justice i have discussed this
with the democratic leader and uh
there's no iron clad rule uh
you know um in our other closed sessions
when we got sort of got on a roll uh
we uh yielded additional time to each
other
and then at some point we just started
having a round robin the chief justice
probably thought it was all completely
out of order but he allowed us
to go forward
i think we'll just have to deal with
that when we get there and i think as
it's been the case all the way along uh
we'll be understanding of each other and
and try to make these deliberations
genuine deliberations i think it'd
benefit us all and and the final result
mr chief justice before i make a motion
then to close the doors
i yield to the senator from texas for a
parliamentary inquiry
we have a motion do we not our big
partners
however amorphous it may be that
what did he say however amorphous it may
be
all in favor say aye
opposed no
the eyes appear to have it
now mr chief justice thank you for that
amorphous ruling
and i would yield to the senator from
texas for parliamentary inquiry the
chair recognizes senator hutchinson
mr chief justice
rule 20 says that while the senate is in
session the doors shall remain open
unless the senate directs that the doors
be closed
my inquiry is this
if the senate by a majority voted not to
direct the doors to be closed
would it be in order to proceed to
deliberations with the doors open
the chair is of the view that it would
not be in order for this reason
on the initial reading rules 20 and rule
24 of the senate impeachment rules
would not appear to mandate that
deliberations and debate occur in closed
session but only to permit it
but it is clear from a review of the
history of the rules that the committee
that it was established in 1868 to
create the rules specifically intended
to require closed sessions for debate
and deliberations
senator howard reported the rules for
the committee and clearly understated
his intention
and chief justice chase in the andrew
johnson trial stated in response to an
inquiry there can be no deliberation
unless the doors are closed there can be
no debate under the rules unless the
doors be closed
and i understand from the
parliamentarian it's been the consistent
practice of the senate for the last 130
years in impeachment trials to require
deliberations and debate by the senate
to be held in closed session
and i would therefore though there may
be some ambiguity between the two rules
my ruling is based partly on deference
to the senate's long-standing practice
in the opinion of the chair there can be
no deliberation on any question before
the senate in open session unless the
senate suspends its rules or consent is
granted
that uh record having been made i now
move the doors for final deliberations
be closed and ask consent that the yeas
and nays be vitiated
uh the senator from minnesota i wonder
whether the majority i've been trying to
get the floor i wonder whether i could
not move
that any senator be allowed
if he or she makes this choice
to have
our statements that have been made in
past closed sessions it's entirely up to
us also to be a part of the
congressional record
mr chief justice uh
if i could respond give us an
opportunity to discuss this with you we
will have another opportunity to do that
i think it you know maybe we can work
something out but i'd like to make sure
we thought it through if that's
appropriate mr chief justice
the senator from iowa
the objection is heard
the yeas and nays are automatic
the clerk will call the roll mr abraham
mr abraham i
mr akaka
mr akaka no
mr allard
mr allard
i
the senate will be in order
strashcroft
mr ashcroft i
mr baucus
mr baucus
no
mr bai
mr bai
no
mr bennett
mr bennett
i
mr biden
mr biden
no
mr bingaman
mr bingaman no
mr bond mr bond i
mrs boxer
mrs boxer
no
order
the senate will be in order
mr bro
no
mr brownback
mr brownback aye mr bryan
mr brian
no mr bunning
mr bunning aye
mr burns
mr burns aye mr bird
mr bird
no
mr campbell
mr campbell
aye mr chafee
mr chafee aye mr cleland
mr cleland
no mr cochran
mr cochran
aye ms collins
miss collins i mr conrad
mr conrad
no mr coverdale
mr coverdell
aye mr craig
mr craig i mr crapo
mr crapo aye mr daschle
mr daschle no mr dewine
mr dewine aye mr dodd
mr dodd
no mr domenici
mr domenici aye mr dorgan
mr dorgan
no mr durbin
mr durbin
no mr edwards
mr edwards no mr enzi
mr nz
aye mr feingold
mr feingold no
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein
no
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald i mr frist mr frist
i mr gorton
mr gorton
i mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida
no mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas
aye mr graham's in minnesota
mr grams of minnesota
aye mr grassley
mr grassley
aye mr gregg
mr greg
i
mr hegel
mr hegel
aye mr harkin
mr
harkin no mr hatch
mr hatch
aye mr helms
mr helms aye mr hollings
mr hollings
no
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas
i
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas
no
mr inhofe
mr inhofe
i
mr noah
mr noah
no
mr jeffords
mr jeffords
i mr johnson
mr johnson
no
mr kennedy
mr kennedy
no mr carey of nebraska
mr carey of nebraska
no mr carey in massachusetts
mr kerry in massachusetts
no mr cole
mr cole
no mr kyle
mr kyle
i miss landrieu
ms landrieu
no
mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg
no
mr leahy
mr leahy no mr levin
mr levin
no
the senate will be in order
and that goes for the galleries too
mr lieberman
mr lieberman
no
mrs lincoln
mrs lincoln
no
mr lott
mr lott
i mr luger
mr luger
i
mr mack
mr mack
i
mr mccain
mr mccain
mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell
i
miss mikulski
ms mikulski
no
mr moynihan
mr moynihan no mr murkowski
mr murkowski
i
mrs murray
mrs murray
no
mr nichols
mr nichols
aye
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island
no mr reed of nevada
mr reed of nevada
no mr robb
robb
no
mr roberts
mr roberts
aye
mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller
no
mr roth
mr roth i
mr santorum
mr santorum
i mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes
no
mr schumer
schumer
no
mr sessions
mr sessions i
mr shelby
mr shelby aye
mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire
i mr smith of oregon
mr smith of oregon i
miss snow
miss snow
mr spector
mr spector
no
mr stevens
mr stevens
no
mr thomas
mr thomas
i
mr thompson
mr thompson
aye mr thurman
mr thurmond
aye mr torreselli
mr torres ellie
no
mr boinovich
mr boinovich
i
mr warner
mr warner
i'm mr wellstone
mr wellstone
no
mr wyden
mr wyden
now
[Music]
the senator from alaska mr stevens
mr stevens
i
[Music]
few
on this vote the yeas are 53 the nays
are 47 the motion is agreed to
mr chief justice i believe now the the
galleries will all be uh cleared and
we'll be prepared uh to proceed with the
deliberations
and i hope that senators are prepared to
go forward with their their statements
just so that this final
clearance can be made i will ask just
for a very brief uh
call of the roll but it'll be very brief
because we want to go ahead and get
started we have a lot of time that we
can use today so i will suggest
abstinent forum but just for a couple of
minutes
mr abraham
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
sovereign god
thank you for the good
men and women of this
senate today we ask what should be done
when really good people disagree
you've shown us
so clearly
what should and should not be
done when the fabric of our human
relationships is being frayed
it is time to deepen our relationship
with you
draw each senator into healing communion
with you
that will give physical strength and
spiritual assurance
of your unqualified love for him or her
then in the inner heart give your peace
and direction
give each senator
this courage to speak truth
as she or he hears it and knows it
when this trial is finished
may none feel the pangs of unspoken
convictions
dear god
we also know there's something we dare
not do when good people disagree
you do not condone the impunching of
another person's character
because they hold different convictions
you do not want us to break our unity
or the bond of sacred friendship
bless these good senators
as they press forward together
with love for you
america
and each other
in the unity of your spirit
and the bond of peace
amen
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date the majority leader is recognized
mr chief justice in a few moments the
senate will resume the closed session in
order to allow members to continue to
deliberate the two articles of
impeachment
members are reminded that the motion
adopted yesterday allows for a record to
be printed on the day of the vote of
articles which would contain senators
final statements
if they choose to have them printed
also
senator daschle was just noting that
while senators have been careful
not to comment on the discussion the
closed session
we still should use a lot of discretion
in going out and talking to
the media about
about the details of what's uh happening
here i don't think there's been any
violation but usually use a lot of
discretion
i would prefer we not even talk about
which senator spoke or how many spoke
and i think that we need to be careful
again doing that
i expect the senate will be in session
until approximately six we will confer
with the senators the leadership and
chief justice
and and see how the the discussions are
going and the speeches uh how many are
being made perhaps we would
wrap it up before that it just depend on
how much endurance we have today uh this
evening uh we will have a break from uh
12 until
about 1 15 an hour and 15 minutes for
the lunch
so that allow the chief justice in time
to
return to the
supreme court and then come back i
expect the senate to convene again
tomorrow at 10 a.m in order to try to
conclude the debate and vote on the
articles if at all possible by five
o'clock on thursday if we we're still
having speeches if we can't do it then
we would certainly just go over to
friday but i think we need to begin to
talk about that goal of five o'clock on
friday uh also i know that some senators
are still on the way here from committee
meetings uh there are only two or three
that were going on today but we didn't
give them much notice
that we were going to begin at 10 but we
are notifying everybody now that we will
come in at 10 tomorrow so that they will
go ahead and be able to take action this
morning
to cancel those hearings and be here
sharply at 10 o'clock
again we will alternate today
across the aisle
with the speakers
going for up to 15 minutes and and
senator inhofe
is scheduled to be our first uh speaker
today i'd be glad to yield to senator
coverdale
i asked unanimous consent to pose a
point of clarification to the majority
leader
without objection
mr leader uh
i'm i'm still a little confused about
this posting of a statement in the
record
is it possible
for
a member of the senate
to submit to the closed session their
statement rather than speaking i think
that might be desirable on the part of
some
i think the answer to that is yes you
can do that
the statement
in my sequence
to the record
and subsequently at my choice decide
whether it would be made part of the uh
congressional record subsequent to the
club that's correct
i think
and i would also say they would all
appear the same as if they had been
spoken or not right
mr chief justice with the distinguished
majority leader i'd be glad to you know
uh
mr mr chief justice and i appreciate the
courtesy of my good friend from
mississippi
i notice he has that there are a lot of
empty seats
here in the chamber and i realized that
at one time we thought we're coming at
noon could have committee meetings
the only time where
if these statements are not made in the
record the only time we're going to have
a chance to discuss with each other
uh what our thoughts are is in this
closed session by being here
um
i also think in respect to the chief
justice we should be doing that i'm
inclined i'd say to my friend from
mississippi
to suggest the absence of quorum i'm
withholding just for the moment to do
that
but if uh if we're going to be off at
committee meetings
i don't think
that
does service
to uh
to the intent of this closed-door
hearing
i would hope that both leaders
and i've discussed this with the
distinguished democratic leader too
would urge members to be here
um nothing could be more important
than this on our agenda today
and tomorrow
uh mischief justice i certainly agree
with that uh we are going to have to
have a momentary quorum just to get the
doors closed
and and then
officially go forward we will call and
make sure all the committee hearings are
being shut down
actually i think members are coming in
steadily and within a moment we're
probably going to have almost all the
senators here but we will take just a
couple of minutes to notify committees
to uh to complete their uh actions and
come on reporting
my friend mississippi and in concord
what he said i will not make that uh uh
suggestion
uh
knowing that he's going to make a
similar suggestion anyway will the
distinguished majority later yield i'd
be glad yeah
well
mr leader we're eager to get on with the
debate we have a quorum president
senator can make a point of order the
quorum is not present but it's obvious
to the naked eye that a quorum is
present
i think it's important for the record
that it be known that there are at least
60 to 70 members sitting in the chamber
ready to proceed
we have about 70 here and i'm sure we're
going to have
a full compliment here momentarily but
so we can
lock the doors and make sure that we
have a few more senators have a time to
get here i would have with the senator
from uh from alaska
miss chief justice may i ask for a
clarification relative to submitting
statements in the record
and having them printed what day
would they be printed in the record
assuming that we finish
thursday today friday which means it
would come out i guess the next day
so if we vote friday it would be if we
vote on friday then it would be
available i guess saturday morning
and if we vote thursday night it would
be available in the record friday
morning
thank you
mr chief justice i uh suggest absence of
court
do would the leader wish we go into
closed session before the queen
uh yes mr chief justice and then and
then suggest absolute reform
the senate will now resume closed
session for final deliberations on the
articles of impeachment
the clerk will call the roll
mr abraham
so again we'll let you know that while
the senate is going into closed session
our phone lines are going to remain open
throughout the entire day today at least
for the period all books
all weekend
every weekend
the u.s senate is returning now for what
could be the final day of the
impeachment trial after the opening
prayer this morning senators will hold a
brief public session to discuss the
plans for the day
then they will resume their final
deliberations on the articles of
impeachment and they'll do that in
closed session again each senator has up
to 15 minutes for a total of 25 hours
over these three days and while the
senate remains in that closed session
we'll show you live and taped reaction
to the trial and take your calls so what
we'll do now is look in on the brief
open portion of today's senate session
and then we're going to talk with a
journalist and then begin to take your
calls and watch events through the
entire day today this is live coverage
from the floor of the senate here on
c-span 2.
all right
oh
okay
um
so
are you ready
okay
um
thank you
okay
uh
sir
foreign
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
holy god who allows beginnings and
brings an end
a time for healing
a time to mend
we ask you to pour out your palpable
unifying power on the senate
today may the senators count on you more
than they count votes
this is a time neither for gloating over
victory nor grimness over losing
but rather a period for grief for all
that has brought us to this day
we are one nation under you
we repent as a nation
we turn from conditional ethics and seek
to return to the absolutes of your
commandments
thank you lord for the clarion
convictions
expressed during this trial by so many
senators of both parties
that morals do count and character does
count
may this shared common commitment
unite them as they lead this nation
now as their chaplain
i hold them all before your grace and
mercy
as their friend i intercede for their
spiritual strength and courage
and when the final votes are taken
hold them together in the oneness
america so desperately needs them to
exemplify
help them to model rectitude
and reconciliation
by your power
then the winner will be neither the
republicans nor the democrats
but the american people
in your holy name
amen amen
the sergeant-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton president of the
united states
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date the majority leader is recognized
this morning the senate will resume
final deliberations in closed session
our best guess at this time leaves
approximately 37 senators still
intending to speak
it's possible that we could conclude and
have the final votes this afternoon or
late this evening but i
don't think that's going to be possible
this time i'd like for us when we do
approach that
point that we do it in an orderly
fashion and one where
members and those that are interested
would be given notice
and that we have some business we would
have to conclude
also after all
the deliberations have been completed
but i'll confer throughout the day with
senator daschle we'll see how it goes
and then as soon as we
can see clearly when we would want to
actually move to the final vote we'd
notify all the senators and the public
we will also take a lunch break sometime
today between 12 and 12 30 and we will
have of course some breaks throughout
the the day
for to take
some refreshments i yield the floor to
allow the chief justice to close the
session
the senate will now go into closed
session for final deliberations on the
articles of impeachment the
sergeant-at-arms is directed to clear
the galleries and close the doors of the
senate chamber
mr chief
to prepare for the closed session so i
would suggest the absence of court
it's the final day of the senate
impeachment trial and our live coverage
is next
the day begins with a brief opening
session where majority leader trent lott
will outline today's schedule
and senators will continue their final
deliberations on the articles of
impeachment in a closed session
we understand that several senate
leaders will make their final speeches
then
and votes on those articles are
scheduled to take place at about 11 30
a.m eastern time
after the trial we may see a move toward
bringing a resolution of censure of the
president
after today's work congress begins a
week-long break
and throughout the day we'll take your
calls and show you live and tape
reaction to the trial live coverage of
the u.s senate next here on c-span 2.
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
gracious god
whose love for this nation has been
displayed so magnificently through our
history
we praise you that your presence fills
this historic chamber
and enters into the minds of the
senators gathered here
each of them is here by your divine
appointment
together they claim your promise
call upon me in the day of trouble
i will deliver you
we call upon you on this day of trouble
in america
as this impeachment trial comes to a
close
you have enabled an honest open debate
of alternative solutions
soon a vote will be taken
you have established a spirit of unity
in the midst of differences
most important of all
we know that we can trust you with the
results
you can use what is decided
and continue to accomplish your plans
for america
we entrust to your care the president
and his family
use whatever is decided today
to enable a deeper experience of your
grace in his life
and healing in his family
we commit this day to you
and thank you for the hope that fills
our hearts
as we place our complete trust in you
you are our lord
and savior
amen amen
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date
the majority leader is recognized thank
you mr chief justice
the information of all senators later on
today the secretary of the senate will
be putting at each senator's desk
something i think that you'll enjoy
reading later and it's the the prayers
of the chaplain during the impeachment
trial uh subsequently we plan to put it
in a small pamphlet because they have
truly been magnificent and we thought
you'd each like to have copies
uh the senate will resume the final
deliberations now in the closed session
thank goodness
uh at this point in the proceedings uh
there are approximately eight uh members
that will still wish to speak or submit
uh part of their uh speech into the
record and following those final
speeches the senate will resume open
session and proceed to the votes on two
articles of impeachment
i would estimate that those votes would
begin approximately
11 to 11 30
however the exact time will depend on
the length of the remaining speeches and
also we will uh have to have a few
minutes to open the uh the chamber and
the gallery so that uh our constituents
and our families can enter the gallery
if they'd like to
following those votes all senators
should remain at their desk as the
senate proceeds to several housekeeping
items relating to the adjournment of the
court of impeachment so again i
emphasize please after the vote
don't
rush out of the chamber because we have
some very important proceedings to
attend to and i think that you'll enjoy
them if you will will stay and
participate
under the consent agreement reached last
night following those votes a motion
relating to censure may be offered by
the senator from california senator
feinstein if offered senator graham will
be recognized to offer a motion relative
to the feinstein motion with a vote to
occur on the grammar motion
therefore senators may anticipate an
additional vote or votes following the
votes on the articles
i thank the senators and i believe we're
ready to proceed to the uh closed
session i'd be glad to hear i just
wondered will there be debate
intervening or no debate on on any of
those votes uh after uh in the uh uc
that was reached last night i believe we
have two hours
that will be equally divided for
senators to uh submit statements uh at
that point or to make speeches if they'd
like so i presume that would uh after
the uh the votes yeah and so that would
go on i presume for at least a couple
hours until two or three o'clock in the
afternoon yeah that was included before
proceeding in uh to close session i
would like to clarify one other matter
senators will recall the motion approved
february 9 1999 which permitted each
senator to place in the congressional
record his or her own statements made
during final deliberations in closed
session i asked consent that public
statements made by a senator subsequent
to approval of that motion with respect
to his or her statements made during the
closed session be deemed to be in
compliance with the senate rules this
would permit a senator to release to the
public his or her statement made during
final deliberations in closed session
except that in doing so a senator may
not disclose any remarks of the other
senators made during deliberations
without the prior consent of course of
that senator i would further ask consent
that senators have until tuesday
february 23rd
1999 and that would be i believe the
monday that we come back
uh is it tuesday tuesday after we come
back to insert statements and opinions
in the congressional record if they
choose explaining their votes finally
would ask consent that the senate
secretary be authorized to include these
statements along with the full record of
the senate's proceedings the filings by
the parties and the supplemental
material admitted into evidence by the
senate in a senate document printed
under the supervision of the secretary
of the senate that will be complete uh
that will complete the documentation of
the senate's handling of these
impeachment proceedings mr leader
a point of clarification i've had a
couple of members ask does it take an
affirmative act of a senator to get
their
speech placed in the record
or or does it happen automatically i
believe it does take an affirmative act
it's not automatic and who should that
information be given to them should that
be given it should be given to uh the
clerks the desk or to uh marty on your
side or or uh your secretary of the
minority and secretary of majority
they'll get it into the record at the
right place
further question mr leader
it does not require each person to ask
for unanimous consent to insert their no
no you can do it automatically that's
already been cleared uh i believe we
have unanimous consent requests
compounded but propounded without
objection it's so ordered all right the
senate will now go into closed session
to complete its deliberations on the
articles of impeachment the
sergeant-at-arms is directed to clear
the galleries and close the doors of the
senate chamber
mr chief justice i suggest the absence
of a quorum
the clerk will call the role
but i am judging the fact that he lied
to the american public he lied under
oath
and i don't believe that he's
fit to be our president
i appreciate being able to
mr chief justice
and the member of the senate
the senate has met almost exclusively as
a court of impeachment since january 7
1999
to consider the articles of impeachment
against the president united states
the senate meets today to conclude this
trial
by voting on the articles of impeachment
thereby fulfilling its obligation under
the constitution
i believe we are ready to proceed to the
vote on the articles and i yield the
floor
the chair would inform those in
attendance in the senate galleries
that under rule 19 of the standing rules
of the senate
demonstrations of approval or
disapproval are prohibited and it is the
duty of the chair to enforce order on
his own initiative the clerk will now
read the first article of impeachment
article one
in his conduct while president of the
united states
william jefferson clinton
in violation of his constitutional oath
faithfully to execute the office of
president of the united states and
to the best of his ability preserve
protect and defend the constitution of
the united states
and in violation of his constitutional
duty to take care that the laws be
faithfully executed
willfully corrupted and manipulated the
judicial process of the united states
for his personal gain and exoneration
impeding the administration of justice
in that
on august 17 1998
william jefferson clinton swore to tell
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth
before a federal grand jury of the
united states
contrary to that oath william jefferson
clinton willfully provided prejudice
false and misleading testimony to the
grand jury concerning one or more of the
following
one
the nature and details of his
relationship with a subordinate
government employee two
prior presirious false and misleading
testimony he gave in a federal civil
rights action brought against him
three
prior false and misleading statements he
allowed
his attorney to make to a federal judge
in that civil rights action
and for
his corrupt efforts to influence the
testimony of witnesses and to impede the
discovery of evidence in that civil
rights action
in doing this
william jefferson clinton has undermined
the integrity of his office
has brought disrepute on the presidency
has betrayed his trust as president
and has acted in a manner subversive of
the rule of law and justice to the
manifest injury of the people of the
united states
wherefore
william jefferson clinton by such
conduct warrants impeachment and trial
and removal from office and
disqualification to hold and enjoy any
office of honor trust or profit under
the united states
the chair reminds the senate that each
senator when his name or her name is
called
will stand in his or her place and vote
guilty or not guilty as required by rule
23 of the senate rules on impeachment
the chair also refers to article 1
section 3 clause 6 of the constitution
regarding the vote required for
conviction on impeachment quote no
person shall be convicted without the
concurrence of two-thirds of the members
present
the question is on the first article of
impeachment senators house say you
is the respondent william jefferson
clinton guilty or not guilty a roll call
vote is required the clerk will call the
roll
mr abraham
mr abraham
guilty
mr akaka
mr akaka
not guilty
mr allard
mr allard
guilty
mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft
guilty
mr
baucus
mr baucus not guilty
mr bye
mr bye
not guilty
mr
bennett mr bennett
guilty
mr biden
mr biden not guilty
mr bingaman
mr bingaman
not guilty
mr bond
mr bond guilty
mrs boxer
mrs boxer not guilty
mr bro
mr bro
not guilty
mr brownback
mr brownback
guilty
mr brian
mr brian not guilty
mr bunning
mr bunning
guilty
mr burns
mr burns
guilty
mr bird
mr bird not guilty
mr campbell
mr campbell guilty
mr chafee
mr chafee
not guilty
mr cleland
mr cleland not guilty
mr cochran
mr cochrane
guilty
ms collins
ms collins not guilty
mr conrad
mr conrad not guilty
mr
coverdale mr coverdale
guilty
mr craig
mr craig
guilty
mr crapo
mr crapo
guilty
mr daschle
mr daschle not guilty
mr dewine
mr dewine
guilty
mr dodd
mr dodd not guilty
mr domenici
mr domenici
guilty
mr dorgan
mr dorgan
not guilty
mr durbin
mr durbin not guilty
mr edwards
mr edwards not guilty
mr enzi
mr nz
guilty
mr feingold
mr feingold
not guilty
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein
not guilty
mr fitzgerald
mr
fitzgerald guilty
mr frist
mr frist
guilty
mr gorton
mr gorton
not guilty
mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida not guilty
mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas guilty
mr grahams of minnesota
mr grahams of minnesota
guilty
mr grassley
mr grassley guilty
mr greg
mr greg
guilty
mr hegel
mr hagel
guilty
mr harkin
mr harkin
not guilty
mr hatch
mr hatch
guilty
mr
helms mr helms guilty
mr hollings
mr hollings not guilty
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas guilty
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas guilty
mr
inhofe inhofe
guilty
mr in no way
mr in no way
not guilty
mr jeffords
mr jeffords not guilty
mr johnson
mr johnson not guilty
mr kennedy
mr kennedy
not
guilty
mr kerry of nebraska
mr kerry of nebraska not guilty
mr carey of massachusetts
mr carey of massachusetts not guilty
mr cole
mr cole not guilty
mr kyle
mr kyle
guilty
ms landrieu
ms landrieu not guilty
mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg not guilty
mr leahy
mr leahy
not guilty
mr levin
mr levin not guilty
mr
lieberman mr lieberman
not guilty
mrs lincoln
[Music]
mrs lincoln
not guilty
mr lot
mr lot
guilty
mr luger
mr luger guilty
mr mack
mr mack
guilty mr mccain
mr mccain
guilty
mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell
guilty
ms mikulski
ms mikulski
not guilty
mr moynihan
mr moynihan not guilty
mr murkowski
mr murkowski
guilty
mrs murray
mrs murray
not guilty
mr nichols
mr nichols
guilty
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island not guilty
mr reed of nevada
mr reed of nevada not guilty
mr robb
mr rob not guilty
mr roberts
mr roberts
guilty
mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller not guilty
mr roth
mr
roth guilty
mr santorum
mr santorum
guilty
mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes
not guilty
mr schumer
mr schumer
not guilty
mr sessions
mr sessions
guilty
mr shelby
mr shelby not guilty
mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire guilty
mr smith of oregon
mr smith of oregon
guilty
ms snow
ms snow
not guilty
mr spector
mr stevens
mr stevens not guilty
mr thomas
mr thomas
guilty
mr thompson
mr thompson
not guilty
mr thurman
mr thurmond
guilty
mr torricelli
mr torricelli
not guilty mr vornovich
mr voynovich
guilty
mr warner
mr warner
not guilty
mr wellstone
mr wellstone
not guilty
mr wyden
mr wyden
not guilty
um
oh
on this article of impeachment
45 senators having pronounced william
jefferson clinton president united
states guilty as charged
55 senators having pronounced him not
guilty
two-thirds of the senator's present not
having pronounced him guilty the senator
judges that the respondent william
jefferson clinton president of the
united states is not guilty as charged
in the first article of impeachment
the clerk will read the second article
of impeachment
article two
in his conduct while president of the
united states william jefferson clinton
in violation of his constitutional oath
faithfully to execute the office of
president of the united states and
to the best of his ability preserve
protect and defend the constitution of
the united states
and in violation of his constitutional
duty to take care that the new that the
laws be faithfully executed
has prevented obstructed and impeded the
administration of justice
and has to that end engaged personally
and through his subordinates and agents
in a course of conduct or scheme
designed to delay
impede cover up and conceal the
existence of evidence and testimony
related to a federal civil rights action
brought against him in a duly instituted
judicial proceeding
the means used to implement this course
of conduct or scheme included one or
more of the following acts
one
on or about december 17 1997
william jefferson clinton corruptly
encouraged a witness in a federal civil
rights action brought against him
to execute a sworn affidavit in that
proceeding
that he knew to be prejudious false and
misleading
two
on or about december 17 1997
william jefferson clinton corruptly
encouraged a witness in a federal civil
rights action brought against him
to give presurious false and misleading
testimony if and when called to testify
personally in that proceeding
three
on or about december 28 1997 william
jefferson clinton corruptly engaged in
encouraged or supported a scheme to
conceal evidence that had been
subpoenaed in a federal civil rights
action brought against him
four
beginning on or about december 7th 1997
and continuing through and including
january 14th 1998
william jefferson clinton and testified
intensified and succeeded in an effort
to secure job assistance to a witness in
a federal civil
rights action brought against him in
order to corruptly prevent the truthful
testimony of that witness in that
proceeding
at a time when the truthful testimony of
that witness would have been harmful to
him
five
on january 17 1998
at his deposition in a federal civil
rights action brought against him
william jefferson clinton corruptly
allowed his attorney to make a false and
misleading statements to a federal judge
characterizing an affidavit
in order to prevent questioning deemed
relevant by the judge
such false and misleading statements
were subsequently acknowledged by his
attorney in communication to that judge
six
on or about january 18th in january 20th
through 21st 1998
william jefferson clinton
related a false and misleading account
of events relevant to a federal civil
rights action
brought against him to a potential
witness in that proceeding
in order to corruptly influence the
testimony of that
witness seven
on or about january 21st 23rd and 26
1998
william jefferson clinton made false and
misleading statements to potential
witnesses in a federal grand jury
proceeding
in order to corruptly influence the
testimony of those witnesses
the false and misleading statements made
by william jefferson clinton were
repeated by witnesses to the grand jury
causing the grand jury to receive false
and misleading information
in all of this
william jefferson clinton
has undermined the integrity of his
office has brought disrepute on the
presidency
has betrayed his trust as president
and has acted in a manner subversive of
the rule of law and justice
to the manifest injury of the people of
the united states
wherefore
william jefferson clinton by such
conduct warrants impeachment and trial
and removal from office and
disqualification to hold and enjoy any
office of honor trust or profit under
the united states
the question is on the second article of
impeachment senators house say you is
the respondent william jefferson clinton
guilty or not guilty the clerk will call
the roll
mr abraham
mr abraham guilty
mr akaka
mr akaka not guilty
mr allard
mr allard guilty
mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft guilty
mr baucus
mr baucus
not guilty mr bai
mr bai
not guilty mr bennett
mr bennett
guilty
mr biden
mr biden not guilty
mr bingaman
mr bingaman
not guilty
mr bond
mr bond
guilty
mrs boxer
mrs boxer
not guilty
mr bro
mr bro
not guilty mr brownback
mr brownback guilty
mr brian
mr brian
not guilty mr bunning
mr bunning
guilty
mr burns
mr burns
guilty
mr byrd
mr byrd
not guilty mr campbell
mr campbell
guilty
mr chafee
mr chafee
not guilty mr cleland
mr cleland not guilty mr cochran
mr cochrane
guilty
ms collins
miss collins
not guilty
mr conrad
mr conrad
not guilty
mr coverdale
mr coverdell
guilty
mr craig
mr craig
guilty
mr crapo
mr crayfo guilty mr daschle
mr daschle
not guilty
mr dewine
mr dewine
guilty
mr dodd
mr dodd
not guilty mr domenici
mr domenici
guilty
mr dorgan
mr dorgan
not guilty
mr durbin
mr durbin
not guilty mr edwards
mr edwards
not guilty mr enzi guilty mr enzi
guilty
mr feingold
mr feingold not guilty
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein
not guilty
mr
mr fitzgerald
guilty
mr frist
mr frist
guilty
mr gorton
mr gorton
guilty
mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida
not guilty mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas
guilty
mr graham's in minnesota
mr graham's minnesota guilty mr grassley
mr grassley
guilty
mr greg
mr greg
guilty
mr hegel
mr
hegel guilty
mr harkin
mr harkin
not guilty
mr hatch
mr hatch
guilty
mr helms
mr helms guilty
mr hollings
mr hollings not guilty
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas
guilty mrs hutchinson of texas
mrs hutchinson of texas guilty mr inhofe
mr inhofe guilty
mr noah
mr noah
not guilty
mr jeffords
mr jeffords not guilty
mr johnson
mr johnson not guilty
mr kennedy
mr kennedy
not guilty
mr cary nebraska
mr kerry of nebraska not guilty mr kerry
of massachusetts
mr kerry of massachusetts not guilty
mr cole
mr cole
not guilty
mr kyle
mr kyle guilty
ms landrieu
ms landrieu
not guilty mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg not guilty mr leahy
mr leahy
not guilty mr levin
mr levin
not guilty mr lieberman
mr lieberman
not guilty
lincoln
mrs lincoln not guilty mr lot
mr lot
guilty
mr luger
mr luger
guilty
mr mack
mr mack
guilty
mr mccain
mr mccain
guilty
mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell
guilty
ms mikulski
ms mikulski
not guilty mr moynihan
mr moynihan
not guilty mr murkowski
mr murkowski
guilty
mrs murray
mrs murray
not guilty mr nichols
mr nichols
guilty
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island
not guilty
mr beat of nevada
mr reed of nevada not guilty mr robb
mr rob
not guilty mr roberts
mr roberts guilty
mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller not guilty
mr roth
mr roth guilty
mr santorum
mr santorum
guilty
mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes
not guilty
mr schumer
mr schumer
not guilty
mr sessions
mr sessions
guilty
mr shelby
mr session mr shelby
guilty mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire guilty
mr smith of oregon
mr smith of oregon
guilty
ms snow
mr spector
[Music]
mr specter not guilty mr stevens
mr stevens
guilty
mr thomas
mr thomas
guilty
mr thompson
mr thompson
guilty
mr thurman
mr thurman
guilty
mr torricelli
mr torres selly
not guilty mr voinovich
mr boinovich
guilty
mr warner
mr warner
guilty
mr wellstone
mr wellstone
not guilty mr wyden
mr wyden
not guilty
foreign
the galleries will be in order
on this article of impeachment 50
senators have pronounced william
jefferson clinton president united
states guilty as charged
50 senators have pronounced him not
guilty two-thirds of the senators
present not having pronounced him guilty
the senate adjudges that the respondent
william jefferson clinton president of
the united states is not guilty as
charged in the second article of
impeachment
the chair directs judgment to be entered
in accordance with the judgment of the
senate as follows
the senate having tried william
jefferson clinton president of the
united states upon two articles of
impeachment exhibited against him by the
house of representatives
and two-thirds of the of the senators
present not having found him guilty of
the charges contained therein it is
therefore ordered in a judge that the
said william jefferson clinton b and he
hereby is acquitted of the charges in
the said articles
the chair recognizes the majority leader
mr chief justice uh there's an order at
the desk
the clerk will read the order
ordered
that the secretary be directed to
communicate to the secretary of state
as provided by rule 23
of the rules of procedure and practice
in the senate when sitting on
impeachment trials and also to the house
of representatives
the judgment of the senate in the case
of william jefferson clinton
and transmit
a certified copy of the judgment to each
objection the order will be will be
entered
uh the chair wishes to make a brief
statement without objection i trust
uh more than a month ago i first came
here to preside over the senate sitting
as a court of impeachment
i was a stranger to the great majority
of you
i underwent the sort of culture shock
that naturally occurs when one moves
from the very structured environment of
the supreme court
to what i shall call for one of a better
phrase the more free-form environment of
the senate
i leave you now a wiser but not a sadder
man
i have been impressed by the manner in
which the majority leader and the
minority leader have agreed on
procedural rules in spite of the
differences that separate their two
parties on matters of substance
i have been impressed by the quality of
the debate in closed session on the
entire question of impeachment as
provided for in the constitution
agreed upon procedures for airing
substantive divisions must be the
hallmark of any great deliberative body
our work is a court of impeachment is
now done
i leave you with the hope
that our several paths may cross again
under happier circumstances
the majority leader
mr chief justice uh we thank you for
uh your comments and i i'll send a
resolution to the desk
the clerk will read the resolution
senate resolution 37
to express gratitude for the service of
the chief justice of the united states
as presiding officer during the
impeachment trial
mr chief justice i ask that it be
considered as having been read in its
entirety
the clerk without objection will read it
in its entirety and i ask unanimously
sent the senate proceed to the immediate
consideration of sres 37 introduced
earlier today
by senator lott and senator daschle
and that the resolution be adopted
without objection the resolution is
adopted i ask unanimous consent that the
resolution be agreed to the motion to
reconsider be laid upon the table and
any statements that senators wish to
make uh on this uh be printed at this
point in the record
mr chief justice
without objection and so ordered
on behalf of my myself and the entire
united states senate uh we want to offer
you our thanks and the gratitude
american people uh for your service to
the nation
and
throughout this uh impeachment court to
this institution
as our presiding officer during most of
the last five weeks you have brought our
proceedings a gentle dignity
and an unfailing sense of purpose and
sometimes a sense of humor
majority leader realized when it was uh
time to take a break and not to take a
break when the chief justice said let's
go forward
by placing duty above personal
convenience and many other
considerations you've taught a lesson in
leadership the presence of the chair
of the president of the senate following
the directives of our constitution gave
committee to this chamber and assurance
to the nation
i would like to close with our
traditional
mississippi par uh party you y'all come
back soon
but i hope that's not taken the wrong
way
and not for an occasion like this one so
instead as you return to your work on
the court in the great marble temple
of the law right across the lawn from
this capitol we salute you sir with
renewed appreciation
and esteem for a good friend and good
neighbor
and now mr chief justice if the
democratic leader will join you we have
a small token of our appreciation we
have a tradition in the senate
that after you've presided over the
senate for
100 hours
we present you with the golden gabble
award
and i'm not sure it quite reached 100
hours but it's close enough
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
mr chief justice i ask unanimous consent
that the february 5th 1999 affidavit of
mr christopher hitchens and the february
7th 1999 ava david of miss carol blue
and the affidavit of mr r scott
armstrong be admitted to evidence in
this proceeding that the full written
transcripts of the depositions taken
pursuant to s res 30 be included in the
public record of the trial at this point
this matter has been cleared on both
sides of the aisle without objection
it's so ordered
and now mr chief justice i move that the
senate
sitting as a court of impeachment on the
articles exhibited against william
jefferson clinton
adjourned shiny die
without objection the motion is agreed
to the senate sitting as a court of
impeachment stands adjourned signee die
and the escorts will go to the podium to
escort the chief justice from the
chamber
now
so
the sergeant-at-arms will escort the
house managers out of the senate chamber
here we
go great
this
mr president uh we do have the senate
will please come to order
mr majority leader uh
mr president i almost called you mr
chief justice
uh i have to get used to this uh going
back to mr president before senator
feinstein is recognized i must take just
a moment
further to recognize a few individuals
and i know senator daschle would like to
do that uh in addition to the chief
justice uh his assistant
leader
the white house attorneys have the same
privilege of being escorted out before
we take our business
i think we had asked senator nichols to
handle that
[Laughter]
the white house council will be escorted
from the chambers
[Music]
back at majority league zoom i want to
thank
the assistants that came with the chief
justice from the supreme court i want to
thank the secretary of the the senate uh
gary cisco the sergeant arms uh jim
ziegler and the deputy sergeant of arms
loretta sims who also gave us our
instructions for the first time in
history i'm sure that a woman
called
the senate to order i'd like to thank
the secretary of the majority elizabeth
ledgeworth
the council of the the senate tom
griffith and the deputy morgan frankel
our special impeachment council mike
wallace my chief of staff dave hoppe who
has just
been tremendous and and worked untold
hours
and also
all of our assistants at the desk and
especially our friend scott bates for
their wonderful work i wanted the record
to reflect how much we appreciate the
dedication the long hours the patience
and and the competence of all these
staff members i'd like to yield to
senator daschle for his comments in this
area the democratic leader mr president
i know i speak for all of my colleagues
on this side of the aisle and
sharing the
expressions of gratitude that senator
lott has just articulated for all of our
staff they have done a remarkable job
uh he mentioned uh
all those who work for all of us let me
mention a couple of people who work for
those of us on this side bob bauer bill
core
pete rouse
marty paoni and so many people that are
particularly responsible for
the fact that we are able to conduct our
work so
effectively throughout this very
difficult challenge so
on behalf of the democratic caucus we
join with senator lott and expressing
our deep sense of gratitude for the
great great job that they've done in
these difficult weeks that we've now
concluded
i yield the floor
the
chair recognizes the sender from rhode
island i wonder if this isn't an
appropriate time to express our
appreciation to our two leaders for
guiding us through these very very
difficult times
[Applause]
mr president the chair recognizes the
senator from california mr president i
move to proceed to my center resolution
which is at the desk
senator the senator from texas mr
president i have to object this
resolution is not on the calendar and
therefore it is not in order to present
it to the senate
mr president the senator from california
mr president in light of that objection
i moved to suspend the rules the notice
of which i printed in the record on
monday february 8th in order to permit
my motion to proceed
the senator from texas mr president i
send a motion to the dest motion to
indefinitely postpone the consideration
of the feinstein motion
the clerk will report the motion
further reading of the motion be
dispensed with and i ask for the yays
and the nays
is there sufficient second there is
sufficient second the a's and days have
been requested the clerk will call the
roll
mr abraham
mr
akaka mr allard
stephens
are you going to agree to age congress
27 yeah this is going to happen later mr
ashcroft
mr baucus
mr bai
mr bennett
please maintain order so that the clerk
can hear the answer to the roll call
mr biden
mr bingham
mr bond
mrs boxer
[Music]
mr bro
mr
brownback mr brian
mr bunning mr burns
mr bird
ramsay
nope
mr campbell
why do you know
belief
mr chafee
this is emotionally
mr cochran
mr cleland
ms collins
uh
mr conrad
mr coverdale
mr craig
mr daschle
it is because my unanimous consent is
required normally it is not here
normally it only takes a majority
mr dewine mr dodd
mr domenici
mr dorgan mr durbin mr
it's good to get edwards to the old way
here
mr enzi
mr fitzgerald mrs feinstein
senate will please
be in order
mr frist
mr gorton mr graham of florida mr graham
of texas
sure
mr grams of minnesota mr grassley mr
greg mr hegel mr harkin
mr hollings
mr hutchinson of arkansas mrs hutchison
of texas mr inhofe
mr in nowhere mr jeffords mr johnson mr
kennedy mr carey of nebraska mr carey of
massachusetts
mr cole mr kyle
ms landrieu mr lautenberg mr leahy mr
levin mr lieberman
mrs lincoln mr lott
foreign
mr luger
mr mack
mr mccain mr mcconnell
ms mikulski mr moynihan
mr murkowski mrs murray mr nichols mr
reed of rhode island mr reed of nevada
mr robb mr roberts mr rockefeller
mr schumer mr sessions
mr shelby
mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of oregon ms snow
mr specter
mr stevens
mr thomas
mr thompson mr thurman mr torricelli mr
vornovich
mr warner mr wellstone mr wyden
senators voting in the affirmative
allard ashcroft bond brownback bunning
burns bird campbell
cochran coverdale craig crapo dewine
enzi fitzgerald frist
grams of minnesota grassley greg
hegel hatch helms hutchinson of arkansas
inhofe kyle
mack
mccain murkowski
nichols roberts santorum sessions shelby
smith of new hampshire specter stevens
thomas thompson thurmond bornovich and
warner
senators voting in the negative
abraham akaka baucus bai
bennett
biden
bingaman
boxer
bro
brian
chaffee cleland conrad daschle dodd
dorgan durbin edwards feingold feinstein
gordon graham of florida
harkin hollings
hutchison
hutchison
hutchison of texas
in a way
jeffords johnson kennedy kerry of
nebraska
kerry of massachusetts cole landrieu
lautenberg leahy levin lieberman lincoln
mcconnell mikulski moynihan murray reed
of rhode island reed of nevada rob
rockefeller roth
sarbanes schumer
smith of oregon snow
toricelli wellstone and wyden
mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas i
ms collins
miss collins i
miss collins
no
mr luger
mr luger no
mr lott
mr lot aye
uh
where is it
wow
so
so
two-thirds not having voted in the
negative
the motion to suspend is withdrawn and
the graham's point of order is sustained
in the feinstein motion to proceed false
that can we go to the opposite way the
vote on this was the ias were 43 the
nays were 56. vice president uh
majority leader we recessed subject to
call the chair
that objections to order
[Applause]
foreign
so
he says